and sheila jackson lee of texas
and that's a look at the program
schedule
now the waco investigation
a house joint subcommittee hearing on
the sixth day of testimony on events at
waco texas in the spring of 1993
in april of that year 80 branch
davidians died during a fire at their
compound
among those branch davidian leader david
koresh
today's witnesses include fbi agents and
officials from the environmental
protection agency
we begin with congressman bill mccullum
of florida co-chairman of the joint
house subcommittee
these hearings of the joint
subcommittees on the waco matter will
come to order
this morning we're going to have the
usual short opening statements from the
four principal uh chairman and ranking
members and then we're going to go
immediately to our first panel that was
kicked over from
yesterday as you know
we now have begun the first of what will
be five days of hearings we've not
intended to meet tomorrow but because of
the day and the delays yesterday we are
going to be forced to hear from a panel
that was scheduled to be later this
afternoon tomorrow and we will do that
we will then again meet on friday and on
monday and hopefully we will conclude
these hearings at that time
our attention now turns to the fbi the
department of justice
during an appearance on 60 minutes in
may attorney general reno said words to
the effect that there had been in her
judgment no mistakes that warranted
taking action against any of the parties
involved in the fbi in the raid and in
the assault and the siege
we're here to learn
and to corroborate or to deny that
particular statement and assertion
essentially what we want to do is try to
review as carefully as we can
what happened in that 51 day siege and
what happened in the assault
we need to know the background and we
need to know the conclusions and reasons
for those conclusions
in the decision-making process that led
to the use of cs gas and led to the use
of force in the final assault instead of
continuing the negotiations i think
that's really the heart
of what this is all about at this
juncture
yesterday we had some tough criticisms
lodged with respect to this by the two
attorneys who represented
leading figures in the matter
of those davidians who are were killed
and in the compound at mount carmel
during that final assault
mr de garan in particular who was the
attorney for
the
late david korish said to us yesterday
that he believed as did mr zimmerman who
was with him that had there been just
about 10 more days of negotiations they
were absolutely convinced that there
would have been a surrender that courage
would have come out
and there was a basis for it that made
this particular negotiation
at this particular time that was going
on just preceding the assault fruitful
as opposed to those where corey had
indicated he would surrender earlier and
did not they were very compelling in
that testimony as to why they felt that
was so
they spent a lot of time going over with
us the details of their reasoning and
how they got to that point in fact they
asserted that a deal had been made in
essence in their mind
and that they could not believe it when
the assault actually took place they
were convinced that some of you at the
table today on our first panel
were equally aboard with them in this
final negotiation and that there was a
general consensus that movement had been
made and a very significant movement
and we're here today in part to explore
why perhaps there is a difference of
opinion on that or maybe there is not we
don't know
there also was a concern expressed that
because they couldn't believe that those
who were involved in the negotiations
and in the operation in the field
had
changed or had lied to them as they put
it
they felt very strongly that it must
have been a washington bureaucrat i
think as mr zimmerman put it who
overrode the surrender plan or surely
this would not have occurred
because they they felt very betrayed
otherwise
in this process
then we heard yesterday evening from two
experts in religion
doctors tabor and arnold who agreed with
the challenge
that had been presented earlier in the
day
they believe that koresha had not broken
all of his promises during the
negotiations and walked through a an
explanation
of his psyche if you will
with respect to how he came to each step
of his decision-making process and why
they believe very strongly that based
upon analysis of his religious views and
his convictions that he was indeed
prepared to come forward when this
tragic event occurred on april the 18th
it was their conclusion in a very
elaborate discussion that he had come to
himself on this through this process
that was unique to his interpretation of
the seven seals in the book of
revelations and that had he been
permitted to fulfill the
the contract if you will that he thought
he had made with regard to surrender on
this occasion he would have done so
there was a lot of discussion late last
night when we kept the panel here until
11 o'clock or so about the details of
that and particularly about the positive
reinforcement that dr tabor saw in the
the attitude of courage and the fact
that he had some reason to come out at
that point something he was really
wanting to do at that juncture they also
pointed to the tapes that had been
played
that we didn't get to hear but hear
openly and hearing simply because we're
not playing tapes but were given to us
and some others have heard them of the
last few days of discussions with david
korish in which they say that this was
corroborated that inside the compound
over the last couple of days there was
joy there was clear indication by all
the members of the davidians that they
were coming out and they were happy
about it and they really believed that
they were coming out uh once uh courage
finished writing his interpretation of
the
the seals well at any rate that's what
we heard yesterday we also heard at that
time from
about concerns over the pressure tactics
that were used by the fbi uh the fact
that most all the witnesses yesterday
did not believe those were appropriate
in fact were negative and that in fact
the use of the cs gas at the end
actually was fulfilling the doomsday
prophecy that pushed would have pushed
koresh over the edge that they had
convinced him or he had been convinced
that indeed his original assumption
about the fifth seal
was wrong that it wasn't his time to
have armageddon if you will or to die
but rather that it was his time to to
prophesy but that when the
if last assault was made he became and
would have become a normal course of
understanding this convinced that it was
all over that he was indeed destined
to be the one who who met
the day of judgment there so to speak
now
in addition we heard
some words that we were not going to
rehash today about the shots and who
fired first i think frankly when you get
done with it i'd like to tend to believe
as most would i think the atf officers
and those involved
that the shots first came from inside
the compound but we did hear the
attorneys yesterday who are eyewitnesses
to some of the actual bullet holes say
they were
absolutely certain that shots came from
without
that came through the roof of the
building
there has been no logical explanation to
corroborate that because no one has been
able to tell us in any way of these
hearings that the helicopters had fired
or that they had the equipment on them
to make those kind of bullet holes on
the other hand there's no logical
explanation
for why the holes would have come
through the roof as these attorneys
described them yesterday from their own
visual inspection
if they did not come from the
helicopters
on the other hand we also had them
saying that there were bullet
marks in the front door and missing door
we had some explanation about that but
it was as they said themselves
unsatisfactory and inconclusive
and rather than criticized the issue of
the who shot first they suggested that
we
be more appointed and concerned about
the raid plan to begin with
we heard tough words from the texas
rangers they believe that the fbi should
have used them in dealing with courage
and that courage may have surrendered to
them based on comments korish made
they also challenged the point which
we'll talk about tomorrow at length that
no other specialized law enforcement
unit could have replaced the fbi's
highly trained hostage rescue team for a
short duration ahead they needed to fall
back to regroup and retrain
in order to continue
the siege that was on at the time the
final assault was made
and last but not least the texas rangers
made it very clear to us that after
their criminal investigation
they came to the conclusion that two atf
officers cereben and hanosky should be
prosecuted for false statements are
lying and apparently they have
recommended that to the attorney general
i do not know where that stands
so today we come
forward with the status that we're in
with our witness panel that will be
discussing the issue with respect to
what actually happened from the fbi's
perspective
and how we got into this whole matter
after they assumed the role of the lead
agency
for the 51 day siege but before we do
that i want to yield to mrs thurman for
any opening comment she may have and
then to mr zello and mr schumer
thank you mr chairman and um
let me welcome you all and i certainly
do appreciate the fact that you've uh
stayed over an extra day and you
probably will be better served than if
you would have been here at uh one
o'clock this morning so we do appreciate
the fact that you have come back again
today
clearly the decision to try after
waiting 51 days to force david fresh and
his followers to surrender peacefully to
authorities was a difficult one today we
will begin to examine the process by
which the introduction of tear gas into
the compound was planned and approved
yesterday we spent the morning and the
afternoon listening to mr zimmerman
lawyer for steve schneider a resident of
the branch davidian compound and dick
the guerin the attorney for david kresh
i think the one thing we can all agree
on is that mr zimmerman and mr degueran
are very good defense attorneys as our
colleague from houston ms sheila jackson
lee pointed out in her introduction of
her fellow texans to the subcommittee
yesterday
the fact of the matter is that both mr
zimmerman and mr daguerreon said
yesterday that they were clearing their
calendars because they were preparing to
go to court on behalf of their clients
yesterday was perhaps their only chance
to present their clients case in a
public forum
however i would like to point out some
facts that they may have that may have
been blurred by mr zimmerman's and mr
tagaran's testimony first i believe it
was well documented that david fresh was
teaching his supporters to follow its
final prophecy we heard from that from
carrie jewell dr bruce perry joyce
sparks and robert rodriguez the notion
that kresh would have surrendered
peacefully at any time is simply not
supported in his actions in addition the
evidence of child abuse including sexual
abuse by koresh has also been undisputed
if kerry jewell's testimony wasn't
enough and surely the testimony of joyce
sparks who spent hour upon hour talking
to the children should convince any way
that koresh was both capable and willing
to commit crimes against children
remember even koresha's defense attorney
admitted quresh was worried about facing
child abuse
charges last night we began our
investigation into the negotiation
process we heard that the fbi consulted
with a range of experts mr mcclure a
recognized negotiation expert from
atlanta stated that it was necessary to
use only trained negotiators in
dangerous seed situations that is what
the fbi did this is consistent with the
effective negotiation strategy
on the issue of cs gas i think we can
characterize the decision to use cs gas
as a way of peacefully
ending the standoff as one of the many
hard choices that faced the fbi during
the 51 day standoff there were no easy
answers would additional time in the
negotiation process
process have altered the ultimate
outcome i do not believe so once again
we have taken very compelling testimony
that clearly demonstrates quresh
desperately needed to fulfill his own
fiery destiny
it is important to remember that
negotiations with quresh and the
davidians had broken down
no progress in negotiations had been
made for two weeks prior to the decision
to tear gas the compound the plan was
for gradual insertion of the gas and the
fbi even informed the davidians that
they were going to use tiercast to bring
them out of the compound even after
being warned about the impending gas the
davidians opened fire on the fbi and the
fbi did not return the fire we will
examine
the other options available to the fbi
and the department i think it will be
useful to examine these other options
within the context of the entire
standoff however the fact is that the
tear gas is used routinely by law
enforcement i would implore all the
members of the joint subcommittees to
listen carefully to all of the testimony
we will receive over the next few days
regarding the us the use of cs gas to
end the standoff at waco i for one am
not ready to pass judgment until i hear
all of the relevant facts and
considerations and weigh them within the
context of the situation at waco once
again i remind my colleagues of our
mission proper oversight by way of all
the facts thank you mr chairman and i
will yield back the balance of my time
thank you mr thurman mr zeller
every day we
have received
much new information as to what happened
at waco yesterday alone we learned of
new surrender efforts that seem to have
borne promise but gotten dismissed or
preempted by the fbi cs gas plane
in this regard we heard from two
well-respected lawyers for the davidians
one a former military judge who had
visited the compound just days before it
burned
we also heard from the widely respected
texas rangers who collaborated portions
of the lawyer's testimony and spoke of
their respect
for one of these lawyers in particular
we also learned that negotiators were
making progress before their efforts
came to a fiery end
on april 14 a corner seems to have been
turned a willingness on the part of
david koresh to come out
but on april 19th there is the gas the
fire and then the ultimate tragedy
new ground has been broken during the
first five days of these marathon
hearings we have dug deeply into
everything from the initial
investigation and sufficiency of the
warrant to botch planning botched raid
execution approvals and the treasury
report
today we'll hear from the negotiators
themselves people on the scene we'll
also hear from other witnesses that many
have waited for the experts on the cs
gas its toxicity its risk and its uses
these expert experts are of all stripes
my guess is that today's testimony will
be lively say the least
as we move into the tragic days and
hours before the deadly fire i think
there will be a quickening of the tempo
these are the days and the hours when if
different decisions had been made we
would not all now be talking about the
loss of over 80 american lives
including 22 innocent children
some key questions are what was the
fbi's massive strategy
how was it conceived and by whom
and when was the cs gas included in the
plan was it in the plan before april
14th when the fbi tells lawyers for the
davidians that they have lots of time to
reach a negotiated closure
or was it afterwards who accelerated the
use of the cs
on that fateful day april 19th
who decided to inject it into the
compound with the tanks and then to
crash down the walls with the tanks and
then they insert cs gas by coke bottle
size ferret rounds or projectiles
350 of them who approved all of this
and when the facts are out who gave the
final go-ahead the top sign-off and on
what information
constitutional oversight is not always
enjoyable
we certainly have been in these hearings
for stretches of 11 12 and 13 hours
straight over the past five days but as
the people of this nation that we serve
we serve them and not the other way
around
if the search for the truth is what it's
all about there's no place for shortcuts
politics or partisan exchanges
that has occurred and that's regrettable
but we need to stay
focused and this is critical
i guess as i drove into work listening
to some tapes last night and this
morning
the scary thing that i'm trying to deal
with is that the fact that over 80
americans were killed
and i have a tremendous respect for the
fbi as do most americans i have a
tremendous respect for our military
and the question that is eating away at
me with all the evidence that we will be
seeing and have seen
was a military style operation justified
could we have done a better job of
listening and could this tragedy have
been avoided
were there different alternatives and
why were they rejected
that's what these hearings are all about
getting at the truth so that we can
change further events
no one is above the law and
accountability and responsibility must
be assigned in order to restore
responsibility accountability must be a
a sign in order to restore credibility
that's what we're trying to do here we
have total respect for what you do day
in and day out
we want to make sure that that
credibility is maintained for many many
years to come thank you mr chairman
thank you mr zoella mr schumer
thank you mr chairman i want to thank
also join in thanking the witnesses for
waiting another day
and i think today will be well let me
start with yesterday i've never really
sat through a hearing the way the likes
of yesterday six and a half hours of
defense lawyers no rebuttal no one on
the other side etc yesterday was the
most unbalanced day we've had in the
waco hearings so far
and i think it was unfortunate that it
occurred
the domination by one-sided um
defense lawyers their marathons their
ways of sliding over the truth
was very unfortunate
they called a man who hoarded illegal
guns and hand grenades peaceful
they smeared a brave young woman who
testified to a rape by david koresh they
said they didn't believe her
and they imp they even implied that the
davidians were justified in killing atf
agents by launching theories of
self-defense
you know ladies and gentlemen
their basis for this
was looking at bullet holes and doors
well let me tell you i'd rather have the
eyewitnesses to the bullets than
eyewitnesses to bullet holes any day of
the week
again the fast and looseness of with the
truth will be revealed today one of the
key points yesterday was mr zimmerman's
testimony that some faceless washington
bureaucrat
stopped mr jamar
from going along with the zimmerman plan
well we'll learn frankly today that that
person doesn't exist i asked mr
zimmerman about it i asked if he had a
name he said no
i asked him if he had any evidence that
mr jamar was overruled no
but in the defense lawyer way just throw
it out there confuse things
and
see what happens well we'll ask mr jamar
today
and we'll find out his answer whether
washington overruled him
again uh more
um
more sliding over the truth
and finally this idea of the fbi having
hand grenades not flash bangs but hand
grenades that mr de garan seem to
support
no one i can speak to and i spoke to a
lot of members who are experts on
military and on fbi the other side no
one i can speak to would have would
think it even closely credible
that the fbi would use hand grenades in
the attack
furthermore the pineapple style of
grenades that koresh had
didn't look like flashbangs and finally
coup de gras mr de guerin said
flashbangers can kill injure maim
anyone who knows anything about these
things knows they can't in fact their
typical use is on an airliner when
there's a terrorist to roll them down
the aisle admit the passengers so
they'll make a big noise divert the
terrorists and
be used that can't be a harmful type of
act of thing
so today we're going to hear convincing
reputations of the line of baloney
put out by mr zimmerman and mr de guerin
and i want to say when my colleagues
from the other side give credibility by
saying for instance that mr korres
seemed willing to come out based on
testimony of his defense lawyers i think
they're stretching credibility
altogether it clearly doesn't make the
case
now
one other thing i'd like to say here
we're hearing a lot of talk in opening
statements how everyone is defending law
enforcement and certainly law
enforcement should be criticized when
they're wrong but certain other things
go over the line as well
one member of the other side while
professing to defend law enforcement
passed out a flyer promoting the theory
of justifiable homicide
justifiable homicide saying that the
davidians had right to shoot
to me that's disgraceful you cannot say
out of one side of your mouth you're
defending law enforcement and out of the
second side say that just that this was
a case of justifiable homicide so let's
stop this kind of baloney total baloney
as to who shot first well there's not
one sin till of credible evidence to
support the theory that
the atf shot first we heard that from
the texas rangers there were three
reporters on the scene each of whom
testified at the trial that the
davidians fired first all of the agents
testified that the davidians shot first
and kathy schroeder testified at her
trial that an ambush was laid that
morning
excuse me
once again i want to compliment my
colleague bill mccollum who said today
that he was convinced that the atf did
not fire first that koresh did but that
is after the cow is out of the door barn
in other words it's floating out there
all this talk all these theories and
again i have to repeat my fear that to
the handful of americans who are
paranoid
and have views that the government is
the incarnate of evil
that kind of irresponsible statement
is very harmful to all americans and
last
today
we're going to hear the beginnings of
what happened with the gas
the myth of the horrible cs gas will be
deflated by experts today
like so many other accusations puffed up
before these hearings the experts will
show that although cs gas is hardly a
pleasant experience it was not an
unreasonable choice in the light of all
the other factors thank you mr chairman
you're quite welcome mr schumer i i do
because you use my name just want to
clarify one thing about what i said
regarding the shooting and who shot
first
i just was implying which is true that
if i were sitting on a jury listening to
the witnesses based on my assessment of
credibility i would undoubtedly come
down after this stage
at this point on the side of the atf
just on the weight of evidence but i
would say and i do want to make this
clear that there are reasons which have
been given before us
for some who will continue to say and i
can understand why they would that they
have doubts about who shot first i don't
i think reasonable people could differ
in coming to the conclusions they would
come
on that point in other words i don't
think we'll ever have any absolutely
definitive
evidence of who shot first that will
satisfy everybody involved so that's
really what i had in mind with that and
i'm going to at this point for the
opening round of well i'm not going to
open with anybody i'm going to introduce
the witnesses somebody punched me to
introduce somebody uh we've got to a
panel today
i'm going to introduce you then after i
do so we need to swear you in and then
we'll commence the questioning first of
all not necessarily although i guess we
are in the order on this list today some
days we don't have that order quite the
same as the seat seating arrangement
uh peter smerrick is a former fbi
special agent was a criminal
investigative analyst with the
investigative support unit of the
national center for the analysis of
violent crimes our first witness today
jim cavanaugh is a special agent with
the bureau of alcohol tobacco farms he
was president waco on february 28 and
began the negotiations with the
davidians following the failed raid
byron sage is the supervisory special
resident agent in charge of the fbi's
austin office he was one of the first
fbi agents on the scene at mount carmel
on february 28 and was the fbi's lead
negotiator during the 51 days standoff
gary nauser is a supervisory special
agent at the fbi academy in quantico
virginia he was one of two negotiator
negotiation supervisors during the
standoff in waco
and jeffrey jamar was the special agent
in charge of the fbi san antonio office
he was the overall commander of the fbi
personnel during the siege at mount
carmel also with us on this panel
because he could not join us this
afternoon and was scheduled to do so is
mr ronald mccarthy a former is a former
officer with the los angeles police
department who is here with us as well
i would like to ask this panel to stand
if you would and be sworn in you raise
your right hand
do you swear or affirm that the
testimony you're about to give should be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth
please be seated let the record reflect
that all the witnesses answered in the
affirmative and i recognize for the
first round of questioning mr klinger
let me just say before i yield my time
that uh
john from new york was very hard and
defense attorneys and
suggested there was a lot of sliding
over the truth i would just suggest the
gentleman new york makes a pretty good
defense attorney himself in that he has
stressed uh certain elements of the
testimony and tend to downplay other
elements of the testimony
if there were in fact perjury committed
the gentleman who testified yesterday
were under oath and i think we should
have a uh find out if in fact there were
untrue stated in the testimony yesterday
at this point i'd like to yield the
balance of my time to the gentleman of
north carolina mr heinemann
thank you mr klinger
let me say
at the opening of today's hearings
that
where i will take part in that and
questioning the panel
i have over the course of my law
enforcement
years had the the pleasure of working
with not only atf
but with the fbi in
in on many occasions
i i see mr nesner here who 12 years ago
13 years ago came to raleigh north
carolina to
to assist me in a in a highly emotional
hostage situation which took place
over a full weekend 72 hours and i would
have to say that
that that was one of the highlights of
my career as it relates to working
in the joint effort with the fbi and uh
and i say that now and i've said that
for the past 13 years and
and i don't generally pass out a lot of
compliments but uh mr messner welcome
it's good to see you here today
what i'd like to do with my opening is
just to lay a foundation
from
february to 28th up to april 19th
so that we can have a chronology and
know where the pieces fit
and with that i'd like to ask mr
cavanaugh
who
is from atf was on the scene in fact was
in that observation house
as the raid took place
if you can tell us today
from that point where you knew you were
in trouble
what happened to the point where you
called for fbi if you in fact were the
one that did call for fbi
well chief um
we were
we were in an unbelievable situation
i hope you can understand it
it's not a good memory for me
i had 75 agents
stretched out in front of me
i had a box seat
and when we drove up
the davidians opened fire
and
i'm sickened by any other assertion
i sat there and i watched it
and the gunfire came through those
double white doors i watched it
it pushed the doors against
their jams out toward the agents
and in fact two agents were shot there
jerry petrilli was shot in the chest in
his vest and knocked down i think the
other witness bellesteros was also
hearing he was shot in the finger
it's unbelievable but that's what
happened
and anybody else who says anything
different they shot first and if i
thought that an atf agent would drive up
in front of a structure and shoot i'd
throw my badge in the garbage it didn't
happen
but anyway we were we were taking an
awful beating chief
they were throwing everything at us and
their guns sound like cannons
and our guns sound like pop guns
we had nine millimeters they were
hitting us with 223
ak-47s 50 calibers but
it was more than you can imagine
nobody was going to get us out
the clinton county sheriff's office who
always did a good job in this case could
not get us out of this
we couldn't call 9-1-1 i mean we
couldn't call anybody we had to get out
of this ourselves
so many men were hurt and wounded and
were laying down there
that i had a call
i called in the compound
i am a trained negotiator it just was my
first negotiation
and i called in the compound
and i
fell answered the phone he said hello
i said in a calm voice this is jim
kavanagh from atf
i want to speak to david
well the fella didn't even answer he
just dropped the phone and ran away i
could hear him running down the hallway
i could hear the machine guns inside
echoing through the phone and i could
hear him outside and watch him shooting
our agent
in a few minutes
a person came the phone
uh it was stephen schneider
and he started screaming through the
phone for us to get off the property
that we had no right to be there
to get off the property immediately
i tried to stay calm i used a calm voice
i said steve we have to talk we have to
work this out you and i have to work
this out
people are dying people are hurt we need
to stop the shooting
he was very charged as you can imagine
he was very excited he didn't want to
listen he just wanted to say get off the
property get off the property
we talked we kept trying to reassure him
he wanted to know what we were doing
there i told him we were federal
officers we had a search warrant
but i i wanted him to work out with me a
ceasefire
and
he agreed to talk about it
once i got him a little bit calmed down
he agreed to a ceasefire after a few
minutes more of
coaxing him
and then he just said okay you have the
cease-fire now
i said well there's a wounded agent
we had already tried to get our wounded
agent who was trapped
in an alcove back there next to the
tower agent kenny king
we tried to move a team to get him
but they just opened up on us
we couldn't get him
can you change that can you change that
that
that photo that blow up photo there to
to the
you should be on mr heinemann
microphone yes i don't think is it on
yes do you have those those pictures of
the
compound can you bring that
and show us the first picture
with the atf agents behind vehicles
we looked at this yesterday and
i questioned the
the two
lawyers that were here and they were in
agreement
that the atf was in the defensive
position
that they had not rushed the door
and they did agree that there were shots
coming from inside that compound through
the door
and i think if
i think if we can focus on that picture
we can see that atf
still running to get behind the vehicles
one officer grabbing for his gun which
was apparently hosted
and there's another picture right behind
that if you can show that
of atf agents on the ground
some being carried from
their position dragged over that had to
be
that had to be the next frame or the
frame after
and
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i can clear that up for you that is a
much uh
misrepresentation of the facts
as you look at that that first picture
that was shown there is very early in
the gun fight and that was taken by
reporters who were in the bar ditch
next to the undercover house we didn't
take that photograph that that was very
early in the gunfight you can see
there's no bullet holes in the walls you
can see the agents are just taking cover
in positions you can see all the windows
are slightly open and that's where we've
taken fire the next picture as it was
presented as being uh here's all the
bullet holes that's three hours later
we didn't achieve a ceasefire to
retrieve those wounded just a few
minutes before one o'clock i achieved it
i remember
that's three hours later of course
there's a lot of bullet holes in the
wall they were shooting us
and the peop the davidians were standing
in those windows back from the windows
because our long rifles then were
keeping them back and they were shooting
through the through the walls down at
our people laying on the ground that's
what all that gunfire is
i'm sure there's some return rounds from
atf because we were laying on the ground
hiding behind trucks and shooting at
them
well i see i see i have
i have the red light and i like to pick
up this line of questioning
when i have my next five minutes thank
you
mr schumer you're recognized for five
minutes thank you and again mr cavanaugh
i want to thank you i mean
i can't have the same emotion you do
having sat through this but i think i
share your frustration as i did mr
buford and mr balosteros hearing this
kind of
either or well some is right how do you
feel when you hear some people even on
this panel sort of saying well
it's unclear who fired first
congressman i respect congress and
the rights to ask those questions
but
i know they get that information from
people and
i'm just sickened by it it wouldn't be
allowed in the court of law it's not the
facts
we didn't shoot first we didn't
and is there any way that somebody could
believe that justifiable homicide as the
lawyer sort of implied yesterday and as
a leaflet was passed out by one of my
colleagues here today yes late last
night could be used as a defense here
no mr schumer i think what needs not to
be forgotten here
that this man was alerted to law
enforcement's arrival 45 minutes that
was our mistake that we went
he knew law enforcement was coming
and our paradigm if you will our mistake
was that we thought that that compound
would bristle with guns
that he would be defiant that he would
get his mighty men and be defiant
not to let law enforcement come on that
property
and he was so diabolical
that he laid an ambush
i've heard some of the members say
yesterday how could anyone shoot through
a door
watch the films every american seen him
100 times our agent on the roof the
bullets coming through the walls the
bullets coming through the ceilings
they shot through the doors they shot
through the ceilings
assertions that we had helicopters or
men from mars shooting at them as
nonsense
our agents were laying on the ground
shooting at a tower three stories high
should we be surprised there's bullets
in the roof of course i agree with you
i'm sorry thank you
i just have a few questions from mr
jamar because mr jamar we heard mr
zimmerman's
tale yesterday and that's what i would
call it uh about a well the tail part is
the washington bureaucrat but so let me
first ask you this question
in rejecting
mr
zimmerman's plan and mr koresh's plan
to leave did you make that decision
yourself or were you overruled by a
washington a shame shameless i think was
the adjective
baseless washington bureaucrat i think
to better understand it let me describe
how our relationship started and how it
came to april i'm going to ask you that
at the i'm going to give you a chance a
little later in the questioning
if you could answer that question the
decision to recommend
a gas plant was made in march i made the
decision right but i'm asking you the
decision not to
wait for him to do his seven seals the
plan that i don't know if you saw the
testimony mr zimmerman said that on
april i believe it was 15th
14th
uh in the negotiations he had a plan and
they were all going to march out with
one lawyer at the front one lawyer at
the back
after koresh finished writing his seven
seals
um
and then he said you were sympathetic to
that plan but a shameless a faceless
washington bureaucrat overruled you
i don't know where he came up with that
i want to know the truth here well the
the plan the surrender plan was
discussed in late march early april with
them not april 14th
the the implication that that plan that
surrender plan was discussed that day
was not this is a week before more than
a week before
what happened we went through that
surrender plan because you want to do
that because you plant surrender in the
person's mind
the only difference between that
surrender plan and our march second
surrender plan is we inserted the
lawyers
okay they left on august excuse me on
april 4th dejected they did their best i
give them all the credit in the world
for the effort they made to resolve that
in the meantime mr the guerin came up
with the contacts with phil arnold about
the idea of
finding another interpretation of the
seals in order to to where of course
will surrender okay that was told to us
on april 14th that's what
now when i said there was plenty of time
there was no approval of our plan at
that time okay had quarish
and anyone else given any indication
that there was an earnest sincere effort
to prepare
any manuscripts
then we would have delayed it but it was
continuous delay there was nothing that
happened that weekend that made me think
that anything had changed in fact if you
examine the the
negotiation tapes
it will be clear that they always have a
way of don't expect anything soon maybe
a year i haven't seen the first page to
edit they said maybe a year would take a
while
and that kind
in that context
the
i'm sorry
that's it good
uh in that context it was just a
discussion with judy schneider about how
long it took her to type these on a
manual typewriter
right what what was koresh's and
schneider's reaction to the lawyer's
suggestion that they surrendered
well they would they were they were as
manipulative of them as they were of us
they would build their spirits up i can
remember one instance when when digni
came out and and believe me he put his
best effort in and i gave him all the
credit in the world for the effort he
made
and he would build up and build him up
and then cut his legs out from under him
one inch of course i remember one
instance where he said he he was making
a point with him and coors feigned
illness
happened to us all the time did you hear
in conversations when koresh uh when the
lawyers weren't around that they said or
indicated that they were just sort of
manipulating the lawyers and not really
interested in sort of laughing at the
lawyers by implication yes explain that
please well they they would uh talk
about the fees
the ridiculous fees uh the
um but it was i don't have a real clear
statement for you it's just their
demeanor and their attitude we picked up
from them from the conversations with
them
so it is your belief
that even on april 15th
koresh and his followers had no
intention of coming out is that correct
sir i know i concluded that very much
and that didn't stop me from still
trying it didn't stop me from going
against the wishes of every other person
except maybe bob ricks to let the
lawyers go in and possibly help destroy
the crime scene i had not given up
thank you mr schumer mr heinemann
yes thank you
mr kavanaugh at some point
you
established a rapport with
with david koresh
yes i'll i'll try to go through a little
quicker also much quicker if you will
yeah uh
established a ceasefire
established to get our wounded agent out
uh kenny king
uh established then to get an ambulance
in
they thought it was an armored car
then established to
move all the wounded agents which is
this photograph you see
back behind the giant
bus that was parked in the driveway so
by this time it was getting a little bit
easier for me because
the ceasefire broke down three times so
we negotiated through a ceasefire
there'd be some some small gun battles
and then
the agent out the ambulance in the all
the wounded out and then the last thing
was to get the bodies of the agents off
the roof do you feel you had a rapport
with david koresh yes sir okay at what
point in time did did a call be made to
the fbi for their assistance in
negotiating
uh mr sage was on another phone that
afternoon from another location but i
didn't um and we had some some contact
but
it wasn't until sunday night
probably about 11 o'clock
that gary nesner from the fbi uh showed
up at the atf command post to uh help us
and to take over negotiation okay so at
that point you relinquished your job as
negotiator to
either gary or someone that he
designated
no chief i never relinquished it uh for
about a week i i stayed on the phone
from that morning at 10 o'clock until 2
30 the next morning well at what at what
point did the fbi negotiate is other
than gary what point did mr jamar come
in
well they were all there and i'd say you
know they took over mundy uh
uh officially as in charge of the
negotiations and they left me on the
daytime as a primary negotiator and it
was an fbi agent at night as a primary
so you negotiated for perhaps a week
after the fbi came in and took charge
that's right is that correct yes sir mr
jamar at that point
you at the point where you folks came in
you were designated in charge of the fbi
operations at the scene yes sir and you
established a command post
yes very near the atf command post on
the tsti campus okay so you only had one
command post yes sir how did you set up
that command post relative to the
negotiating team and the tactical team
the
it was a hangar on the tsdi campus which
had been an air force base
people will always be indebted to kaiser
technologies just handed over office
space to us
we had the upstairs floor where we had a
corner office for the myself and the
other sacs we had a larger room for lack
of be a squad for a squad of agents in
this the nerve center of the command
post right out across the hall from from
my office was the negotiation room
next to that room we had a smaller
office where they could talk and there
was another office we ultimately used
for to monitor the microphones next to
that was a larger conference type room
where we kept the aviation people
primarily and then next to that room was
the
hrt the hostage rescue team's
intelligence well can you could you
tell us whether the
the uh the hostage negotiators and the
tactical team shared the same office we
had a a member of the hostage rescue
team in the negotiation room all the
time
okay now in that
in in that command post was that inside
of the compound or was that close to the
where the staging area was no sir it was
about five miles as the crow flies
forward near the near the um
compound we had trailers
under a hill about i would guess a
thousand meters from the compound and
there were several uh uh all the
agencies had one some there and that was
our forward command post uh mr jamal did
you have any
training in in hostage negotiation
no i never entered into any either
i left that to the experts did you view
the people inside the compound as
hostages
no
i i view the the situation as a
barricaded subject
i think i said on the on one press
briefing that i can and somebody ask if
the children were hostages and i said
they're hostages to this circumstance
were hostages to the circumstances which
bar
did you have
in that ensuing week when after the
shootout
was mr cavanaugh in your command post
at that time yes sir we moved social
negotiating yes so we moved the phone
lines to the central place in our
command post and mr cavanaugh
came with yes did you give special
directives directions to the
the negotiators and also special
directions to the tactical teams
we each we all had goals we all
you know the ultimate goals we had we
all agreed with
i left the day-to-day operations of the
negotiations and the conduct of the
negotiations to include who did
negotiations how many everything else to
to mr nesner and the others and
mr sage i left it to them to run that
and i just gave them the support they
needed
you may have said this did you have a an
intelligence component in that
yes sir we had um
the in the nerve center i would call it
the main room we had we brought
everything together there in addition to
that
the hostage rescue team had an
intelligence
operation right there in the command
post very nearby
and and did you have meetings joint
meetings
we would have
meetings
with briefings after a while once we got
established
i'd like to have the opportunity
sometimes to describe what was like when
we arrived
uh i think it would be very helpful well
i'm sure someone will pick up on the
but we we would have meetings
after we got established it took days to
get established where the supervisors of
each component would get together and
dis and report and discuss matters and
then we would have various means we'd be
meetings primarily for the first two or
three weeks we were always among the
negotiators we didn't have who excuse me
i think i have one more question i had
to beat the red light
who did you report through directly
when i reported headquarters
most the time the person i spoke with
was assistant director of the criminal
investigative division at the time larry
potts at night his deputy would beat uh
danny coulson was there so you were in
constant contact with washington
numerous times a day
mr heinemann mrs collins
thank you mr chairman
mr cavanaugh around the second of march
koresh told you that he was going to
come out if
you played a tape that he made can you
tell us about that conversation
yes congresswoman we
we had worked on him pretty heavy for
about three days
trying to get
him to surrender in mass uh we were
having a very successful release of
children we had six on sunday six on set
uh monday
i think we had four on tuesday so we
were very feeling very good about that
the fact that he was letting all these
children out um
and then we we had arranged that
negotiation to release the children
based on the fact that we would play his
biblical message over the am radio and
every time we played it
uh
two children who come out
now this biblical message was this is
what was on the tape
and was this uh was this to be his
analysis of his religious philosophy or
something yes now this one you're
talking about congresswoman was much
longer
an hour or so
message
did you listen to the tape
uh it's been two years ago since that
but you did listen to the tape yes okay
would you be able to remember anything
so you could summarize for us your
impressions of what he said on that tape
well i'm not a theologian and
all during this process with karash i
i made that clear to him that i was just
a policeman
i tried to understand his religious
beliefs it was very difficult
it was very difficult to understand what
he would tell you basically i think he
gave us the unsolvable riddle i'm god
you prove i'm not
was basically what we faced
and and and most of that message had to
do with the fact that he believed he was
the lamb of god people have said he
believed he was christ he didn't believe
he was christ he believed he was the
lamb of god the person to open the
seventh seal
and he would go on and talk about that
i'm sure theologians could be more in
depth with you
well uh
for it for a while did it seem to you
that quresh was really going to come out
yes i believe so well
were the davidians lined up to come out
to your knowledge on that day
congresswoman they were lined up to come
out they had their jackets on
koresh was i believe that was our last
best chance to get him to ever come out
i don't believe that he once he didn't
come out on that tuesday
the reasons i say that he was fatigued
he had been in a gun battle on sunday i
shared the feelings i was in the same
gun battle
he was fatigued he was wounded he was
hurt we've been working on him for three
days
this was our our chance i thought to get
him out and if you go back over those
tapes
you know you can see how the process
worked but at the very last moment
he couldn't do it and mr smear who was
there with us gave us an analysis and i
still believe that his analysis was the
right analysis and he said
when he lined up with all the children
and the women in the hallway and they
all came by to kiss his ring
and that's detailed in that transcript
ad nauseum
that he couldn't leave this place where
he was god with unlimited sexual favors
unlimited being the messiah
and walk out to a cold jail cell
he couldn't do it at the last minute i
believe that was the case i think one
davidian later said they thought that
was a suicide pact but i've never been
convinced myself that it was
on the day of the raid um
when you have the picture for us how
devastating it actually was that there
were agents lying around probably
calling for help and all that kind of
stuff
at that time you had to begin
negotiations with koresh
how did
this had to be very difficult for you
was it not it was very difficult and i
i'm sorry to get a little
sad about it but
i had a radio mic in one ear with an
agent pleading for his life and i had
this guy on the phone who thought he was
god and
if you can picture yourself in that
situation
you know i just think it was the it was
unbelievable
and if i couldn't negotiate it
how was i going to get this guy out
and how many agents was i going to send
to get them how many people would die i
mean i felt like a ship's captain how
many people are going to get in the boat
so i put all my energy into negotiating
it
because if i didn't this guy in my ear
my friend
was going to die
did you feel that you were in a physical
danger of being shot by correction or by
the division davidians at that time the
rounds were coming through the walls on
my position while i was there
last week we heard uh young 14-year-old
carrie jewell who was sexually molested
by him when she was 10 by koresh by him
so that based on her personal experience
with korres she was not coming out would
you agree with her statement
yes congresswoman i agree i don't think
the archangel gabriel can talk that guy
out of there
mr sage
there's a very controversial picture of
you coming out of the negotiations
facility with the burning compound in
the background it's been called a trophy
picture
i want to give you an opportunity to
explain to us why you had that picture
taken mr sage
i appreciate the opportunity i've seen
it as well it's very bothersome
first of all if i can back up a little
bit i was there for
the entire 51 days i arrived at
approximately 11 o'clock in the morning
on the 28th of february
in very brief summary i will say without
hesitation that myself along with
approximately 50 negotiators from the
fbi and a number of local county and
state agencies
gave 110 of our effort uh and that
believe it or not is an understatement
for one purpose only and that was the
safe resolution of of this situation
paramount in that focus in my mind
constantly
was the safety of those children
when that picture was taken
it was taken at approximately
12 30
12 35 on
the 19th of april
i had just finished
nearly six continuous hours of
broadcasting starting off with
instructions
and then requests and ultimately please
uh
literally begging david and if if he was
not capable of doing it then steve
schneider not to end it this way this
was not the way to end it it was no
one's intention to end it in that
fashion when that picture was taken i
had just
completed
what
jim kavanagh had started the morning of
the 28th of february and that was
an absolute heartfelt commitment to try
to resolve this matter it had just
failed miserably
i i was crushed i think emotionally
everyone was spent physically
emotionally everywhere i could never
express the full range of emotions that
were going through me as i
exited from what we referred to as
sierra one alpha which was the forward
position immediately adjacent to the
former atf undercover house
i
a fellow negotiator i believe uh
hollered out to me i turned briefly and
that photograph was taken
so it was not a posed photograph by any
means congresswoman i can tell you
without hesitation that that is the
furthest thing from a trophy photograph
i hope to have an opportunity to show
you a photograph of
a face-to-face meeting that i had that
with steve schneider and wayne martin
and the sheriff of mclennan county
if there's a a trophy photograph
which i find the term first of all to be
very offensive that would be i would too
because that photograph represents the
commitment
without hesitation of all the
negotiators involved i just happen to be
fortunate enough to do it i will say one
thing please
i would have given my life
to save those kids
that photograph is anything but
a trophy photograph
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
congressman
thank you mr chairman i'm going to try
to move through some questions here
quickly mr sage uh one of my colleagues
described the testimony of
mr zimmerman and mr degaran yesterday as
lying baloney
i don't believe that that testimony was
lying baloney any more than i believe
that your testimony today or that of any
of your colleagues is going to be lying
baloney i believe you want to save those
children as a matter of fact
your report the justice department
report says the negotiator's goal was to
prevent the further loss of life was
that your goal absolutely mr jamar was
that your goal yes sir
okay
um mr smart you were kind of the lead
consultant on negotiating was saving
life your goal absolutely sir okay
um mr jamar according to the report that
the justice department prepared
director sessions and president clinton
met on march 1 and discussed the bureau
strategy for handling this crisis
sessions described it as a waiting
strategy whereby the fbi would negotiate
watch and contain were you aware of
those discussions
the
communication to me was that the white
house and that term the white house
communicated to the fbi that
we would do nothing beyond negotiate
without first discussing it okay
the report goes on to say that the
acting attorney general gerson advised
sessions that the president approved
this proposed waiting strategy involving
negotiating
watching and containing
and then asked to be advised if that
ever changed were you aware of that as
well
the
um
information i got was if you depart from
negotiation notify we also had the
authority to react in emergency
situations without consulting there's a
footnote to that effect as a matter of
fact yes okay
um
again
the characterization of lying bologna do
you believe the testimony that came in
yesterday was lying baloney
i wouldn't characterize
anyone's testimony as lying baloney
that i heard yesterday i think
the
there's a tendency to get rolling when
you start talking i think one of the
witnesses
spent a lot of his time doing that
yesterday i think but the imp like i
said well again the implication that
there was a plan and it was april 14th
is simply not the case that was all done
let me get into that but yes one of the
things that was said yesterday uh by
mr zimmerman was that he had the highest
regard for your integrity mr jamar and
did not believe that you ever
intentionally deceived him i presume you
don't think that was lying maloney
it's certainly not because i did not
deceive him okay
now there was specific testimony and um
the term is not a faceless bureaucrat
there was in fact a statement that some
desk bound bureaucrat in washington
changed the plan i'd like to get into
that and figure out why at least this mr
zimmerman believes that
mr degaran testified yesterday very
directly and very specifically that you
indicated to him when they came out with
this new strategy to allow mr koresh to
write out the
what he had to write out that that would
lead to his surrender
that when he described all that to you
that occurred on the 14th of april
correct
and at that point in time there had
already been as i understand it a
meeting in washington
on the 12th of april
where
the
gas plan
was described to the attorney general is
that also correct yes we i we submitted
the plan that became the plan
um
uh ultimately to april 19th
um with several modifications but the
original submission by by us and senator
in waco headquarters that was sent in on
march 27th they've been sending them
march 27th for
approval higher up yes sir okay and to
your knowledge it was taken to the
attorney general on monday april 12th is
that right i don't know the precise date
but there were numerous discussions and
i think that's probably correct well the
attorney general will be here we can ask
her that
okay we move forward monday april 12th
we move forward to wednesday april 14th
do garen and zimmerman go in they come
out with this whole new plan they
describe it to you you say to them
quote they had all that you have all the
time in the world
was that a misrepresentation on your
part why did you make that statement to
them i think the was not a
misrepresentation because what i said
was if
there is
writing of a manuscript if this if there
is progress we'll take the time
okay but on april 14th i didn't know the
plan was going to be approved
so at that point in time when you had
that conversation you were not aware
that the plan that had been lodged in
washington quite some time earlier for a
more confrontational result had in fact
been approved yes as a matter of fact it
hadn't been improved as approved as of
the 14th had it was not approved until
the 17th and executed on the 19th
correct okay so it was your hope uh on
you still had some hope on the 14th that
we might make progress we might get to
negotiated settlement is that right i
had hope i submitted the plan on the
27th and i had dick de garon going the
crime scene on the 28th okay 29. and
they came out with this whole new plan
on the 14th that said we may be able to
make this this is a real breakthrough
this follows with what's in koresha's
mind now my question is
following that conversation on the 14th
what steps did you take
later you got advised that the justice
department had approved the gas plan yes
what states do you take to advise
justice of the new plan that is of uh
this new proposal by uh koresh and by
zimmerman and
de garan which they later felt betrayed
about i'm not sure that
uh
when you say notify the department
that
proposal by then would been routinely
sent through our channels on the normal
discussion i don't know how it was done
specifically i don't know that
so do you do you know if attorney
general reno was ever advised that there
was this new development before she made
her decision i don't know because i
doubt it because it was not
from from our understanding of it and
the judgment was looking at what they
were doing
maybe that she was not i don't know but
it wasn't any reason to because it was
not a
serious plan it was just another
delaying tactic well clearly mr de
guerin and mr zimmerman by the emotion
and the passion they brought here and
the feeling that you had betrayed them
they said you never lied to him before
and now they felt you lied to him and
they want to know why you would say to
them on the 14th yet all the time in the
world i now understand that they felt it
was serious you can't tell me that
attorney general reno was ever advised
of that i can't tell you that no but i
had there been serious preparation of
the of the manuscripts we would have
waited
there was none i think they'd contend
there was serious because one came out
thank you very much my time's expired
uh
mr collins yes you may ask in absence
then mr chairman i ask you now i was
consent to have my opening statement
made just prior to my questioning please
uh without objection thank you um mr
scott
thank you mr chairman let me get um
jamar i'm a little confused right now
did
do i understand that mr karesh made an
offer to come out in a
in due course voluntarily
did that as i understand from the
questioning that that
kind of offer that offer was made right
what happened he sent the letter out
saying it was time to write
the seals and he was ready to do that
was open-ended as to when that might
occur but that he might at some time
come out voluntarily
i think that was about the fourth time
he had promised that yeah and did you
have any reason
not to believe that he would actually do
that
uh from his conduct from uh february
28th until april 19th i'd have every
reason to believe he would not do that
yeah what do you mean can you elaborate
on that he constantly
would make promises he did not keep
i think the efforts of
negotiators
in seven weeks of discussion i think an
analysis of those tapes
will indicate how manipulative and how
devious he was in his ability to control
events he would put us on one edge and
put jerk us down to the other constantly
that was his stock and trade
did you have any reason to believe this
last offer was any more credible than
any of the others that he had made
i remained as hopeful as i always was i
didn't bite as hard as i did on march
the second
but we listened we we pushed and pushed
and pushed what's the progress on the
manuscripts tell us tell us tell us and
all we got was stahl
yeah were you receiving any expert
advice any
advice from experts on how to handle a
situation
yes sir
uh how many different experts were
giving you advice i would say indirectly
doesn't
and can you explain the consensus of
that advice
well it would change as time passed you
uh was there a consensus was everybody
telling you pretty much the same thing
at certain times uh there was a
consensus
other times no
and what kind of different advice were
you getting
well the uh a good example is um
a good consensus would be let's don't do
anything to provoke them from the start
which we did not do we were extremely
careful but far
uh the beginning and i i'd like to take
that opportunity to describe what we
discovered there
when we arrived the fbi arrived byron
was the first and he started with the
negotiations at 11 a.m
we arrived in the evening of the sunday
the several of us to
examine what we what the situation was
what we had was four atf agents who had
been killed had been uh
hours of gun battle
and what we had was a
a
site that was uh
but they had a four-story view of a very
wide area and they had people with
automatic weapons they already
demonstrated they're fully prepared and
capable of using them
we tried to find out
what it took to get control of the
perimeter
we didn't want to do anything to
interfere what was going on the the flow
of children coming out that jim
cavanaugh had established
so we went the the hrt commander was
enroute i went forward to try to find
out what we had
and discovered that the perimeter was
very loose and thank goodness for some
local and state agencies which maintain
swat teams maintain the perimeter
but we determined that we could not get
within
hundreds of yards of that place without
being exposed to automatic gunfire and
possibly 50 calibers
so the decision was made that we must
have some sort of protection for our
agents if we're going to establish any
type of perimeter
that perimeter was not established until
after march the second
we were not in view the only only way
that uh korish was aware of the fbi was
through the negotiators
we were very careful but the the danger
level of that situation if you look at
the the what was taken down there's a
photograph under some of it that on the
right please the easel on the right if
you would take that
no i'm sorry the one behind that one
that's what i'm after thank you
the lower road there across that's
double e ranch road
the where jim cavanaugh was describing a
while ago was that house right in the
middle there
you go up the driveway and around up at
the top you see
um that's where we put
we call the sierra two that was a dairy
barn
we want to get people in there we did
not and that's the
up that picture the upper level that
picture would be the brand's davidian
property we did not go on that property
until we made the effort to go in the
back on the evening of march the second
but the the danger level was so high
their ability to see the scene to see
the entire area was so strong and their
weapons were so so powerful that we had
to have armor
to protect our agents we could not have
established perimeter around it and can
control those circumstances without some
armor well i guess what the point we're
trying to focus on is
in the negotiation process and that's
what i think this inquiry is about today
or lisa's panel
what basis you had to believe that mr
quresh
would actually come out as he said he
would mr sage did you have negotiations
were you involved in the negotiations
yes sir
did you believe mr koresh when he said
this time that he would be coming out
this time being the 14th of april right
right before the um
the only consistent
uh aspect of of course's actions as of
the 14th of april was the consistency of
breaking every promise that he had made
that may be slightly overstated but only
slightly
so the the short answer to that question
is no
i was hopeful but i was doubtful
thank you
in the selection of cs gas a lot has
been made made about that were other
gases
considered
and can you discuss briefly the
merits of one or another of the gas
gases
we
relied on the expertise of our
headquarters and the experts they
consulted i think
i don't possess that expertise i think
that's going to be in a slater panel
discussed in
very much detail
mr scott i don't think that i'd be
i can't describe all the possible gases
thank you mr scott mr cobo
you're recognized for five minutes
i thank the chairman mr chairman i yield
five minutes to the gentleman from
arizona
i thank my colleague and appreciate him
doing so um mr cavanaugh you said a
minute ago you would have given your
life to save those children is that
right i think mr said said that
mr sage you said that i i take it mr
kavanagh you share that sentiment though
don't you
well certainly yes
um indeed
there were a number of children in the
compound and a number of women in the
compound
and
regardless
of what you believed
about mr crash
you had to take a different attitude
toward those women and children children
didn't you mr cavanaugh yes sir mr sage
the answer is yes but can i can i make a
distinction
when i wrote when i arrived there as the
first fbi negotiator at 11 o'clock this
was already
in motion
the problem that the fbi was faced with
was that prior to the 28th
we would at the most atf fbi would have
been uh faced with the possibility of
attempting to negotiate a group of
individuals willing participants out to
face the potential of maybe multiple
fighters
right there i need to just use my time
as quickly as i can the point is there's
an important point congressman
when we rolled up we were then faced
with the possibility or the problem of
attempting to negotiate a group of
people out to face multiple first-degree
murder charges in a state that that may
well lead the nation in capital
punishment but overwhelming difference
overwhelming problem same priority focus
the safe resolution of the situation
right the children were never going to
be charged with murder were they no sir
okay so in many senses they were victims
of this circumstance weren't they i
think we all agreed on that so they if
they were victims they had to be
considered in your negotiations
differently than those that that were
responsible karesh himself and those
others who pulled the trigger that's why
they're the top priority to try to get
out yes so in many senses they were
hostages were they not well they were
hostages to their fate
yes sir they were they were hot in fact
coarse even referred to the children as
hostages and the fact that they were
more important because of their value as
a hostage which drove your obligation to
get them out safely if you could without
question okay i want to go into the
tension that it seems to me to have
developed between the negotiators and
the tactical people because some things
occurred
that uh i don't understand the report
states rather specifically
that the negotiators and mr sage you
were a negotiator mr smerrick you were
an advisor on that and uh i believe mr
newsome you were
a negotiator um it says that you
remained hopeful what you mean doubtful
at times hopeful to the end of a
peaceful resolution did you feel that mr
smear
i agree with the premise that david
koresh was never coming out of that
particular compound
as an analyst for the fbi from the
investigative support unit
i believe the best that the negotiators
were going to be able to attain in this
situation was getting additional people
out of that particular and you had some
success in getting people out mr kevin i
believe you got 34 people out in 23 days
is that right
no congress but i i see you personally
but the fbi right that's right the fbi
got 34 people out in 23 days i believe
that's right okay um
the so the statement you would agree
with the statement in the report that
you remain hopeful to the end for a
peaceful resolution of this
is that a question for me yeah uh yes we
we always try to work towards bringing
about a peaceful resolution even if
we've come to a decision or a conclusion
that the the ending may not be to our
liking we continue to work and strive
towards a peaceful resolution and it was
35 people that came out here 35 35 good
i wish it had been more so um
some of the things that happened trouble
me it the report itself acknowledges
that there was it says the negotiators
felt that the negotiating and tactical
components of the fbi strategy were more
often contradictory than complementary
tell me why the report says they were
contradictory well i think in in any
dynamic situation the way our system is
set up in the fbi and most police
departments follow this
in our structure the negotiation
components and the tactical components
are separated and the purpose being that
the on-scene commander have an
independent assessment of the situation
and independent recommendations one is
not tainted by the other so there is a
dynamic
process that takes place there yes the
negotiation uh strategy as i recommend
when i got there i thought we should
take a low keyed approach stay back and
appeal well the president was told that
apparently believed it
is that a question for me
well let me let me put a question um did
you feel betrayed by some of the tactics
that were ultimately used for example uh
there's a report uh a direct quote from
the transcript where it is said by a
negotiator to mr crush we had a very
good dialogue last night the electricity
will not go off tonight because we have
had a good dialogue this evening as a
negotiator to mr koresh half an hour
later no i'm sorry it's a negotiator to
mr steve schneider a half an hour later
the lights are turned off and left off
permanently the electricity shut off
why
i can't answer the why but i can uh tell
you that the negotiation team was
disappointed in that decision um what my
job is as a negotiation coordinator
during the time i was there from the
28th through march uh excuse me february
28th through march 25th was to provide
my assessment and input to the on-scene
commander he has to take that
information and couple that with the
information he receives from other
intelligence sources from the tactical
team and he has to weigh all those
things weigh them with his own
experiences and his own perceptions and
he has to come to a decision we have a
saying that negotiators negotiate
commanders command and even though i may
not have agreed with some of those
decisions i know that they were made by
mr jamar with the best of intentions in
resolving this peacefully
did you feel well
i did not feel betrayed i was
disappointed in the decision betrayed is
far too strong a word okay um mr sage
that was not the only incident of that
type there were a number of incidents
where it seemed to me from reading the
report like you were trying and mr
cavanaugh was trying to gain the trust
of mr koresh to be able to talk him into
a reasonable resolution and yet things
that happened that were inconsistent
with that for example the crushing of
the cars or this whole issue of tension
that arose between
the negotiators and the tactical people
over uh a machine gun that was sticking
out a window negotiators
say to crush move it that's threatening
people making things bad and and the
tactical people get angry with you about
that uh talk to me about the tension
that existed uh we are told that they
were at points uh almost fist fights
between the negotiators and the tactical
people now that's that's been greatly
overstated it's uh there's there's
normally going to be a dynamic as as mr
nesner has uh
pointed out there's two
options uh that need to be presented if
those options absolutely were mirrored
images of one another we would be doing
a disservice to the on-scene commander
as far as giving him or her a realistic
assessment of the options available
was there tension between the
negotiation
effort and the tactical effort yes there
was
did it affect ultimately the outcome of
this incident no sir it did not
did you ever come a point in time to
your knowledge when the president was
told that the negotiate strategy the
wait and see we've got all the time in
the world had been abandoned
sir i was so far down the the chain of
command that i don't know what the
president was told
well that was it was never abandoned i
think that i think that's that's the mis
that's the misunderstanding here well it
appears all been abandoned on the
morning of the 19th
i think well i think when you say
abandon i think when the the action to
go
uh when we did was in agreement with
everyone there wasn't anyone who did not
agree with that yeah my question was
negotiators
thank you very much
um mrs slaughter you're recognized for
five minutes
thank you uh gentlemen i've been
impressed with one of the witnesses who
was hearing seemed to feel that they had
a real understanding of david korish and
that they were going to be able to talk
him into doing something that he had
spent a good part of his adult life
saying that he was not going to do
a man who was able to persuade
intelligent people
to do the things that he got them to do
would not likely be swayed by two or
three visits from a social worker or
from defense lawyers but mr jamar i'd
like to know why you let those defense
lawyers go in
i was hopeful that
they could appeal that mr de garan could
appeal to mr korus's self-interest
everything mr korris did was to his
self-interest
so the idea was uh give you the quick
history
i accepted one call from the lawyers the
whole time i was there and that was from
dig to guerin just because
just a minute ago destroyed evidence
yes ma'am would you elaborate on that
yes ma'am i
the decision to
get mr guerin in touch with mr korish
was easy
to let him be on the telephone was easy
the hard part was let him go in the
crime scene and let a defense attorney
go into an ns
it's extraordinary and i was told that
by everybody uh
everybody opposed it um and i thought it
was worth doing i it was extremely um
upsetting to the prosecutors extremely
upsetting to the direct texas rangers
extremely exciting to atf my fellow socs
with the exception of bob ricks
extremely upset at me for doing that
i think i heard yesterday some
descriptions of
they did the very things that the
prosecutors and the investigators feared
it inhibited the investigation
very much but but i felt so strongly
that if we're ever going to reach korish
the way to reach him is his
self-interest nothing else
of course really didn't care if his
uh followers died in a fire
he
had explained to them had he not that
this was a redemption
that this was the way to salvation that
they would all go in this in this fiery
burst there's no question about that
several survivors are concerned about
their salvation right now and there was
also an indication that some members
particularly mr snyder believed that he
could walk through that fire that he
would survive it
i don't know if
they bought all that i think
i think steve snyder was really
wondering about what he was doing there
at the end
um
i'm curious too about the negotiation
because this is very important you had
professional negotiators with you the
best in the world the best in the world
uh and yet um
apparently ministers who called up and
thought they could do it too was they
were allowed to have a go at it
we had a lot of them call we had all
sorts of people call
i think um the the um
philosophy and the process
and making that decision be better
described by either either mr industrial
mr sage
why you don't let somebody buy into
somebody else's see i i find this very
distressing because the one thing that
you knew was that you were dealing with
a man who had extraordinary ability to
control people's minds he demonstrated
that very effectively without question
as a matter of fact i wouldn't be
surprised if some of the people who
talked here and thought they had a great
hold on him if it wasn't maybe the other
way around
uh and and i've been somewhat disturbed
about that um now i'm talking about the
letter that mr daguerreon talked about
yesterday that was not in mr korsh's
handwriting
i have no idea who wrote it but my
assumption and i'd have to have an
expert tell me but it was a very
feminine handwriting it was probably
judy snyder i think she wrote the other
letters he sent out do you have any
evidence of that that she did that
i would uh just infer it based on she i
was told she wrote the the more
threatening letters we'd gotten in the
previous days
and if there were were there any
indications over there that joyce
schneider was getting worried and she
was sort of free agenting to try to help
you people get them out we really hope
that i i we really thought that could
she have written the letter it's really
on her own could she have done that
letter by herself no way that anything
would leave that compound without
uh course's approval you believe that is
his genuine signature on that letter
um i haven't thought about it before but
i presume so i i'd really like to have
somebody think about that a little bit
because it did occur to me that perhaps
she wanted out
um
another thing about this there's a lot
of questions i guess about the attorney
general and whether she knew this how
many times during this 51 day standoff
had he promised to come out if you play
a tape or you'd sing a song or he could
do something or other else and and you
complied and he never did come out
i think there are four very very clear
ones but i think i would
i think the game
was constant
right
um
we're all do do you have any knowledge
that each time this did you negotiate
that this went all the way to the
attorney general united states well she
was she was kept briefed i'm certain uh
but
i think uh there's a sameness to it all
after a while
after you've gotten these other demands
that you had complied with that if you
do this i'll do that
did you have any reason to believe that
the letter that mr degarin brought out
was any different
no but i remained hopeful and i examined
their conduct very closely thereafter
and i saw nothing new that would make me
change that and you sent the letter up
up the chain of your command at the fbi
i presume that they were informed of it
that i
sent the letter to washington itself i
doubt that but i would presume that they
were informed of that the contents of
that letter yes there's no evidence of
any sort that you know of
that the attorney general
had any reason to believe this last
letter or even existed
that and there wouldn't be any reason
for it to change your opinion if you did
all right that's uh that's that's very
important mr sage uh you you did quite a
bit of negotiating and i think i've
heard some of it on cnn some of the work
that you have done do you have any
feeling that mr koresh was going to
change his mind surrender send everybody
out and come out peacefully we were we
remained hopeful uh up until
the very end of this thing the tragic
end of this thing when you talk to him
did he give you indications that he was
considering doing that oh he gave us
every indication in the world
regarding a number of topics including
the safe and orderly exit i mean to a
point of minutia when we prepared the
original exit plan on the second of
march wasn't there at one point where
everybody was lined up to leave
and he had lied about leaving is that
correct can you elaborate on that a bit
we were led to believe uh on the 2nd of
march that he literally had and in fact
there was a very clear this this person
was every bit
well
maybe i won't say every bit as skilled
at using the same techniques that we try
to use on him you can say it uh but we
had a uh at one point in time a very
vivid picture painted for all of us and
i will i will say matter of factly that
that
i bit off on this hook line and sinker
probably in very close uh similarity to
the defense counsel
uh
addressing or adopting the
representations made to them
subsequently in the siege
but i'm referring to the activities of
the second of march
we had a very vivid picture
of uh the children lined up with their
uh
little coats on and uh it was very cold
outside rainy everybody concerned that
uh
the the very smallest aspect of that i
can recall vividly uh working very
closely with with uh jim kevin on this
up to and including concerns about well
they some of the kids wanted to bring
their puppies out with them
and
we were we were ready
from
the 28th february when i got there until
uh
the ultimate conclusion on the 19th of
april to accommodate any reasonable
request
and
he would get us uh in a position where
we thought it was there was a major
break at hand and then pull the rug out
from under us but that's our job
not to lose faith to continue to try to
reach a safe and reasonable conclusion
and we never we never ceased in that
effort he was not only playing with you
he was playing with his followers
absolutely your time has has expired mrs
ross
thank you
mr chairman and thank all the witnesses
uh for being here today i'd like to
follow up uh uh to uh mr
shattuck's uh line of questioning as all
of us know from uh reading the report
according to the uh the justice
department report on the events that
waco and i quote the guiding principle
in negotiation and tactical employment
is to minimize the risk to all persons
involved hostages bystanders subjects
and law enforcement officers yet despite
this uh this clear objective
uh the doj report states that uh the
components uh the the tactical and the
negotiating components of the fbi
strategies were quote more often
contradictory than complementary
and i'd like to uh to ask mr kavanaugh
and any others who'd like to comment
what accounts for the lack of a coherent
uh game plan for ending the siege in in
accordance with the stated principles
about minimizing the risks
congresswoman i think that in the
negotiation
what you want is these two contradicting
voices if you're the commander you want
a negotiator coming to you and saying i
can talk these people out
and you want a tactical commander coming
to you telling you that i can resolve
any other issue that might be tactical
that that is the way that it is
appropriately handled
the voice of the negotiator
has to be equal
to the voice of the tactical leader
and
my recommendations to the justice review
and i don't know if
so you're saying this is what you wanted
to happen you you wanted to have this
contradictory yes it's supposed to
happen that way that's supposed to
happen and i told the justice review and
i'm not sure the fbi will necessarily
agree with my assessment of the fbi
but i made it and certainly in all good
in intentions and that would be that
their negotiator their chief negotiator
would be the same pay grade and rank
as the chief of their hostage rescue
team
so that they would come at the sack mr
jamar with an equal voice
and i'm sure mr jamar gave them an equal
voice and he was very very understanding
and fair but what i'm saying is i think
that perhaps there might be a difference
between the playing the good cop bad cop
routine and having a a situation where
you're giving contradictory uh
tactics and
and you end up with a system that's all
fouled up so i think that
you might be saying that that's a good
maneuver to try
but when you get into a real life
situation and when you're uh negotiating
that way and the other folks say do it
the other way i think that we could see
what can happen i think that's a little
different than than playing off each
other and bouncing those kinds of ideas
could i comment on on that
uh mr kavanagh i would just disagree one
point he made the system is not built
that that the two components be in
controversy all the time the system is
built so that each of the components has
an independent input to the on-scene
commander for example in the talladega
prison riot both the negotiation
component and the tactical component
there were in complete agreement that
the most risk effective method to
resolve the situation would be the
utilization of tactical resources and
that was a very successful operation
there is often times where both
components are in agreement they're not
necessarily in conflict we weren't
purposefully trying to be in conflict at
waco there was a strategy there was a
fundamental strategy disagreement what
was the best way to proceed in in waco
the negotiation team wanted to have a
lower keyed approach the tactical team's
approach was more to apply pressure part
of that i believe was driven by the fact
that the tactical team as mr jamar
indicated was exposed to open fire we
were dealing with the most complex
situation we've ever had in united
states where it had already been a
demonstrated willingness to use force we
had in fact four dead federal agents
unknown number of dead people inside
certainly 50 caliber weapons that could
reach for over a mile and uh and affect
our tactical personnel so the need to
provide them with adequate cover
to contain the situation had an impact
on conveying perhaps a message that mr
koresha didn't want to hear
so i think that's important to make note
of thank you
yes just a short statement i'd like to
move on to another i think uh that there
should be no misunderstanding that the
last thing the tactical people want to
do was to approach the compound they
don't want to do a tactical action at
all
you don't do that except as a last
resort i think i think whether that
report is is where there were incidents
where they
were in conflict but it was not that
much it just didn't happen that often
the doj reporter further uh states that
the this standoff
left the the davidians with a sense of
hopelessness and uh and isolation and it
further states that uh
and i'll quote the problem uh was the uh
the pace of the surrender uh was there
an explicit or an imp
implied directive
from higher ups to uh to get this thing
uh over with
and i'd like to ask mr sage to comment
on that and any others who'd like as
well
i was there the entire 51 days as i've
mentioned
i can say that matter of factly i never
felt pressure from anyone that there was
a specific time frame timetable
and where we needed to have this
resolved by date certain
uh
every effort was was undertaken to try
to identify and fully explore every
option available to us
obviously pursuing those that were
considered the most
potentially fruitful
and we did that
we had constant input
to the on-scene commander and his
assistants we had one of the sacs bob
ricks was very closely involved with the
negotiation
cell throughout most of it there wasn't
a breakdown in in relaying back and
forth
the dynamics of negotiation the
identified
potential avenues that we intended to
pursue and the efforts gained from those
and speaking of those avenues that that
you might have pursued according to the
doj report it says some of the
negotiating personnel did believe that
more branch davidians might have
departed the compound had the pressure
tactics been withheld and these tactics
as we've read included the the playing
of chance which had said mr sage
objected to to deprive the davidians of
of sleep who made the the decision to uh
to overrule these negotiators uh about
this uh these pressure tactics
uh mr smarrick or anyone else i think i
would be the one to answer that since
i'm the one who did that
um
the decision to start playing with the
the loud noises and that sort of thing
was made
march 22nd
that's when that started
uh the
that tactic had been recommended to us
by the behavioral scientists from the
start
i didn't like that my memory was of
noriego you remember that in panama all
that and i didn't like that uh just but
finally
we got the point where not much of what
we were doing
that was
you know from mid-march on
was not being very effective
so we
we um
in discussions what more can we do and
the thought was let's see if we can
keep them awake maybe that'll help again
that was recommended from the start
um the
negotiators felt like that wouldn't
wouldn't wouldn't work wouldn't be
helpful
uh did it affect um how many more people
came out i don't think it did i think
with a we started on march 22
uh livingston fagin came out march 23rd
but that was purely coincidental i don't
think it made any difference at all can
i add to that just a moment uh
we
we had set up intentionally set up a
bank of loud speakers and intentionally
set them up in the form of
high fidelity speakers so that there
would be inflection to the voice
the main reason for that was not to play
achy breaky heart or these boots are
made for walking or any other of the
rest of the misrepresentations that's
out before the american public
the sole purpose of the pa system
initially was to make announcements of
which i was
designated to make the majority of them
but more importantly it was to play
actual tape recordings from released
branch davidians back in for example on
the uh i believe is his 12th of march
uh kathy schroeder came out kathy
schroeder had a position of leadership
in the eyes of of her peers
when she came out it was much more
effective
to put an audio tape of kathy schroeder
calling back into the compound saying
hey
i've been released i've been treated
well i've been reunited with my little
three-year-old boy brian
i
i have access to an attorney i have
access to the media and so forth
we played
beginning the
approximately the 12th or 13th a series
of tapes four tapes in particular and
then a fifth one was added that was
kathy schroeder making just exactly
those representations voluntarily in her
own voice instead of them hearing it
from me or another negotiator oliver guy
arfus the same thing saying it hey here
i am everything's fine they've treated
me well they're not the animals that
we've been led to believe and i've got a
an interview tomorrow morning on uh good
morning america
uh two tapes from jack harwell who was
the uh
and is the sheriff of mclennan county uh
there which mount carmel is included in
and the fifth tape
was a conversation had between myself
and david korish on the 17th of march
after he refused to allow a second face
to face the reason for playing those was
to give all of the people inside and i
stress this all of the people inside
an equal opportunity to understand
exactly the dynamics that have been
going on trying to resolve this instead
of just a core group that we may be
talking to or course may have limited
full communications to that was the
intention of those of the pa system not
all the the rest of the stuff that seems
to have taken a higher
uh focus uh
in this matter thank you gentlemen miss
ross laden your time has expired we are
at a point now where any moment the
house will convene in a special joint
session to receive the president of
korea
we're going to have to under the house
rules take a recess until that joint
session is concluded
we intend to return to this panel and i
understand the difficulty of this break
you're just going to have an early and
long lunch hour i think
we intend to return to this panel
within 30 minutes after the time that
joint session is concluded or 1 pm
whichever is earlier
and with that in mind this joint
committee is in recess
[Music]
[Music]
the joint house subcommittee hearing on
the waco investigation will continue in
just a moment
first some program information
over on our companion network season no
it's too cold
emmy award-winning journalist john
hockenberry and his book moving
violations war zones wheelchairs and
declarations of independence sunday
night on book notes at eight eastern and
pacific time
we now return to wednesday's proceedings
examining the waco investigation
last week a house joint subcommittee
began hearings into events at waco texas
in the spring of 1993.
he's a joint committee hearings on waco
will come to order
a little bit later than i hoped we would
be coming back from the break after the
joint session of congress
but nonetheless we're here and gathered
now uh i don't believe there is a member
of the minority side ready to ask
questions at this juncture i've been
advised and so i'm going to yield for
his five minutes to mr blue mr blute you
may proceed
thank you very much mr chairman and i
want to thank the witnesses for their
testimony today i'd like to direct a
question to mr jamar if i could
uh did you regularly get a memorandum
from mr smarrick concerning what was
happening at waco
uh the first week um i think
mr smear gave me a memo of probably four
memos did you find those memos helpful
in the development of your strategy
yes
in his march seventh memo to you mr
smarrick recommended that you bring in
the local sheriff
to become more involved in the
negotiations
uh did you act on those recommendations
he was already involved before that was
he involved extensively would you say he
stayed with us all day every day from
from i think a duration of the siege
was his input helpful tremendously
helpful we heard testimony earlier from
an earlier panel
from a branch to vidian who had escaped
who had first-hand knowledge there who
seemed to indicate that the relationship
between the sheriff and koresh was
fairly cordial is that your
understanding yes the sheriff was a type
of man who
had been sheriff for
over 25 years
very engaging man
extremely bright man
he knows how to communicate with people
in that community and he was extremely
effective uh with courage was there any
idea of using him uh up front with
courage we did i think um
there's one instance where we put milk
in where we made it look like it was the
sheriff accomplished in order to build
him up i think you might want to ask mr
sage about the there's a photograph up
there that face to face is a good
example of the sheriff's commitment in
his involvement with us
in in mr smarrick's march 8th memorandum
he recommended that the resort to
tactical pressure quote should be the
absolute last option we should consider
and that the fbi might uh
unintentionally make quresh's
vision of a fiery end come come true uh
seemingly you did not uh listen to that
uh recommendation well i don't think
that
how do you want to define it and when
one of the points i tried to make
earlier is is
establishing a perimeter
and
using armor to do that is that tactical
pressure
if it we didn't do that we wouldn't
stayed we'd be gone we'd have to leave
remember
we
we arrived
there's four dead atf agents at least 16
wounded and
at least five people we knew about dead
inside
you don't show up
and try to establish control of
something
and put people in peril although they
were in very much peril the whole time
so that part if you define
tactical pressure as that then no
as far as doing something to provoke
them or anything like that the first
thing we did i think would be close to
provocative
was on the 15th of march where we
removed some debris
from the
we call the black side the back from as
you recall from television which you the
view you saw from the back
because it was some of some
building materials and stuff that they
would go out and continue to fortify and
they kept leaving so we wanted to remove
that from them
let me just ask mr smarrick if you would
consider
operating bradley fighting vehicles
close to the compound as a provocative
act
it wouldn't necessarily be construed as
a provocative act what it would do is
be perceived perhaps in a compound as
additional stress being placed upon them
and so what i was concerned with of
course is that if our goal is to try to
break the control that david koresh had
over the minds of his people
what would like to do is with draw back
slightly so that we're not increasing
the pressure uh within the compound and
strengthening the hold that mr quresh
had on his followers but it was not a
tactical move to provoke any type of a
fight what about the issue of your
decision mr jamar to cut off the power
inside the compound uh did you believe
that uh the hrt agents in the field were
cold and wet and this is somehow why the
davidians
should be the same at that time was that
part of your decision making that was
part of it but i think the thing to
remember we cut the electricity off in
the ninth we cut the electricity off
from the tent
the idea was to there's something we can
do maybe to get a reaction from them
which we did
uh
of course never permitted classical quid
pro quo negotiations he didn't would not
involve himself and did not permit it
but that was the what was going on we
had turned it back on well that evening
um morale and and
and
the coal was a factor but remember the
reason we did in the first place
was also to use up their fuel if they
had generators the sooner we use their
fuel up
the generators will stop and they can't
use the fuel for molotov cocktails
there's a lot of reasons for doing
something but that night i'm first to
tell you that when i that the reason i
did it that night primarily was for
morale in one respect not just not just
the tactical people everybody who was
out in cold
and away from home and everybody else
but also
that we're not as predictable as they
may think
now the negotiators like that not not at
all because it was a departure for them
but i it got us out of a box that that
well what about the further decision to
play loud music uh the tibetan chants
and the rabbits being slaughtered was
this an escalation and was this
consistent with the advice that mrs
merrick had given you well i think uh mr
smart was gone when we did that we
didn't do that until march 22nd mr smart
had the memorandum one memorandum of his
where that was an option to consider he
did not
specifically recommend that necessarily
but um
it was done at that time i i wouldn't
consider it
relevant to any of his memoranda well
let me just say that it seems that there
was a
two-pronged approach here where you were
uh raising the temperature while your
negotiators were trying to lower the
temperature and is that and let me ask
mr sage his opinion while these things
were going on
did you think that these were helpful
things in your negotiations or hurtful
they were they presented difficulties
for sure but uh that's not unusual uh
these are not matters that we were not
prepared to uh
to attempt to uh negotiate through
uh it's not uncommon to uh
as part of the negotiation process to
actually
uh try to ingratiate yourself a little
bit more with the uh with
courage and and uh his followers by
saying look this is out of our hands but
that's why you need to give us something
to work with i need to be able to go in
to the on-scene commander
and demonstrate some good faith progress
here
uh that that held true throughout this
it was not an overwhelming stumbling
block and it was not
something that was undertaken without us
having uh prior knowledge of it let me
just quickly ask one last thing did you
negotiate your with each other or
discuss your negotiations on a daily
basis
constantly all day all shifts thank you
mr chairman
thank you very much uh mr schiff you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
mr cavanaugh uh you're with the
bureau of alcohol tobacco and firearms
were at that time yes sir
um after
after the initial raid which you have
already described
did you become the initial negotiator
with the with david koresh and the
branch davidians yes congressman
and uh for how long did that last
on february the 28th i was the
negotiator
from 10 am until i got the ceasefire and
the wounded out at one o'clock at one
o'clock
i told david koresh and steve schneider
i said
you're completely surrounded
this was not true but i was stretching
that a little bit
i was stretching a lot really but if
just because time is short if i can
redirect you to the question i'm sorry
for how long were you the chief nego
essentially the chief negotiator i was
the primary negotiator up and through
wednesday or thursday
all right and uh who replaced you as
negotiated at night the first first
person was gary nesner at the table here
he replaced me sunday night at 2 30 or
monday morning at 2 30 a.m now mr nesner
is with with the fbi is that yeah sure
yes so that's at the point uh several
days later where the fbi then took over
the negotiations with david korish
yes sir they officially really took over
i'd say monday the next day uh
directing operations taking over the
negotiations mr hartnett had come to me
and told me
that
the white house had directed that the
fbi would take over the whole situation
when the white house directed that the
fbi take over from atf
uh did you continue to participate in
the negotiations even though the fbi was
now in charge of it yes congressman i
did you continued to participate all the
way through well i stayed on the phone
for uh up to thursday i stayed on the
negotiating team
up until saturday
i had been transferred to washington
uh once again i had to move my personal
goods i was not on the phone speaking at
that time and so i left i came back
enough for another stint of about seven
to ten days in uh late march early april
so you were always a participant in the
negotiations
no sir uh
a week and then a break of a couple
three weeks and then a week and then i
wasn't there for the list were you ever
removed as a negotiator did the fbi ever
tell the atf we don't want you involved
anymore no sir
so always fully involved
yes sir
did you believe that the that uh were
you aware that there were surrender
plans being discussed with the quresh
and the other people inside the compound
by the lawyers is testified here to
yesterday yes sir i do i was aware you
knew about that uh
in your opinion were those serious plans
for surrender
well mr schiff like i testified earlier
uh i i felt the best chance we had to
get him out was on march the 2nd and i
agree with mr jamar he tricked us he
fooled us he played with us
i thought if he was coming out that was
the
best time we were going to get him out
fatigue he was wounded his blood
pressure was down i think he was playing
more sick than he really was
but i thought we might have a chance at
that point of getting getting him out
uh when what i told mr jamar not to let
those attorneys in there
i disagreed with that strongly i well
let me turn now to miss mr jamar if i
may uh mr jamar are you aware of the
surrender discussions between koresh and
lawyers
well the surrender discussion was i
described earlier that was the
the week the weekend there of the late
march
early april
not the 14th we're talking about two
very distinct periods of time here
well the specifically uh in april around
april 14th the lawyers testified that
they had reached an agreement for a
surrender are you aware of that well no
i think that was that was the
implication of what they were saying but
that wasn't exactly it what they agreed
what it was was he was going to come out
after he writes a manuscript an
open-ended time which they believed if
he was telling them the truth would take
two a couple days each so they thought
10 or 12 days he would be coming out
all right and and did you convey to mr
sage as chief negotiator or was mr sage
already aware if you know
that there was at least a discussion of
a surrender in 10 to 12 days as an
estimate
well that that's i don't think you're
saying it quite right mr schiff i think
though i'll let you say it then the way
okay
clear earlier
that this all the surrender discussion
all the surrender plan discussion was
done long before april 13th and 14th
with them it was when the lawyers were
inside they came out and and then
they were
on a high he took it right away from
them and then they left
we thanked them for a wonderful effort
taking their time and that was it then
mr daguerreon came up with the idea
i've been discussing with some some
scholars some theological religious
scholars
that let's try this new angle with the
with the seals with him
well he he gets on the phone with
courage and presents that to him well
morris goes for it and sends a letter
out excuse my interruption it's only
because time is short
was there a point that you felt that
there was a serious
uh surrender discussion or offer being
made
did you ever you talking about in april
with the lawyers um that's what i'm
talking about you know
i was serious on their mind i think they
were they were earnest and really
hopeful but in in in course is mine
never a chance i'm sorry
all right mr chairman uh i see my time
is about up i just want to say that once
again we've heard some very powerful
testimony at this hearing about the
initial events and and the uh shootout
between the uh bureau of alcohol tobacco
and firearms members and the people
inside the compound i just want to again
say that on my part and i think
everybody else is here in both both
parties in the subcommittees
that
all of us
support law enforcement and all of us
want to see that if there are and there
will be dangerous situations in the
future
that federal agents are not sent forward
in inherently dangerous situations
without proper planning and management
and backup thank you mr chairman i yield
back thank you very much mr schiff uh at
this point i'll recognize ms lofgren for
five minutes
mr chairman i'd like to first apologize
for not being here this morning the
science committee had a hearing at the
exact same time on the internet
which is a huge importance to my
district and i would say
future the country
i was um
i've read through the various fbi
reports and and the like and i was
interested in
the report on july 13th mr jamar
uh
i assume it's accurate where you
indicate that
um and i guess it's page two that
there had to be some method devised to
remove individuals in the cam compound
if for example it became apparent the
children were being brutalized or had
their lives endangered
i was wondering how much you knew or
believed at that time before the april
19th event as to the abuse of the
children the
uh child molestations ongoing and how
much that was a factor even though
it might not have been your direct
jurisdiction in in factoring how to deal
with this whole situation well i think
the is mr sage
uh and mr kavanaugh indicated the
children were utmost in everyone's mind
all the time
the the information we received when we
arrived was that um there were several
instances of complaints by poorish of
severely disciplined infants to include
paddling them to where they bled and
the other would be
taking 10 and 12 year old girls for his
wife
in fact when the tapes they sent out he
had a group of his wives or potential
wives sitting on the couch with their
star david
necklaces on
what we took from from
a reason we're into discontinuant
during the siege
there was
some evidence we thought of him being
involved with the child while we could
hear a microphone we've been told that
was not the case it was a preaching
but kathy schroeder tells us
kathy schroeder is one of the people
that came out and was a witness in the
trial kathy schroeder tells us as she
stuck her head in the door to say
goodbye to course when he forced her to
come out of the compound because she did
not want to come
he was in bed with a with a child with a
10 or 12 year old girl
so it was but we didn't know that then
it's my point we know it now i'm
wondering what you know but what that
does to me is confirms the belief that
if he had that kind of conduct in the
past it would continue during the season
it did apparently well what i'm trying
to pro i'll tell you uh trying to think
back to just what my neighbors i'm a
fresh person i've only been in the
congress now
seven months i guess and and like a lot
of other americans in 1993 my neighbors
were you know opining what should happen
and one of the questions that i would
call people in the neighborhood and in
the town i lived in
asking was why
why not just wall them up and
leave them alone how much and how much
was it costing a day for the taxpayers
to keep this siege on going
i'd like to know how much was it costing
per day
and were there good reasons for not
simply withdrawing and letting them sit
there for a year or more well there's
lots of reasons not to withdraw here
we've got four dead atf agents and
people who are armed um
the other is that
if we leave those people in particular
the children
to
him to do what he pleases
with the conditions in there forget the
danger level forget the possibility of
gunfire inside there
is the the sanitary conditions because
the place was not made for
um
normal living so all that we just
wouldn't
let me ask you this you have mentioned
that you had
a lot of input from experts
in
behavioral sciences and i was wondering
you had conflicting information uh we
had a gentleman testify yesterday about
the need to understand the biblical
context in which they were
operating which i agree with he
analogized it to somebody who spoke a
different language you would have
somebody who could negotiate with them
in their language and i think that's
sensible
but i'm wondering what kind of how did
you assimilate the various diverse
pieces of information you were getting
to make the soundest judgment you could
as to strategy well i'm your observation
about
being able to relate and stuff like that
maybe you don't always want to do that i
mean ask mr nester to to give you
the
the philosophy of negotiation when you
have someone who has a deep belief
system you might ask him to describe
that to you but
the um
each component
each shift of the
negotiators would report interesting or
insignificant events and all that was
controlled i don't know we have a very
short time i don't want to be rude but
i'm not suggesting that we necessarily
should
negotiate with someone who is psychotic
in their terms but we to the extent
possible we should try and understand
what that person thinks is going on
is that not correct i think one of the
great misunderstandings of this is
there's implications that the fbi
totally discounted mr karesh's religious
perspectives and i think nothing could
be further from the truth if you listen
to the hours upon hours of tape we
listened uh to david koresh's theology
and his points of view we never tried to
tell him that
that we understood that to the level
that he did but there's two consistent
themes that you'll hear from every
mental health expert uh that knows
anything about crisis intervention
crisis negotiation and that is that you
neither embrace someone's belief system
nor you do you discount it
i'm guess i'm not making myself clear i
am not suggesting because i'm not a
negotiator
how the negotiations should have been
conveyed i'm more interested in the
internal process of how the negotiating
experts came to understand
the behavior and the likely future
behavior this individual who some
believe was and i personally am not a
physician but appears to have been
psychotic in addition to being engaged
in a rather
strange
religious cult and how you assimilated
this information so that you could make
the best tactical decisions based on
your understanding of his
outlook online what i think i was trying
to get to is is we we learned from
listening to david koresh and
for many hours to try to understand the
individual we were dealing with and we
did not believe that he was psychotic or
out of touch with reality he manifested
primarily those attributes of an
anti-social personality that's a con man
an egotistical uh self-centered
individual who manipulated people and
events for his own personal gain and who
carelessly disregarded
his naive and gullible followers that's
how we read david kress now we didn't
confront him with that but we tried to
employ techniques that would help us
better understand him and to provide him
with the alternatives that he felt would
be in his best interest and we gave him
numerous options throughout
the negotiation process to take
advantage of all sorts of opportunities
whatever concerns he had we met they
were concerned about being able to
return to the compound because the
inhabitants had given up their worldly
goods we went out over the press
conference we went in on paper saying
that the compound would not be
confiscated uh he was concerned about
being able to continue his ministry in
prison we provided documentation from
the from the united states attorney's
office from the uh
from the sheriff and from the sac saying
you will be allowed to meet with your
followers in prison
we sent them in videotapes of the
children who had been released we made
transmitted messages to and from
relatives whatever the needs or desires
that they had we undertook extraordinary
methods to try to comply with those so
that david koresh would understand that
he'll be treated fairly with dignity
he'll have his opportunity to to speak
his peace and present his perspective on
events in in the public uh
forum as well as in the court of law and
yet despite those efforts um he chose
not to do it out of his own
self-interest
i think that's an important point my
time is up but very quickly i did ask
how much per day the siege was costing i
wonder if you have a figure but he could
answer that you may do so i'm sorry i
don't how much per day did the siege
cost you don't know i'm sorry mr
chairman i don't know all right we
probably can get that somewhere else ms
lofgren thank you very much mr shabbat
you're recognized for five minutes
jamar um
following up with mr schiff's line of
questioning uh did you tell mr sage
about the de garin arnold uh
agreement so to speak with correct did
you pass that on to him he was with us
uh when we were
all the time we spent with mr de guerin
in transporting him back and forth byron
was there also when we had him on the
phone
uh byron was there when he had to be he
learned mr stevens was there so he
learned that
yes mr sage did you pass that
information on to anyone
absolutely at the end of uh of each
shift uh
we would have a uh summary of of the
events of that uh which we referred to
as significant events which would be
documented for briefing the next shift
that came on
and we i didn't wait that long as soon
as we came back from that meeting
because of the potential value of this
uh
of this situation
we discussed it thoroughly amongst the
negotiation team the team leaders a team
coordinator who at that time had shifted
from uh
mr nesner to uh clint van zandt so
everyone knew basically that that
this agreement or or whatever you want
to call it between
korash and yourselves had been made the
concept was thoroughly discussed what
needs to be kept in context is that this
really was not a major departure in fact
we had the
the concept as i recall uh
was addressed uh at least
at the very early stages of it as i was
transporting uh mr degaran and mr
zimmerman uh
to a meeting and we tried to press them
for uh i tried to press them for a basic
time frame and it was at that time when
they mentioned that they were talking
about and i recall two to three days per
seal
well at that rate two to three days
would be
14 to 21 days at the outside so we
embrace that aspect of it as well in the
negotiations to try to keep an update as
to
to progress okay thank you mr smirk let
me ask you a couple questions
the fbi turned to you for professional
uh psychological and strategic advice
during the course of the siege is that
correct uh that is correct sir okay and
you provided the fbi with guidance
through a series of uh reports or
memoranda yes sir during the first week
of my stay in waco texas okay and in the
memoranda you stress the need to try to
ensure the safety of children correct
yes sir
and as i understand it in your first
series of memorandums i believe the the
first four
um you essentially suggested a waiting
strategy and you urge the fbi in fact to
back away from the house is that right
that is correct so the the strategy that
you were emphasizing was
wait and be patient okay
wait and be patient
now you believed and here i think i'm
quoting you that increased pressure on
koresh could eventually be
counterproductive
and could result in loss of life
correct yes and you believe that i i
assume yes okay
now however in the last memo
uh you suddenly recommended new measures
including cutting off negotiations and
that seemed to be a fairly dramatic
uh change in in the tone of the
memoranda at that time is that correct
yes sir okay i'd like to quote to you
uh something from the
washington times
this says that the memos urged just
referring to your memos
urged the fbi supervisors to wait koresh
out saying increased pressure could
eventually be counterproductive and
could result in loss of life which we've
just discussed
then it goes on to say
mr smarrick now retired said fbi
officials pressured him to change his
advice on how to resolve the situation
and in a fifth memo he made changes that
amounted to an endorsement of the fbi
raid
um
could you explain that
did you feel pressure from the fbi
not uh overt pressure it was more of a
self-imposed pressure
i had received information from fbi
headquarters that fbi officials were
not happy with the tone of my memos
from the standpoint that they felt it
was tying their hands meaning they were
not going to be able to increase any
type of pressure within that compound
and instead we're going to have to rely
on strictly negotiations
no one at fbi headquarters at any time
told me or directed me that
hey write different memos
but the analogy i like to give is one of
perhaps a youngster who's been
admonished by a parent
or has just a finger waved at him
we all have a tendency of wanting to
please our supervisors and i believe
what i did subconsciously is tone down
my memo in memo number five to more or
less fall in line with what they would
want to hear
so it was not any pressure from the fbi
it was pressure from myself to become
more of a team player to become more of
a team player right
was there anyone in particular that
wasn't pleased with the tone of the
memoranda
no name was mentioned to me other than
the the director of the fbi was not
happy but
it was made in passing
who told you that uh john douglas who
was my unit chief down at quantico john
douglas
thank you
well that may appear uh in memo number
five to be a dramatic change
in philosophy on my part
you might also notice in the earlier
memos which i had prepared meaning the
one on the seventh of march
i had made similar recommendations at
that particular time for consideration
so in reality what i said in the very
last memo was not in reality a dramatic
departure from what i had said earlier
the bottom line is
for 51 days the fbi did not ignore my
memos and in fact followed many of the
suggestions and recommendations which i
have provided
but you clearly felt
particularly early on
that it was important
particularly for the safety of the
children
uh that the strategy should be
weight and and not
move at that time so absolutely and the
fbi in fact did not move uh at that
particular time and for the longest
period of time went over and beyond what
normal negotiators might consider doing
in a situation like this
in my experience in the past of working
with negotiators in similar crises
for instance the idea of bringing in
attorneys to deal with the offender is
unheard of
the idea of bringing in religious
experts to discuss the matter with the
offender is unheard of and yet the fbi
considered all of these particular
options
and so the newspaper article that you're
referring to is not exactly accurate in
its portrayal of my my settlements
the fbi did not ignore my memos and in
fact they did in fact follow many of the
suggestions i had made mr chabot your
time has expired
mr watt you're recognized for five
minutes thank you mr chairman and i
yield my five minutes to mr conyers
i want to thank my colleague for
yielding to me
mr chairman our
distinguished member of judiciary ms
lofgren came in and apologized for being
away from the hearings
and it really touched me i i come and
apologize for being at the hearings
this thing has taken up
days and days of my life
she wanted to know how much money we
spent on the siege
i'll find out how much money and i'm
going to find out how much money we
spent on these hearings
uh we've got
all kind of problems in america this
thing could have been done in about half
the time at least
and although there have been good things
that have come out of it
i i can tell you and i know you can't
tell by the tone of my voice i'm really
getting tired of this stuff
but this is my job and i'm i'm here and
i'll do it
mr cavanaugh you stated earlier that you
felt that the atf sounded like pop guns
compared to the davidians
cameras
uh cannons is that right yes sir
is there any need for me to ask you to
elaborate on that or what what what's
behind that i think the only point
congressman there is that
you should know and the members should
know that
the nine millimeter guns that the atf
agents brought to that scene
were done for a purpose we knew there
was a lot of children in there we knew
there was a lot of women and innocents
in there and that's been discussed by
various members we we never alleged that
everyone in there was a criminal uh in
in our search warrant affidavit that was
not the case and with all these
innocents in there our teams our special
teams took mostly nine millimeter
firearms that they knew wouldn't
penetrate those walls they knew it and
go through and hit innocent children and
so
in essence the beating we took was
because we were trying not
to
have farms that would go through the
walls that's the only point i would make
very good thank you
nice meeting you mr jamar
you've taken a lot of knocks here in
your absence over the days about this
hearing from not only witnesses but
members here in the committee
and i'm glad to meet you and welcome you
here thank you i think you did a good
job under the circumstances
how did the range and assortment of the
davidian's weaponry
affect
your options in ending the siege
the
weapons we learned when we first arrived
were
the
dozens of
automatic weapons the fear of a 50
caliber machine gun it turned out to be
250 calibers with 10 shot magazines it
was not a machine gun those 50 calibers
produced
a lot of concern for us created a lot of
concern for us
it made us
be extremely careful to avoid
provocations many times we would if they
would have had mere 22s we'd have the
same attitude about the provocation
but the peril that the agents were in
was magnified by a great
degree because of the one automatic
gunfire that that presents and the power
of a 50 caliber 50 calibers an aircraft
that's the power we're talking about so
that caused us great concern one of the
great part is a 50 caliber ago i think
from uh our place up the street to here
would be pretty good
let's say ten blocks almost half a mile
i think maybe some people say 3 000
yards but i think
i think it could be shot 10 blocks that
way you're concerned
okay um
so it's it's because the arsenal of
machine guns or whatever they were in
hand grenades that the fbi was forced to
use armored personnel carriers around
the compound yes sir we wouldn't been
there without them
mr mccarthy you were tactical leader of
the los angeles
county police department swat team
and
my staff prepared the question the
premier swat team in the country
and believe me with maxine waters was
here
she wouldn't let me say that and i don't
i'm reading the staff
prepared question
for 13 years and as the leader of that
team did you ever have the occasion to
order the
use of cs gas
and did your department ever use cs gas
on an occasion where people not known
criminals were present
yes sir we used cs gas on numerous
occasions i personally over 200
always with
a positive resolution where the cs gas
even when used in extremely heavy
concentrations probably heavier than
existed at waco in a few circumstances
uh and in those incidents
nobody was injured from the tear gas and
as far as i know no one has
ever died of a concentration of cs gas
now that's one of the things i've
learned since the last time the
judiciary committee held hearings on
this subject because when general reno
was here
we were talking about poison gas and
you know the whole idea it was not
understood what this was and so i want
to tell you i've
i've learned a lot about cs gas and tear
gas and all of its variations on the
theme
you've then used
this kind of gas and enclosed spaces as
departments
and are you aware of any severe injuries
and do you have an opinion of the safety
of cs gas
and what about the abc error about the
manual that states cs1cs gas is supposed
to be used
first of all i am not aware of anybody
who has been
either killed or severely injured and
overcome i happen to be personally an
asthmatic and i've been in cs gas
hundreds of times myself personally what
about that lawyer that was here
yesterday that kept telling everybody to
take a trip out to quantico and
take a whiff if you think this uh not
i mean i i i shouldn't be reminding
people of that testimony because
yesterday was not a good day for me and
these hearings but
uh
where do where do people get this for
the american people either
the uh the fact is that uh tear gas is
extremely uncomfortable will cause uh
tremendous mucous flow saliva flow and
your eyes will water severely and you'll
want to keep them shut
it's very uncomfortable there's no
question of that but
it does not kill people
the study that was done
regarding cubic feet and the amount of
gas per cubic feet has been disclaimed
twice once in 1991 and once in 1993 by
the organization that authored it uh it
was authored in 1969 and the
international association of chiefs of
police disclaimed that study and advised
tear gas companies in their periodicals
to uh
uh refrain from using it because it was
outdated
time for mr watt thank you mr chairman
you're welcome mr sauder you're
recognized for five minutes
uh quick question mr mccarthy has the
lapd ever
children under 10 in a confined area
we have
not gassed children as far as i know
however in the similar circumstance uh
in a 51 day circumstance i would not be
in a disagreement i just wanted to
establish that in the 200 incidents that
were not children in a confined area
is that correct no sir we didn't have
that kind of an issue i understand that
um i wanted to ask mr jamar i'm i'm
actually confused i don't have a firm
opinion i want to get a clarification
in the tapes on march 4th
it's been alleged that david koresh was
the person who initially called about
the milk or did the fbi suggest a milk
did david koresh ask for milk
um
the report here says the fbi offered
milk in return did koresh initiate the
milk request
i think so yeah and and did uh was this
on the tapes let's get her that's
heather jones out
and then we'll send you the milk i'm
sorry would you be peter was no he's
behind me i couldn't hear you let's get
her out and then let me send you the
milk
in other words the core question here is
is that the fbi offered milk in return
for the release of some children right
yesterday we heard that um koresh
believed that the promise was violated
because that and that the tapes suggest
that there is the phrase now it may be
other phrases in it too let's get her
out and then let me send you the milk
well that was an effort to this remember
march 4. it's an effort to establish a
quid pro quo an exchange here and the
next day she came out heather jones
it was but
it was an effort to get that done she
did come out but that exchange was an
effort by the negotiator
to establish that type of relationship
and and and to communicate with people
so do you believe that then not sending
the milk after she came out the next day
gave karesh some reason to doubt
uh
whether or not you were going to follow
through and negotiated you don't believe
that was a negotiated deal send her out
and we'll send you milk i don't think it
was at all he chose let her go for his
reasons um he never involved himself in
the quid pro quo
i think that's out of context i don't
believe we ever made a deal with mr
kresh that we didn't follow through on
uh and mr jamar is right in a classic
hostage situation which this was not and
we've never characterized it as such
although others have in a classic
situation like that the individual
holding the hostages is doing so to
compel the authorities to fulfill a
demand we didn't have that situation
here whatsoever so it was very difficult
for us to make these quid pro quo
agreements with david koresh but what we
would do is he would we would do some
act of positive nature send in milk or
do send in a tape or whatever it might
be and occasionally he would do
something positive in return
but you couldn't pin him down on making
a firm promise for a firm act of good
faith on our part
i'm i'm still a little confused i may
ask some uh written questions afterwards
but it helps some i want to yield the
balance of my time to chairman mccullum
mr sage you said earlier
that in a discussion with mr degarin
about the agreement on the written seals
the interpretation of the seals that he
indicated to you that it would take
20 days approximately two or three days
per seal to do this when did he have
this conversation with you when was this
on the 14th of april or was it before
that about the writing of the the
interpretation of the seals and it would
that it would take two or three days per
interpretive letter my recollection is
that it was approximately the 14th i
don't know
specifically but that's a general time
mr jamar what i want to know from you on
this very same type of point is that you
have given us an indication that
you were aware of all this going on you
really didn't have any confidence that
koresh would ever come out
but that this seal interpretation
writing was to take place you've also
told us that there was no
evidence over the weekend of the last
two days before this uh last assault
occurred that any progress was being
made
on the writing of these at any time did
you ever indicate to mr de garan that
between the 14th when this
whole arrangement was being discussed
and the writing were to occur
that there wasn't going to be 20 days
or that if he didn't show some progress
he didn't bring one of them out within a
couple of days
that was going to be the end of it in
other words did you give him any
indication mr de garan that his client
didn't have
any real time to do this and or had to
show some good faith by producing
something immediately well i think the
idea of producing it
was clear to us both that we expected
something they used two to three days
for each one so we expected some
progress in the next two or three days
but you never told mr gagarin that if it
didn't happen
it was all over
or something something else was going to
happen well i didn't know something else
was going to happen well you did at some
point
i did the 17th i'm not going to call mr
degaran and tell him we have an
operational plan we're going to actually
explain the operational plan but i would
have expected you knowing you didn't
have any faith in this to begin with
didn't believe in it and begin with that
you would have at least given him some
indication
that his client you know better hurry up
and produce something now
because we're not sitting around here
for 20 days on this you ought to know
it's highly improbable we're going to
spend 20 days sitting around here
waiting for him to produce one of these
things
did you ever make that clear to him
i think he knew that he didn't indicate
that to us yesterday by any stretched
imagination in fact he indicated to us
quite the contrary yesterday he
indicated that he was deeply
disappointed and that he would consider
himself greatly deceived by you had
he learned what apparently he is now
learning today that all along you didn't
uh you didn't really expect this to
happen and he didn't have it he thought
this was a commitment i mean that's what
he said i don't know merited this i'm
not trying to reject it i saw the
testimony i know i know what he said and
it was he's been quoted and saying that
in the past in the media where he said
that i said there's plenty of time
and there would have been plenty of time
if there had been some production we
would have stayed we wouldn't we
wouldn't have done what we did on the
19th well but again there have been some
as production again my point is you
didn't really hammer that home to him
you said you didn't need to know that
you thought that was a given obviously
there was a miscommunication here in
some form or fashion or at least it
seemed to me let me ask one last
question while we're involved in this
area altogether uh with regard to
releasing people there has been some
question about
uh that that was made by mr daguerreon
and mr zimmerman yesterday and a couple
of the others i think maybe mr tabor
that i believe mr jamar you indicated
that when one of the witnesses or one of
the davidians i think kathy schroeder
was was let out early you played the
tape back in maybe mr sage indicated
that
with her relating how
the things were going all right for her
and so on that was pretty early on in
this uh that was in in march correct
and and what i'm getting at my question
is
that mr de guerin or mr zimmerman i
forgot in which mr taber i think
corroborated indicated that
along the way
into march april whatever uh
that there was some
some witnesses some i mean some people
had been in that compound who came out
not witnesses but davidians who were put
in jail
who were not given the kind of freedom
that one would have expected maybe them
to be that everybody i think they said
everybody came out was put in jail
uh that
they were separated from their children
that the child protective services got
the children and that this was a bad
message going back in there now would
you care to respond to that please uh
the first two people who released were
elderly lady first two adults excuse me
were elderly ladies they were charged
with capital murder i complained to the
u.s attorney and they changed it to
material witness warrants
it was a horrible message sent back but
they still kept them in jail
i don't know how long they stayed in
jail i don't think they stayed in jail
for for very long those two ladies
i could be mistaken but i think it's
worth checking in i don't think they're
in jail that long i think they got out
now the other adults who came out
were held on material witness warrants
thereafter and were held in jail now
there was never parents and children out
together never so never were parents and
children separated by by authorities
there was never an instance where parent
and child came out together
thank you very much um let's see
miss jackson lee you're recognized for
five minutes
mr chairman thank you very much
and i want to thank the witnesses for
being here
today and
some very important issues i think we've
already heard testimony isolating
the
actions of mr koresh as being plainly
anti-social
behavior and anti-social personality
but i imagine as these hearings are
unfolding particularly for you gentlemen
the american people might wonder again
and we've we've heard this question
query to you and asked why didn't you
wait they might be asking that question
i think they also should know that about
34 persons
went out on your clock up until about
march 23rd that people were coming out
they were abandoning
the circumstances mr jamar i'm going to
ask this question you you might want to
say that how many came out
but i do want you to again for us
uh give me
why we moved from the
negotiating posture of trust and
calmness
and we want to work with you
to the position of stress heightening
the stress creating adversity
um and i want to ask my other question
as well afterwards
you've been in the fbi you'll tell me
for how many years i know you're a
senior member of the yeah when i retired
i was 25 and a half years 25 and a half
years this is a very large nation would
you imagine in your service that there
are a variety of groups
living in
different ways whether they happen to be
pacifists or whether they happen to be
people who are environmentalists living
in
uh very rugged conditions across this
nation and i would ask you as to whether
or not your understanding is that they
still live in peace
across this nation although they may be
different and we may not even know of
their existence or the fact that they're
there you may know it and i'd like to
ask that question i'll have that those
two questions answered before i moved to
mr nashville yeah let me answer the
second one first but it's okay
i think there's plenty of groups of
people who are living together
in peace and doing just fine
the difficulties and they are different
they are different they're going to be
you know growing different food and
doing whatever totally odd behavior
they're totally
foreign to most people the difference
between this group and all others is
this is a group of people who were
absolutely devoted to a person who would
abuse everything about them
who would abuse religion to for his end
to suit any purpose he wanted he would
abuse any of their assets any of their
family members
any of them to serve him and what he had
absolute devotion when that devotion
faltered or if you didn't follow
discipline out the door you went
that's the way he controlled things and
that was it that's the difference
between this group
and 99.9 of the others i pray i hope
there's i don't this is so this is
absolutely extraordinary control here i
like to think that these type of groups
are extremely rare and we won't run into
people like this we've already
established the enormous number of
weapons that were in the compound i wish
you were here yesterday with the lawyers
the balance would have added to our
understanding because the question
becomes
why did the other individuals who were
with their faculties they uh were
trained and educated people did not
separate or distinguish themselves from
this gentleman mr david koresh who the
documents reinforce over and over this
bizarre personality and bizarre attitude
and actions why couldn't they get
separated and how come you can reach
through to that component of the uh of
the company steve stevenstein is a
perfect example of your the person that
you described here's a highly educated
person with a master's degree in
religion
he's i think he was
a successful person his ability to
support himself married to judy
schneider
comes to he's recruited by courage in
hawaii he leaves hawaii
to come to live in these conditions in
fact he talked about during the
negotiations he said you think you gave
up something i came here from hawaii
so
he was very conscious of all that but he
gave up not only his
his his life to come there he gave up
his wife to courage they weren't able to
have children together he admitted that
yes
he and judy were unable to have children
together
she had a child by courage
i mean that it's the degree of devotion
by this man who is highly educated a
successful person by any anybody's
measure
he gave himself totally and we worked on
him and worked on him and worked on him
there was an instance where i had an
occasion afterwards to talk to his
sisters on a television program and they
asked me why didn't we let them talk to
him
and i said
when's the last time you saw him did he
come home that were you able to convince
him to stay they said no i want the
american people to know that you made
those individuals separate inquiries
because it is a question why we move
from stress to then from rather from
trust to stress but you did make an
effort to get to individuals to separate
them out and i do want to move quickly
to my next question i i think you've
made that point next i am going to try
to ask you a question on that matter
as we move toward the cs gas
determination i think mr mccarthy has
indicated that the gas does not kill
um is that what you just said mr
mccarthy the gas did not kill that's
correct um it is frightening however gas
people attribute explosions and
tragically fire
uh mr jamal simple question did you want
those people to come out alive
absolutely in terms of the cs gas and
its decision to use it and utilize it
did you have an architectural
understanding of the location or the
structure of that building and where you
are prepared to isolate isolate out
people excuse me and get them out did we
have the roots out for them to come so
that you could effectively be looking
for these people to be pouring out at
the time of the gas being inserted and
how would that track with the bulldozers
going in okay the the premise of the
delivery of the gas first was to the
corner of the compound there's not a
picture up there now but every i think
everybody has this this image in their
head
on the what we call if someone can put
the picture up i appreciate it the red
green corn is where we started the the
premise of the plan was to deliver that
gas
there and the idea was gas is in your
compound we're we're going to make your
compound uninhabitable and then we're
going to back away
but when they fired upon the first thing
only one tank approached
the we've had put concert give me the
sound it makes
fired upon you can you make the sound
i'm sorry the the automatic gun fire was
piercing at the at the tank as it came
up as it drove up what that did it was
cause us to deliver gas in the whole
compound particularly the tower to try
to take
that part away but the plan was to make
the building uninhabitable
and with the this is the type of stuff
if it gets on let's say a loaf of bread
or a
milk bottle or glass or anything and it
just stirs up all the time it just it
just never goes away the plan we
expected to do that for 48 hours we
didn't expect that we expect some to
come out immediately we expect it would
take us 48 hours to contaminate the
whole place if they didn't respond to us
of course if they would have said stop
we want to come out it would have been
the end of the gassing right there
that'd been the end of it right there
my time has expired mr micah you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman mr chairman just
one thing i want to keep the record
always clear i heard somebody on the
other side of the aisle and when you get
involved with a bunch of attorneys you
have to make sure you keep the record
straight i'm not an attorney i passed
this out yesterday
and it deals with the law and i read the
law as it is in in
in texas relating to uh
to its
uh use of force uh in arrests in in
texas
i did not comment on it i asked the
texas texas rangers when in fact if that
was the law
and they replied in the affirmative then
i quoted cert from uh
from the report
of
the treasury department their conclusion
certainly an armed assault by a hundred
agents had to be seen as an attack
independent of who fired the first shot
not my commentary i have never said
that there is any justification for the
the killing of four
atf agents or and wounding of others and
i want to make that perfectly clear
and i'll see anybody outside who
disputes me on those facts mr cavanaugh
let's go through you were uh
you were this morning very emotionally
describing your participation i want to
get to some of the points leading up to
your participation you and i have this
uh this memo uh relating to your
comments at a waco administrative review
that was done in november after all this
occurred
first meeting you attended in december
of 92
uh you had said to
cereben you'll have to negotiate this
one is that correct
yes sir pretty much
uh second meeting uh you stressed two
main points you need to negotiate with
quresh if at all possible and two remove
correction as top five lieutenants from
the compound if at all possible those
were your recommendations correct yes
sir
and then you uh you said
a ruse could be used to get correction
as top followers outside the compound
correct yes sir
uh then you were taken away from this
this is the second meeting and you came
back and you were well when you left you
left with the impression that the
houston uh
division had decided uh to siege the
compound is that correct
well left with that impression yes
then in january uh you were very
surprised to learn a new turn of the
events
uh that they changed their plan and that
serbian had said he had new information
and they were going to use a different
approach is that correct yes sir
uh then you said that that you read you
read the plans and it said there was no
provision for a negotiator
uh as you had originally stressed and
two there was only one public
information officer assigned to the plan
were those your objections yes sir
all right then kavanaugh uh you later
raised questions
you said uh you were concerned because
only different bits of information were
given at different meetings it was
conceivable that one would have received
more information on the types and
numbers
of guns at one briefing that was one of
your concerns wasn't it
uh
sorry congressman as i recall it was the
types and uh bits of information that
meetings but we didn't know you didn't
know exactly the the this quantity this
vast
quantity of weapons that were available
and to be used against you was one of
your concerns
or you said it might have been at
different meetings and not everybody had
the full picture okay i don't recall it
exactly i'm sorry and then you asked
also uh
uh i think you urged serbian to call a
thing uh to well to call the thing off
and and serbian wanted to proceed on
saturday
uh but he said the helicopters weren't
ready and the the training was not
complete that's saturday night before
the raid is that correct
yes sir uh
i always only felt this should be
negotiated
i'm sorry i'm sorry that's okay and the
morning of the raid
uh it's not like this
the uh waco times had already done the
story right yes sir and you were
concerned about this right yes right and
the morning of the raid wasn't that uh
you were in this observation thing
didn't you see newspaper more newspaper
and media activity in fact i think you
identified a waco times uh uh vehicle
right near the front door of the
compound is that correct yes sir and
then you said that
uh the decisions were ongoing uh wait
you said the go versus no ghost go was
in the hands of wenacki and headquarters
further furthermore
serbian told you the discussions were
ongoing between atf headquarters and the
treasury and said that he felt as if uh
his that your input did not matter since
the decision making was uh proceeding at
a much higher level
than your level is that correct yes sir
that that would have been not sunday
morning that would have been uh probably
more friday and saturday
well
all right we'll uh go on from that
uh you were also concerned that uh that
there was bad information from uh
rodriguez is that correct
concerned it was bad information yes
that that uh that uh rodriguez wasn't
giving a good information
and ever what i'm trying to say is at
every point you express concerns about
this
yes sir i can elaborate if you like i i
did
then uh when you found out that that
that uh this had been you know sort of a
media event too that got out of hand
that uh in fact that uh the press miss
wheeler and some of the others there
were media out in the front of the place
she said
uh and this is you you said that
everyone at the undercover house was
wondering whether the raid would be
called off
is that was that your comments that
morning
yes sir i think there's varying degrees
of of apprehension that we felt uh in in
the undercover house and uh the other
thing sir you know
i'm only sent here temporarily to find
out what went on with government
resources personnel agents we're not
here to get anybody we just want to find
out what we never even made a statement
that that these reports were you know
were false or anything mr hartnett
though who was overseeing a lot of this
operation talked about this report this
inside
uh treasury report and it said that
that report was filled with distortions
omissions and in some cases things that
were simply untrue i believe it was done
for political reasons the politics of
the situation became more important than
the people involved and then he resigned
he said that i didn't say that these
people on this side of the panel didn't
say it this is the treasury
agent in charge of the whole situation
what what do you think who's who's
responsible mr congressman i can only
speak to the treasury report as it as it
addresses my role
and and i feel like they were candid and
fair with me i can tell you that they
were extremely grueling
and talking to them i mean it was very
rough
they left no stone unturned in my
situation
i felt like they
they portrayed my role fairly
and that's all i could say
mr taylor mr taylor you want to be
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman and i want to
thank mr condid for working with me on
this
gentlemen
a lot has been made
by some people on
in this room
about the use of cs gas especially when
there were older people and children
present
but as one of the earlier witnesses said
today david kresh got rational people to
do totally irrational things they would
give their wives to them
they would
they would give their wives to quest
they would give everything their own
request they would let him have sex with
their very young children
then
it would follow that crash could have
told these people
get up
and walk out
and they would have listened wouldn't
they
isn't there becoming at least i seem to
be noticing more and more
a case where people who do despicable
things
have increasingly started surrounding
themselves with innocence as human
shields
and isn't it accurate to say that koresh
kept little kids and old women and old
men around him as human shields
well i'll answer that i don't
he kept people around to be
for his
for his personal use
the shields was the appropriate time to
use a shield to use them to shield if it
was something else you'd use them for
that
but i i'd like everyone else regret the
death of those young people and those
old people but the bottom line is if
that man had had a shred of courage or
shred of decency
he could have told them to walk out
at any time at any time for 51 days let
the record show
but that coward could have turned to
those children and said lee you're in
danger here you could have turned to the
old people and said leave you're in
danger to you
he chose not to do so uh could not have
done that because not only with the
children shields for him
he recognized the fact that he was the
father of those children the mothers of
those children were under age
when they gave birth
which means with dna testing it can be
proven that he had carnal knowledge of
women who were underage he knew that if
he came out of that particular compound
he was not going to prison as a
religious martyr who defended his
religious faith he was going to prison
as an individual who was a child
molester
that is one reason why i believe under
those circumstances was david koresh
going to surrender and come out of that
compound alive
thank you for adding
can i add something that absolutely and
that is i think there's a
misunderstanding that's occurred today
about there only being a few occasions
where specific surrender
discussions took place and i think the
record should show if anyone really
listens to those negotiation tapes uh
the hundreds of hours of tapes koresh
represented day in day out that in fact
he was coming out
it was a rare occasion where he would
say i'm not coming out almost every day
he said he was coming out he just simply
didn't do it
so for him to represent to the attorneys
or to represent to us throughout this
was hardly
brand new information he'd been saying
to this this to us every single day
i wonder since i know my time is running
out it is a rather large panel i'm going
to ask you the same question i've asked
every other time
it is it you've had we've all had now
two years of hindsight
and many of you were there on scene yes
anything that you've seen anything
you've read anything that you've heard
justify the murder of those four atf
agents conway lebloo todd mckeehan
robert williams
stephen willis
and the in the wounding of 20 more by
david corrections followers
as anything that you've seen justified
that because even the two defense
criminal defense attorneys yesterday
who first said yeah it was justified
when i asked them which one of these
agents should have died
they backfilled real fast
so is there anything that you gentlemen
have seen that justifies their murder
excuse me nothing would have justify the
murders and in fact what i saw as a
behavioral scientist was a calculated
plan by david koresh to put his plan of
action into action
meaning he wasn't a peaceful religious
order minding their own business perhaps
collecting some weapons
he went out of his way to attract the
attention of law enforcement so that
there would have to be some sort of a
response in the future
and so we learned through the
investigation by atf agents for instance
that he had his followers
get credit cards and run up the limits
so that he knew somebody was going to be
investigating that there were
allegations of child abuse so he knew
someone was going to be coming out to
the compound to investigate that
he collected so much arms and ammunition
beyond what is necessary for your own
self-defense that he knew sooner or
later either atf the sheriff's
department somebody was going to have to
investigate that particular matter
when atf showed up at that particular
day he had several choices in front of
him he could have surrendered he could
have fired warning shots in the air to
stay off of my property he chose none of
those particular events instead he
waited for the atf agents to come up to
the compound and then he ambushed them
in order to put his plan into effect
david koresh in my mind as a behavioral
scientist is not a religious martyr
he is a psychopathic criminal a killer
who used religion
in order to exploit people for his own
benefit
mr kavanagh
mr taylor there's no reason in america
that anyone should shoot on a law
enforcement officer
serving a warrant
mr sage
i would agree wholeheartedly with what
you've heard i'd also state that
i'm very concerned frankly of the
precedent set by
anyone embracing the concept that uh
that criminals have a right
to uh to exercise
uh
justifiable force what they feel
justifiable force against
officers that are exercising a lawful
warrant
that puts
all of our society in in harm's way mr
jamal
i think that observation is uh adds to
the others
that
during a period of time when the
the defense in many cases is
that the defendant becomes the victim
and everyone else is forgotten
and he says perfect instance of that
certainly agree with those comments uh
as we've heard
mr koresh told robert rodriguez that he
knew atf was coming so he was fully
aware of who was coming to his front
door that day the way they were equipped
the way they were tired and to take that
kind of action against him is just
simply murder and there's no way you can
justify that
if you're going to take away from law
enforcement the opportunity to survive
serving a search warrant issued by a
judge which is absolutely valid on its
face and you're going to condemn law
enforcement to being totally incapable
of supporting a democracy
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr condi mr bryant you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman at this time i
would yield my time to my distinguished
colleague from arizona
thank you mr bryant
the topic of this panel really is
negotiations and i want to go into that
issue in a little more depth uh we
established earlier that your goal was
to get people out without any more
deaths that obviously should have been
an important goal
at some point in time however
a decision was reached that negotiations
were not making progress and that you
had to do something further and indeed
that led to the gas insertion plan mr
sage
the department of justice own report
pretty much lays all that at your feet
it says
there was a meeting in washington on
april 14th the attorney general that
appears
was resisting the gas insertion plan
she was frustrated she asked the
question of why now
and it says both it and an interview i
have say that
people were directed to talk with you
and that they did talk with you and this
report says that there was a two-hour
telephone conversation with webb hubble
and you in which you said
further negotiations with the subjects
in the compound would be fruitless
that the only people koresh had released
were older people or people who had
given him problems during the time they
were in the compound or children whom he
had not fathered
it says
further
that you advised hubble that quresh had
been disingenuous with his discussions
with you about the seven seals is all of
that accurate yes sir it is okay
and it goes on to say you were convinced
that the fbi had not succeeded in
getting anyone released from the
compound through negotiation there were
35 people released whether or not
ultimately there was a total of 46 if
you
if you subscribe to my definition 35
people that actually came out prior to
the 19th why would you tell webb hubble
that you had not succeeded and get
anybody out through negotiations because
my definition was the quid pro quo and
that's exactly the context in which it
was expressed to him we were discussing
only if they came out as a result of a
quid pro quo was that a success if i can
finish my uh response to you congressman
i'll be happy to uh
what i told uh mr hubbell
was that from a
definition of a of a negotiated effort
normally a hostage negotiation this
instance it was not
that we had
very limited success in a true
definition of a negotiated release of
individuals i am i was convinced at that
time i am absolutely convinced now that
the only people that mr kareshwa let out
or directed out in hindsight which we
didn't have the privilege of then
were the elderly the infirmed
those children which were not of his
direct wine lineage and troublemakers i
read that i know you have a right to
answer your question i just have a very
limited amount of time
answer can i apologize it goes on to say
hubble recalls sage saying he believed
there was nothing more here than
negotiators could do to persuade
koresh to release anyone else or to come
out himself that's overstated my comment
to him was that we
something to the effect
that
we had not abandoned negotiations and as
i mentioned earlier
uh i personally did not give up hope in
negotiations until practically 12 30 on
the uh the afternoon of the 19th of
april well here it says in a memo from
the justice department an interview of
webster hubble it says
the attorney general was told
negotiations would and this is based on
the conversation that you had she was
told that negotiations would not get
anyone else out of the combat compound
at that and that negotiations were at an
impasse
now all of this is happening on april 14
and april 15th in point of fact the
defense attorneys who are here whom you
can disbelieve if you want
clearly believed themselves
that negotiations weren't at an impasse
that in fact
the seven seal strategy was a new one
and that it might work
my question is did you advise webster
hubble of those new negotiations based
on the seven seals of what the attorneys
the defense attorneys believed about
them and give him a chance to pass that
information on to the attorney general
first of all the seventh seal issue was
anything but new we were hit with the
concept of uh of explaining the seven
seals and they would all come out
literally right from the uh from the
first day in fact uh i believe the
evening of the 28th of february
uh my conversation with mr hubbell was
that the negotiations were at an impasse
as far as the possibility of a
substantial number or substantial flow
of people out of that compound in the
near future
foreseeable future
i i did not then nor do i now feel that
we were at
a process where we should abandon
negotiations
so you you did not think that their new
renewed sense of enthusiasm on the 14th
as expressed to uh mr jamar
was valid at all and
and you thought they were just mistaken
about that i think my recollection of
this is that the the emphasis placed on
this this new timetable which was
relayed once again by the attorneys not
by courish ever
was came after this discussion with mr
hubbell in in my recollection it did not
change anything ultimately because we
continued to press
for any indication that this was a true
genuine effort and that there was
progress being made there never was and
let me let me explore that a little
further
this was brought forth as a as a viable
allegedly viable option on the 14th and
has been stressed significantly here
on the we continued to press as to
whether or not this was valid through
the the course of negotiations on the
16th
i judy schneider who during the course
of of conversation negotiations
expressed that she was the primary
typist here
indicated to us that due to the
equipment they had inside that this
could take up to a year to complete she
was based in and then you gave her more
different equipment didn't you well we
sent in first of all uh tapes for the
the manual typewriters they had we
stress that if
that the concept is fine but we can we
can provide you with all the equipment
you want if you just come out we will
facilitate and in fact the the sheriff
in dorset concept on the
we continued that probe as recently as
the evening of the 18th of april
the evening before the raid
uh
steve schneider admitted to the
negotiators that he had not seen the for
and i'm paraphrasing here but the the
quotes are available today i'm going to
run out of time so the first page of the
first season
yet let me switch topics i have to ask
you one more question yes sir
this is in fact not a routine hostage
situation never was
that's been testified to the point is
you had some people on the inside who to
your knowledge were not involved in
criminal conduct the children could not
have been involved in criminal job
conduct they are incapable of forming
criminal intent so you had
people on the inside who were there but
to the best of your knowledge they were
not being held at gunpoint and indeed
mrs schneider you just mentioned one of
the purpose of the
microphones was to be able to or the
speakers was for you be able to
broadcast a message back in so that if
koresh wasn't telling them everything in
the negotiations they could hear that
correct my concern is and my question of
you is there came a point in time
sometime over that weekend and i'd like
both you mr sage and mr jamar to answer
this there came a point in time
where
not only had you decided that further
negotiations were hopeless and told fbi
washington and they told the attorney
general washington and the decision was
made to go with the gas plan
my question was is
given that this isn't a normal hostage
situation there are not guns being held
at the heads of all of the mothers or
all of their children forcing them to
stay in the compound
wasn't there a duty
before you inserted the gas
to warn the mothers and the children
middle-aged children you know children
they were cognizant if they could
that the negotiations had failed on the
chance that koresh hadn't told them and
to give them some last chance you're not
dealing with normal hostages who have a
gun at their head who can't jump off the
airplane you're dealing with women and
children who if koresh doesn't tell them
that the negotiations are broken down
and you don't tell them that the
negotiations are broken down they have
no reason to leave the compound and yet
a point in time comes when you start
inserting gas was not there an
obligation
before you push the gas in to allow them
the regular already has the right to
finish this question he started it when
the yellow light was on this is the same
courtesies then because i've been cut
off and was not able to get my question
answered when the red light went on
regular order wasn't there an
obligation as to those innocent children
and to women that weren't involved in
criminal conduct to at least warn them
that negotiations had broken down and
maybe not telling tear gas was coming in
but tell them that some confrontation
was going to occur and if they want to
run out the back door they better do it
soon
do i have time to answer that all the
time you need to answer yes mr sage let
me just mr jamar too if you want please
go ahead it's kind of a three question
question
uh first whether or not uh there was an
expression that that we were at a total
impasse and that further negotiation was
hopeless i believe was a term that you
used and i've seen that referred to in
the report that's correct
as i mentioned before i think that's an
overstatement it may well have been the
concept or the
the recollection of mr hubble i can't
speak for him but i can't speak for
myself
i'd never abandoned the concept or the
hope that negotiations could
successfully and peacefully resolve this
matter
my statement to him at the time and
there were several people privy to this
conversation both in washington dc and
uh in waco
was that i felt that we were at an
impasse
that we had not gotten uh a single child
out which again was our first uh
priority since the fifth of march
the fifth of march this is the 15th
of april
uh
not that it was completely over but a
realistic assessment of it was that we
had obviously reached a very significant
point that we needed to uh to factor
into further consideration and this was
a consensus of the negotiation team not
just me mr hubbell wanted to talk to
a member of the negotiation team and i
was selected to participate in that
conversation and was more than willing
to do so number two
as far as the release of those children
we specifically from the first day and
it's been
elaborated upon quite efficiently by mr
cavanaugh and i think by the rest of the
panel that was our primary focus the
last child came out the 5th of march
we continued to press there was one
point in time when david core said to
the negotiator
that the rest of these kids are
different we said wait a minute david
you said that all those kids were your
kids and they were precious and so forth
and this again is paraphrasing but we
can get you the exact quote or if it's
already available to you
he later said very specifically and
candidly because i remember it because i
i will never forget it it raised the
hackles on the back of my neck he said
basically
these are my biological children and he
said it in such a fashion that it was
very clear if not articulated that they
were not coming out that was the 7th of
march
we continued to pursue every viable
option to try to get not only just those
children but everyone out of the
compound the last aspect of it was a
notification it's a very valid question
there was
continuing notification continuing
opportunity for them to come out for 51
days we talked during the course of this
matter
a total of
949 conversations during the course of
the negotiations
949 a total of 214 hours almost 215
and we talked to a total of 68 people
including mothers and children every
single person that we talk to we ask
them at least two core questions are you
there voluntarily and can you please
make arrangements to come out every
single one of them said they did not
want to exit that compound that has to
be a part of this record we tried to get
them out constantly for 51 days 24 hours
a day seven days a week we were
available to facilitate that as far as
formal notice
when ultimately the decision was made
to go in the morning of the 19th of
april to exercise what we felt was the
lowest
potential threshold of threat to those
people and that's the introduction of of
a non-lethal tear gas
i was the one that put the telephone
call into the compound at 5 59 in the
morning that was one of the toughest
calls i ever made at the same time that
i was on the phone i had a microphone
clipped to my
vest
informing everybody over that pa system
that we were in the process of
delivering a non-lethal tear gas into
the compound we were not entering the
compound that's why we referred to it as
not being an assault we've taken a lot
of lumps on that comment
the reason i said that is we had no
intention nor did we ever
enter that compound in an armed fashion
that was a formal notice to every mother
every child
every parent anybody that had a common
shred of decency i'm telling you i've
been through cs gas a number of times
and i would move heaven and earth
to get my children out of that type of
an environment that's why it was
introduced congressman to initiate
an environment which would
cause those people to come out safely
not even orderly at the end before the
fire and certainly after the fire we beg
them i beg them
to come out
through any exit they could and to
follow the instructions of the agents
waiting to provide them with medical
assistance and take them into custody
thank you mr jamar
yes sir thank you
i think the duty also includes that we
don't sit still and let their children
die of disease we don't sit still and
that their children continue to be
abused we don't sit still and let coerce
pick the time to leave the compound at
one o'clock in the morning with a horde
of people with a child under one arm and
a machine gun under the other
i think that duty extends to
ensuring that we do everything in our
power to get those people out but also
at the same time make the area safe for
them so that's why we cleared this stuff
out to make it harder for chorus to do a
breakout one thing all of us were
concerned the first day was a breakout
where it's you know suicide by cop is a
one way of putting it
it was something we feared absolutely
and when we learned of the um
of the suicide pact which we didn't
learn for several weeks
and when it wasn't cooperate until well
afterwards but it was a fear
that that duty extended to doing
everything physically and
emotionally and mentally and and through
any speech or anything else we could do
that duty extended and everything we
brought to that place
and that duty we i think we exercised
i think and and the best way we could do
it and the failure was our failure no
question about that but that failure was
made certain by david korsh
thank you uh mr conditch you're
recognized for five minutes thank you mr
chairman um mr jamar mr sage and the
rest of the panel i'd like to focus just
a little bit
during this whole episode
the news media the news networks
reported prophecy
by mr quresh
and terms like all the saints will die
through explosion blood and fire
these were prophecies that he had been
making
my questions to you and is
did you ever consider
his prophecy
as a possibility that
there would be mass suicide by fire i
mean to me it seems that
that you had to take that serious and
did you make preparations for that that
there would be a fire
uh what what was your planning process
for that i mean my understanding is that
you had to call the waco fire department
to help you you put out the fire and i'm
wondering did you anticipate there might
be some substance some truth to the
prophecy did you take that serious and
did you plan for it let me answer the
suicide portion first and then i'll turn
it over to mr jamar
one of the toughest things as a
negotiator i've been a negotiator for 18
years in the fbi
uh is the issue of addressing an
individual and and you can well imagine
it that may be potentially suicidal with
that very topic but the mental health
professionals will tell you that that is
precisely the manner in which that
should be done and that's exactly what
we did repeatedly
and that can be brought to your
attention in the form of
of the negotiation tapes we address both
with with schneider with uh directly
with korish with wayne martin with the
number of the individuals but
particularly those in leadership roles
the possibility as bluntly as do you
intend to commit suicide
the responses were uh were
overwhelmingly uh that they did not
uh course on on occasion said he was too
young to die in there
uh
schneider mentioned specifically that
that was against their religion it was a
sin an unpardonable sin i believe he
mentioned
but we continued to address it we also
framed questions with the assistance of
the behavioral science people
to try to determine or elicit from them
answers that they might not realize
would would lend itself to
a very probative uh analysis of of what
their true mindset was
were their responses terminal
indicating the possibility of suicide or
were they long-term in nature indicating
the the possibility of
survival
in almost every single instance their
response to specific questions and
subtle questions were survival oriented
we felt very confident probably too
confident
that these people did not intend
to
exercise an option of a mass suicide
and we move forward with with efforts
along those lines i'll turn it over to
mr jamar
mr conden to answer your question on the
the planning for the possibility of fi
part of our
operations plan
which was very comprehensive i think you
have access to a copy of it part of it
was local emergency medical service and
and uh to include local ambulances that
we could bring in to help us we brought
in a lot of our own helicopters
everything else
but
part of the concern was fire suppression
the number one fire department was bell
mead actually not not waco
we had bell mead fire department uh the
primary responder which um
we
had a
response time a minimum of um
one unit eight minutes two units and
twelve minutes
uh waco fire department there's a
description of the several units here a
response time of minimum of two pumper
trucks within ten minutes that's we had
that access to us right there we didn't
have fire trucks at this at the site
because we viewed fire as a possibility
and when you when you the the references
you cited theological and others there
were direct references but not as many
as portrayed by witnesses i think in the
past here
i think
it was a possibility hardly a
probability
there's a lot of reason not to bring the
fire trucks one is operational security
but the other is is what occurred
is when the fire fire did start
and the fire trucks did arrive i didn't
let them in i held them at the creck
point
because i didn't want the firemen to
drive into gunfire i just wasn't going
to permit it it was a it's a terrible
thing a very terrible decision to have
to make
but i didn't it didn't has it that
wasn't that it took me that two seconds
to make it but it we held the fire
trucks so that was our fire planning
let me ask you could i add to this
day in day out david koresh preached an
apocalyptic
uh theology so fire and brimstone was a
regular part of his of his dialogue so
it's hard to discern is this his general
theological approach to the ending of
the world or is he specifically talking
about a fire and uh while we never
trusted it one way or the other the
remedy we chose to deal with it as mr
sage suggested we confronted them with
the time and again what their intentions
were and at no time did he specifically
say we're going to start this place on
fire
i understand that was there any concern
or consideration given to using a
suppressant like avalon or something
have making that available you do you
know what i'm talking about
um it's a fire suppressant how do you
deliver it
well they have a way of doing it in
other places on ships and and things but
apparently you did not
that was not a consideration no it
wasn't
the possibility the problem is the same
with any delivery system is the same as
the firearm at night but you just
couldn't bring it in because of the
safety of the fire trucks
okay well thank you very much um
whatever little time i have left i'd
like to yield to my colleague from
california miss lofgren
you were dealing with by the time you
got there a well-armed barricaded
maniacal messianic well-armed
child molester and as the
with who is controlling a bunch of
people within the compound and what you
face was very difficult and i think
uh you did it uh
your best i i am convinced to
save
children and in a decent way
i'm interested and i don't know if you
can answer this question or not but i've
asked a number of other people and no
one seems to know the answer
i think key to dealing with
a cult of this nature
is to is early intervention
um before things get so out of hand
and one of the incidents that i'm very
interested in why nothing happened
and maybe you can tell me or did
something fall through the cracks or or
why this would happen in the summer of
1990 when the cult was in laverne
california the laverne police were
called when the
son of a cult member robin bunn was
kidnapped by a koresh follower to texas
and the police and this is well
documented in our material the police
gave koresh 48 hours to return this
little boy who was then returned however
at the same time the
ms bunt who was had left the cult told
the police and they were able to verify
it that they koresh had been
taking very young girls below the age of
consent as his wives one of whom was a
14 year old girl from australia
i don't it did not appear from the
record that she had an adequate visa
when they returned
karesh had taken this 14 year old girl
as his wife to texas and i've wondered
throughout how come i mean that is
transporting a child across state lines
to have sex with her and i mean that's a
problem why
wasn't why didn't something happen then
before this cult grew and things got out
of hand why didn't the fbi go after him
for child molesting why didn't the
laverne or maybe they did can does
anybody know the answer to that
well i think the the incident you
described
i'm not sure the fbi would have been
made aware of it
i don't think
the statutes you cite
is utilized
except instances where there is
a kidnapping
or
um
there was a complaint family complaint i
think this was a family agreed to let
their daughter marry this person to mary
korish
if you're talking about rachel i presume
that's who you're talking about his wife
rachel
those type of incidents i think
where
young girls are
taking the prostitution even
among the priorities
and investigations and prosecutions and
federal courts
isolated
cases of
non-kidnapping non
heavily abused children being taken for
prostitution
don't really make it up to the top of
the surface
sadly
i think
when you
when you go home tonight you drive out
and you drive in certain parts of this
city or any major city united states
you're going to see children on the
street
for various reasons i think it's uh you
talk about intervention um
the intervention's
10 years too late
it's sad and i think this is with just
one more instance of of children and
young people
just falling through this cracks in
society so maybe we'd be better off
putting some more resources there early
on rather than later in a lot of
instances thank you yeah mr condo's time
has expired i now recognize for five
minutes mr ehrlich
and i will be glad to yield my time to
my friend and colleague mr bryant
thank you mr early um gentlemen thank
you for appearing today
as a former united states attorney i
certainly want to recognize all federal
law enforcement
and make it clear that this entire panel
does not mean these hearings as a
blanket indictment against federal law
enforcement officials that we have a
great deal of respect for all of you
however it is our duty as a congress to
have oversight over
the fbi and the atf
and certainly it is our job the monday
morning quarterback in certain instances
realizing we weren't out there having to
make the decisions at that point
without editorializing over i wanted to
ask mr smerrick you had commented
earlier that uh in regards to your fifth
report you've given four reports in
essence cautioning a conservative
approach to this the fifth approach
apparently was a change in in policy in
terms of a more con
confrontational approach you said you
did that maybe subliminally whatever but
you felt pressure who was the gentleman
that asked you or made this comment to
you about
this did you say john douglas john
douglas
of the investigative support unit of the
national center for the analysis of
violent crime he is the chief and he is
your direct supervisor your boss he was
at the time he has since retired okay
and
did he say that the attorney general was
not happy with
the flow the
tone tenor and
nothing like that at all he just
indicated that he felt that um
superiors at fbi hq felt that by
recommending as much caution as i was we
were tying the hands of the fbi from
taking any type of action
i'm not talking in terms of using cs gas
or attacking the compound or anything
like that
as we've discussed earlier there's a
difference in philosophy regarding
tactics that can be used in a situation
like this
and so where i might be in a side in
this particular situation of the
negotiators and
say talk talk talk
perhaps a tactical side or the
commanders may feel we need a little bit
more pressure a little bit more stress
on the situation such as shutting off
the electricity
and so it's it's a degree of difference
here i i may have misunderstood you but
i i thought in your first testimony you
did mention specifically that the
attorney general was unhappy no sir not
the uh
it was director sessions uh director
sessions was not happy that's what john
douglas reported to me yes okay now mr
jaymar let me ask you again to name
names for me as i want to ask the the
questions in the context of you being
the field supervisor at waco in charge
of what was going on
and washington
which way who made the decision
to use cs gas was it that came from
washington
or was it at your recommendation and
without a great deal of
reasoning why but you know what's the
flow
the the operations plan we submitted
march 27th
uh was the the plan that was
modifications became the april 19th
however we did an emergency plan the
first week we were there
in case we detected something like let's
go let's kill five children to show them
we mean business or let's start doing
others there's a lot going on inside
there one of the few options we have
non-lethal to try to stop some kind of
conduct like that is gas so so that but
the the gas
that was recommended to us from the
start and the gas we've fbi has used and
los angeles police department is using i
think
i don't know what law enforcement
doesn't use cs gas
that
uh that was just that with that but the
decision to
use gas at waco was a decision that was
part of our operations plan that i
recommended and that went up to
washington yes sir and then they
approved it and approval came down
correct okay now the same question in
terms of the that particular day
uh because i'm still intrigued as to the
what reason
caused compelled you actually compelled
you to go
on april the 19th uh what reason was
there and again what was the flow up or
down on that decision to go on that
particular date okay
the
let's let's go forward to where the
operation is planned by the fbi is we're
all in agreement now that took several
days
and where it's presented to the attorney
general attorney general is considering
this plan
the conditions and circumstances which
led to the recommendation
which was been in late march had not
changed nothing had changed during that
period of time that made us recommend it
we didn't sit still
we've heard what we did during that
period of time to include all the
negotiations and the lawyers and
everything else but the circumstances
remain the same
and the in the the highlight the
motivating factor to me during that time
was a danger that i tried to describe
earlier the danger to the increasing
danger overall to everyone in the place
that's the
as time passed the possibility of a
breakout increased every day there were
plenty other dangers too
but the
those circumstances were the same okay
when i was notified in the evening of
the 17th
that
the plan had been approved by the
attorney general the first thing i did
was check the weather because we had
spent 51 days there in rain and texas
thunderstorms that were
horrendous
and the weather was good and that the
weather was probably the primary factor
for me was that the it was a clear it
was going to be clear
and that um
but nothing had changed not one thing
had changed since that period
during that period i interrupt you real
quick i think maybe mr uh
uh i don't have your name mr sage you
answered this uh was there any
obligation and maybe you did this on
your part to give the compound warning
right before this rate occurred that
there is going to be gas injected and if
the children are going to leave you
better leave the next 15 minutes did you
do that or was there any obligation to
do that it was my
my instruction in the evening before
we had prepared a specific
list
of
issues that i was to present to the
compound both over the phone
if we had that option and that
simultaneously over the um
over the pa system that in fact was done
it started i called in at 5 59
steve schneider was on the phone shortly
thereafter
i just began to get into that particular
issue
where upon he hung up the microphones
indicate two things they immediately
dawned gas masks and they immediately
began to spread fuel
i continued with the broadcast then for
the rest of the morning
and for six solid hours advising them
that we were in the process of
delivering gas my understanding is is
nearly 10 minutes past that the first
cev
was in the
process of of approaching the compound
they had plenty of time to have
uh to but we started all they needed to
do
and this was my understanding all along
all they needed to do was send us some
sort of a signal
any kind of signal that they were
prepared to begin a safe and orderly
evacuation the whole thing would have
come to all stop and we would have
facilitated them coming out
mr bryant your time is is up we are at
the point now where we have four or five
votes in a row gentlemen on the floor
there are five-minute votes so we should
be back here fairly shortly to complete
your testimony
i will now have this committee in recess
until
the five minutes after the last of this
series of votes committees are in recess
[Music]
the joint house subcommittee hearing on
the waco investigation will continue in
just a moment
first some program information
this weekend we begin our live coverage
of the national governors association
summer meeting in burlington vermont
saturday at 11 a.m eastern time c-span
brings you the opening news conference
with governors howard dean of vermont
and tommy thompson of wisconsin
nga chairman and vice chairman
sunday night the latest developments on
the road to the white house
campaign events speeches debates and
forums
this week colin powell and campaign 96
segments from previous interviews with
the former joint chiefs chairman and a
look at what role if any he'll play in
the upcoming presidential race
road to the white house sunday at 7 00
and 10 pm eastern and pacific time on
c-span the political network of record
sunday on c-span with the british house
of commons in recess we take a look at
the people and politics of the united
kingdom
this weekend
british ambassador to the u.s robin
renick on the eve of his retirement we
think that if the united nations didn't
exist we'd have to invent it because
when it comes to crises like in
rwanda or burundi or indeed in somalia
you have to get somebody uh to try to
help deal with these
crises they have been successful in
cambodia they were successful in namibia
their failures get very heavily
advertised but we do believe
that they fulfill an essential role
people in politics of the united kingdom
sunday night at nine eastern and pacific
time
we now return to wednesday's proceedings
examining the waco investigation
last week a house joint subcommittee
began hearings into events at waco texas
in the spring of 1993
[Music]
[Music]
the joints the joint subcommittees on
the waco hearing matter will come to
order
we recessed a few minutes ago we were at
the point where it was mr brewster's
opportunity to question and i will
recognize you for five minutes mr
booster
thank you mr chairman
mr moore i know that uh you didn't
create the incident in waco that your
group was called in to try to bring some
resolution to it at a later time
uh several questions along with that
when was the plan set up and the date of
april 19th set as termination point
the plan was submitted
uh
first in late march
given to the attorney general after a
discussion within the fbi she approved
the plan uh
april 17th
the plan of the 19th being the
tournament plan that was i'm sorry the
plan that was
was uh um
performed on the 19th she approved the
17th yes
okay the plan to execute on the 19th was
approved on the 17th
yes so really the negotiations didn't
play a lot of uh part in the last couple
of days and is that correct well he
played a great part i think the
had
um of course had a different attitude
had we had any any signal
of a change we wouldn't have gone on the
19th
i read the the transcript
and he said several times in there that
he wants to come out wants to have a
shower wants to do those things but once
again
i guess most of those things had been
said before is that correct
almost every day
so that was really nothing new no sir uh
he also mentioned in here that he was
getting awful tired of eating the mres
i've heard that the military before
how much more food do they have in there
you have any idea i think the estimate
was when observed was at least two more
years
they're reading about 6 000 meals a
month
so that would be uh
my goodness and they had two or three
hundred thousand of the mres well they
weren't all anymorees i think they had i
think a figure i saw was fifty thousand
mres they had purchased
fifty thousand that right
a ton of potatoes they had all kind of
cans of you know
vegetables
and fruit
along that same line i know some of the
people
were suggesting
uh mr america thing at one point
suggested that uh
maybe pressure wasn't the right thing
that uh these people could be suicidal i
think back in early march like the
eighth ninth tenth somewhere along there
you had several of those
uh
i know you had to make a decision on
what you thought was the best outcome
and didn't choose to go that way but in
looking at the way pressure was applied
and and i heard rumors it can't be true
surely
did you in fact play tapes of rabbits
being slaughtered
i think among
the sounds and everything that was
played
that began march 22nd
not back when
the first week in march march 22nd
i think among that was
all sorts of sounds uh i think the
uh
rabbit's one of the things that the
media reported yes
and they for what length of time i think
bobby i don't know how how there was
such a mix
it probably wasn't done very often there
was a there was a person in houston that
provided us
this library of tapes and sounds
designed for this sort of thing they're
all sorts of sounds
well as one who's a varmint hunter
predator call is about the eeriest thing
i've ever heard and i was kind of
curious if that was really true if it
was tell me what would have been lost by
waiting another 10 20 or 60 days
to do the execution final clip i think
the
thing that that i hope i can get across
the
most important in that regard is that
in
when once we decided that
we would recommend that we do a
the plan that became the plan on april
19th
that
the fear we had all along was a breakout
and the thing is as time passed
is going to get to the point where by
his actual 19th i think
removes any doubt in my mind about this
that he would decide when it would
happen
and how would we stop him what we could
we do to stop him from doing either a
mass suicide inside
by poison whatever you want to do
shooting people a fire
a breakout with a child whatever that
might have been he would dictate when
that occurred and how would we stop him
what could we do not only without
gunning everybody down or or entering
the place and killing a bunch of people
to stop well it's gas
cs gas
so
what we wanted to do was do it on our
schedule as best we can now we wouldn't
have done it at all with any inkling of
any change
but we won't do it on our schedule we
don't want him doing it one o'clock in
the morning we're not prepared
so as time passed the possibility of
that with him making sure that his
prophecy came true
was going to be more and more possible
to occur
and so if the longer we waited
the more happened that was to occur
so you waited 51 days and had you waited
another 20 or 60 days
you think in your mind there's a good
possibility he would have tried to break
out well the possibility was that
my point to you is that the ending was
going to be the same he was going to
have that ending
no matter what now could we have gotten
a few more people out if they became ill
or he wanted to expel them or they
negotiated them out that's a possibility
i don't think any question about that
but the end
he was going to have that end in one
manner or another i'm firmly firmly
believe that in yesterday's testimony we
had
a group that i
personally think have lived in texas a
number of years is one of the more
professional groups i know the texas
rangers
[Music]
they were very unhappy with the
treatment they received from the fbi
down there i think for me it sounded
like more than just the i think the
bureau is a
i think it sounds like i'm the one that
they correctly had
complaints about did you realize that at
the time no i did not i think uh it's
uh
what i think i heard that that uh they
were concerned about a
what they had to wait for me i think was
during the first week and i sometimes
never got to meet with you at all well i
think um
um
probably that first week
we were so running around all the place
and everything i think that we got off
on the wrong foot when i learned that
when i discovered because i thought we
had agents over there all the time i
thought it was okay when i learned that
i went to see captain burns and i
apologized
and tried to rebuild it but the problem
was and and it's an absolute legitimate
complaint on their part
here they were asked to come into a
federal matter one of the biggest
disasters in law enforcement history
and investigate the homicide
and they run into me and i'm constantly
undermining their case
you won't let them check the footprints
well no that's not true all right that's
not so that's why i checked the
footprint i think it was circumstances
that kept that rain and what was going
on with the compound i never did that i
never said they can't do that i think
they just misunderstood
and why that we didn't get them out
there when they wanted to go
but but they're complaining about me
just
taking the evidence away and letting the
lawyers go in absolutely legitimate can
play on their parts terribly frustrating
for them terribly frustrating for the
prosecutors they weren't real happy
about it either one other question your
time unfortunately has expired i
let you go a little while here but i
can't have to put you in check i'm sorry
thank you mr chairman mr hyde you're
recognized for five minutes
i thank you mr chairman and i'm pleased
to yield my five minutes to you well
thank you very much mr hyde for yielding
mr jamar i want to follow up on a couple
of questions one of them being the
sanitation question inside the compound
during the time of the siege and leading
up to the april 19th date you've
indicated that it was less than what you
would find on the outside i assume
you're referring to things such as the
fact that i don't believe they had any
toilets in there and that sort of thing
could you tell me what these sanitary
condition problems were as you perceived
them what the conditions were inside in
general terms and what might have been
different about that from perhaps what
was the case before the siege began
you know before let's start with the
conditions we understood before the
siege
that women and children were allowed to
use
toss pots
men were allowed to go out
into would be equivalent of an outhouse
so
that when the
uh whatever accumulated during the day
would be tossed out
at the end of the day
there was one spigot of water in the
entire building
they had water tanks
um
to be the lower right side behind that
you can't see them there but right
behind see where the fence comes out in
loops but they're inside the compound
white plastic large bad water tanks that
were that that
they had a well electric whale 600 foot
deep well and it was one spigot from
those water tanks drip spigot into the
place that's it
that's all the plumbing they had
operating
so when when they had this when the
seizure began they couldn't get rid of
all that
as they used to there was a huge
sewage field out to the right
we call the red side that was about 30
yards out or maybe not far maybe 60
feet
at the sewage field i mean when the
agents put the concertina wire they were
knee-deep in sewage
they were dumping it out there and then
behind the place was a sewage field so
they couldn't go out there and dump it
they dumped it anyway but we ended up
dumping it all
into the side would be to the left of
that under like was it covered by a tarp
paper it looked like there yes sir that
was filled with human waste
when
on april 19th when the agents went in
with you so that is the the difference
in the conditions they were not able to
go out as far away as they were to dump
it but they the conditions as far as not
having running water or plumbing were
that way for a year or more before this
happened yes sir and the other thing we
did we asked for a tape of the children
so we had forced them to clean the
children because we knew they wouldn't
send a tape out with dirty children
it was a way of us finding about their
water but they had plenty of water but
the
um we thought they had a water shortage
because when when branch and watford
came out they were they were dehydrated
but that was a disciplinary action by
porish so it really wasn't a water
shortage the point is that the only
difference in the conditions though they
were certainly far from ideal
as before the siege during the siege and
and at the end of it was this question
of where they dumped the sewage and how
close it was in its ultimate
accumulation i presume you assume that
would ultimately become a problem though
at any given time
sure when there were dead bodies in
there too excuse me i'm sorry but so far
as we know no disease had occurred as a
result of that no illnesses particularly
that we were able to detect is that what
you were able to detect we were fighting
efforts of tb it was and we had
everybody was there inoculated for tb
but you didn't have it no manifestation
of it at the time no sir it was a fear
of it okay now i want to get back to
this question mr sage of your
conversation with mr hubble that you
were responding to mr shattuck about
concerning the issue of what you may
have told him on the uh i guess it was
the 15th of april during that two-hour
telephone conversation regarding the de
garin
uh
breakthrough issue now let me frame it a
minute the question i want to ask you
and i'd like maybe mr jamar to uh to
respond in the generic too so i'll ask
you to listen up to this from
yesterday's testimony both by daguerreon
zimmerman and as well mr taber and
perhaps mr dr arnold
it's my impression
that
they believe that at the by the 14th or
the 15th of april this is the 14th there
was a difference in koresha's attitude
uh that he had looked at things
differently that he wasn't now looking
at becoming a martyr
they believed and i think they were
sincere in this belief
that at that point he had switched and
they had been able to convince him to
switch his thinking to the fact that
instead of god wanting him to be the
martyr in the messiah
the idea of coming out
that he was going to be the messenger
under his interpretation
of the seals and the in the book of
revelations
and that by writing these
instruments
uh that he was interpreting the seals by
putting them down and writing them that
he'd be able to come out and publish
them even though he might be in jail
he would be able to produce these things
in some way and he would be able to
fulfill that
particular
mission as opposed to the martyrdom now
they seem very genuine in that
conclusion and that was i assume i'm
correct the basis of what was quote new
unquote on the 14th of april
uh about this the seals themselves the
fact he wanted to interpret the seals
wasn't new but his change their
perception of his change of attitude at
least they were conveying that to you am
i correct in that is that the way you
read it i think they absolutely believe
that i think they were as deceived on
the 15th of april with uh or yes with
15th of april by courage in this
particular
venture
as we were
as i was on the uh the second tomorrow
my point is just for the record that was
your impression and i've got that down
as well as theirs that's what the
daguerreon was looking at that's what he
was thinking and that's what what his
impression was and yours was of what now
whether you thought they were deceived
or not that's another story my question
is
this new idea of de garin deceived or
otherwise
was that
that new development if you will that
de garan thought he had obtained the
correction state of mind being different
and the seals being i mean the
the interpretations being written down
and and this change from desire to be a
martyr was this
aspect of the garan's interpretation
and tabor's interpretation of it was
that conveyed by you in that telephone
conversation mr hubble it seemed to me
that you were saying that you thought
perhaps that the discussions with the
guerin took place after the hubble
conversation
and if it was not conveyed during the
hubble conversation on the 15th of april
did you ever convey that or did mr jamar
ever convey
this to mr hubble or personally as
opposed to up the chain of command
through written form or whatever
to anybody in washington
uh in the justice department or to mr
hubbell or anybody in the white house
before before the 19th
my recollection is that uh
we gay i gave a
very general overview as to the
dynamics of negotiation since the first
day since i was the only one there that
had been there the entire time
i gave them direct candid insight
as to what my observations were as to
the success
and to date and or failure of negotiated
efforts
uh and as straightforward a consensus
from the negotiation team as to what the
possibility was of a successful
resolution i would like to mention this
i was
i was surprised
that uh that i was to talk to mr hubble
uh i was when i responded to waco from
the very beginning it was not in the
form of being a
in a supervisory role or anything else
it was to be a negotiator in the trench
and that's exactly where i was the
entire time i'd in hindsight consider it
to uh
to have been very
commendable
for
them to have sought out not only the
uh opinion of the
uh let's say on scene commander or the
the command level personnel but also the
specific frank
insights of those individuals that were
there in the trenches where it was going
on to ensure that they were getting an
accurate representation of the dynamics
of what was going on that's exactly what
i attempted to do but the question you
haven't answered is and i just want the
answer to my question is did you convey
this new thing from daguerreon
explicitly to hubble or on another
occasion to anyone else in the justice
department or in the white house you
personally
by telephone or in person
between the time you got that uh
that information on the 14th of april or
on about that date and the date of the
uh the ultimate assault
the
the answer to the answer to that the
best of my recollection is that on the
15th of april
this first of all was not a new
revelation to us as as far as the seven
seals i've mentioned that previously no
but but the other aspect was mr chairman
i think i can clarify well you can but
let mr sage finish first please we were
we were still in the process of trying
to determine through negotiation process
the veracity of the offer that had been
laid forward i do not to specifically
answer your question i do not remember
uh addressing in any detail the dynamics
of that because it hadn't unfolded yet
it had not unfolded yet we didn't know
the veracity of his offer whether or not
he had followed through ultimately he
did not so your answer is you personally
did not convey it explicitly not that i
recall on the 15th or any time
thereafter mr jamar mr chairman uh
previously i did not i was not uncertain
i was not certain whether it had been
conveyed to the attorney general i've
since been told
that she was made aware of it and among
other things it's the reason that she
asked mr hubbell to call out and talk to
a negotiator
is because where does this what does
this mean to the negotiations
and to satisfy her before she made the
decision she asked mr hubbell to call
and a negotiator
when they called out that said that
someone from the attorney general's
office wanted to talk to a negotiator
i selected mr
sage because he'd been there from the
very beginning he had the best feel but
mr jamar
the question was not whether you have
been told the attorney general knew
about it we'll find that out down the
road and confirm it or deny it question
is did you
yourself or do you know of anybody in
your team who personally talked and told
mr hubbell of this new information
explicitly or
anybody else in washington in the
attorney general's office justice
department other words or the white
house
after that information on the 14th that
came into being one of my friends before
the assault i'm sorry my previous
testimony was that i presume that it had
been done i could not cite how and who
but you did not personally no sir no sir
that's all i wanted to know and you
don't know how or who thank you but it
was accomplished mr lantos
we have been inundated in the last few
days with
countless detailed questions and
detailed answers
what i'd like to do
with your gentleman is to ask you to sit
back take a deep breath and look at the
broad picture
there have been basically three kinds of
approaches to this tragedy
one approach
this is the approach of what i call the
lunatic fringe
still clings to the notion that there
was a gigantic governmental conspiracy
that brought about this nightmare
it is difficult to see how any rational
human beings subscribe to subscribe to
such a notion but obviously many do
the second broad area
where
most are
relates to the kind and nature
and level of mistakes made by various
governmental authorities
uh along the way
and i suspect
we can
debate
ad nauseum and that infinitum the
specifics of the mistakes and that is
not my intention
but the third arena
in approaching this tragedy
is the one that i think has received the
least attention so far
which to me
is intriguing because in many ways i
think
the answer is to be found in the third
arena
the only analogy we have
to this episode
in american history certainly in recent
american history
is the tragedy in jonestown guyana
where
you had a charismatic criminal
who had an apocalyptic vision
and who brought about
the death
under the most nightmarish circumstances
of about 900 american citizens
there was no fbi there was no
atf there was no justice department
none of the conspiracy theories could
work
there was really no question about
mistakes being made by our law
enforcement
agencies because they were basically
not there
yet 900 american citizens
under the spell of a criminally insane
charismatic cult leader lost their lives
they were either killed
or they committed suicide or they were
forced to commit suicide
but i would like to ask each of you
and each of you is an expert because
you've been dealing with this issue it's
not to worry about the details now
we have spent plenty of time on that
perhaps more than this committee should
have but i want you to look at the broad
picture and beginning you with you mr
jamar
i want you to tell me whether you see
any analogy
between the jonestown nightmare
whether this at any time during
this process cross to your mind
consciously subconsciously as you think
back at this whole
horrible episode in your life
do you feel that you may have been
influenced by what you remember happened
at jonestown
i was asked the question
was
in a media briefing april 20th 1993
was just another jonestown
and that's my answer was
it is
if
you look at it as a charismatic leader
causing the death of all of his
followers
our fear all along
was
that
courage would find a way to make those
people die in his name and his glory and
he would survive
that was my greatest fear not that that
makes a difference whether he died or
not it's just that that was his
he was so
uh
concerned about himself
that one of the one of the descriptions
of him as a psychopathic personality is
that he's not really interested in dying
for any cause including his own
uh even to fulfill a prophecy
so you reject the notion that one of my
colleagues
uh introduced yesterday and had a
dialogue with the defense attorneys that
if rational people had just waited 10
days everything would have been all
right
well i think
that
as i said earlier that he was going to
find this end those people are going to
die in his name and with him or without
him right one way or another whether 10
days a year later where it was i'm
convinced of that ending
uh still
i would have waited a year if we had
something to work with there was just
something there we could attach
something to we did it for
from march 1st when or february 28 until
a decision was made in the in the late
march that we thought we were going
nowhere and we were afraid he was going
to dictate when the people or when his
when he was going to cause it
and we couldn't prevent it as easy as we
could have otherwise
that's a long time
we did a lot and we did more even after
that
but i am convinced that he was going to
end it his way he controlled events from
the february 28th he controlled events
with us march 2nd and there's not i
don't think there's an event that he
didn't control other than the weather
maybe so you see an analogy with
jonestown
uh yes sir could i ask the rest of you
gentlemen to respond during the
negotiation process we mentioned
jonestown many times it was on our minds
and we were certainly aware of this
might be a precedent for mr koresh i
think it's important that this committee
examines what we did in law enforcement
and to determine how we can improve in
the future and i i for one didn't agree
with every decision out there and and
we've learned from that we've taken
corrective actions in the fbi but
there's one thing i have to tell you as
having spent so much of my career in the
field of negotiations there are no
guarantees
i could talk to 38 people wanting to
commit suicide today and we could
probably convince 36 37 of them not to
do it but the other handful of them will
do it regardless of what we do and
that's because of what's going on in
their mind and what is in their own
sense their own self-interest and that
was david koresh
we can never say he might not have
changed his mind later on but if there's
anything that we could have done that
would have guaranteed that we would have
had the outcome we like the answer is
absolutely not there is no guarantee in
this business and it's and we're all
upset and terribly
uh uh
terribly devastated by the outcome this
is not the outcome that any of us in the
fbi wanted by any stretch of the
imagination but to suggest that we'll
always now have an opportunity to be 100
successful with the david creches of the
world is simply not going to happen mr
mccarthy
uh i would comment that there is a
parallel uh certainly
uh both cults both suicidal and we know
that from what occurred i would also add
that
a brave congressman flew there to
confront jim jones and guyana and was
murdered on the airstrip and
one might
offer then that had he not confronted
jim jones in an effort to resolve that
incident in jonestown
that 900 people wouldn't be dead
and uh i think that would be just as
unfair as
saying that the fbi is responsible for
the death of the children that's bizarre
i fully agree with you gentlemen could
you come in
churchill said there's no risk-free
battles and in law enforcement there's
no risk-free decisions
prior to the atf raid i strongly
recommended that we negotiate this
situation i believe that today i
believed it prior
and so from the atf standpoint
and
if we were able to confront a situation
like this again we would negotiate from
the very beginning and i believe that
that was an error
and so the director uh
feels along with me very strongly that
we have to strengthen our negotiation
capabilities to be able to deal with
these violent groups
uh
it was a terrible tragedy and i do agree
that when congressman ryan was killed in
in those three i think three eighths
uh it was very similar and in our
planning
uh prior to the atf raid it was
discussed frequently we used the word
jonestown jonestown that's what's going
to happen and one of the things we faced
if we surround the place and they all
commit suicide
then all the critics will be out saying
why'd you surround the place then you
think of jonestown absolutely so that's
true
in these types of situations there are
several dynamics one of course you have
to have a charismatic leader but number
two you have to have people who are
willing to follow this individual
and normally these types of individuals
are looking for someone in life that
they can turn over all of their
responsibilities to
and so in this particular event you have
people not only giving up their homes
giving up their possessions giving up
their material wealth
but giving up their freedom for the
belief in this one individual it went so
far as to giving up sexual relations
with their spouses and the ultimate
after power and control is turning over
your own children to an individual like
like the david koresh so you see a
parallel i see a parallel too uh it
really comes down from a behavioral
perspective of being power and control
every charismatic leader that i've
encountered that is the main issue
sage
i would basically adopt the comments of
the rest of the panel and just state
that uh i was not in jonestown i was in
at mount carmel
i will never forget it this individual
was an absolute master of deception and
to embrace some of the the concepts set
forth yesterday would will be to enable
coerce to consid to continue this
pattern of deception
uh on these subcommittees i want to
thank all of you for your advice thank
you lantos your time is up the committee
will be in recess until after the vote
that's now pending thank you
[Music]
the joint house subcommittee hearing on
the waco investigation will continue in
just a moment
first some program information
[Music]
we now return to wednesday's proceedings
examining the waco investigation
last week a house joint subcommittee
began hearings into events at waco texas
in the spring of 1993
no
he was next door
uh this one
[Music]
the subcommittee will come to order uh
we were agreeing that it was a time for
the republican side of the aisle but the
democrats have gotten back here sooner
and mr conyers is sitting there with his
time and i'm going to
give you your five minutes now mr
conyers
i'd like to talk with mr cavanaugh
he's on the way
mr cavanaugh gets seated and everybody's
ready to go
did you notice i didn't even make any
requests for additional time because i
knew the chairman's fairness would cover
us
i
appreciate that mr congress
all right i think we got mr cavanaugh in
seat and mr mccarthy still hasn't
entered the room but you don't need him
right now for your question is that
right i'd like to begin my discussion
with mr kavanaugh farewell please
proceed you're recognizing sir you were
in a unique uh role in
this episode that's being relived many
many times here
in the hearing room
you were both a
commander and a negotiator
and as such you played a
key role
in each capacity and i congratulate you
for your
very important performances in both
areas
one thing that's been said in terms of
negotiation
is that uh
of course we were dealing with people
with a religion that was unique and not
popularly understood
and it's been gone over time and time
again we have to understand
from their point of view and so forth
uh
was that something uh difficult
for you or the other negotiators to
understand
in other words
it seems to me a little simplistic for
us to say well you've got to take in
to consideration that these were
davidians and they believed in other
things
how could one not do that i mean what
else would you be thinking of these
these are not hard shell baptists these
are not catholic these are not
any they're who they are and
to what degree mr kavanaugh was that
understood by yourself and others that
participated in the negotiation process
with you
congressman i i fully respected their
religious beliefs
whatever degree there was there of
religious beliefs and all i think all
the other negotiators did also
i i don't mean to be
sarcastic but my feeling was they can
worship a golden chicken if they want to
but they can't have sub machine guns and
hand grenades and shoot federal agents
uh i was very i played the role as a
policeman that's what i am i didn't try
to fool the davidians that i was some
something else and i think that's one
reason that koresh
uh
certainly trusted me from the beginning
i didn't try to fool crash or or or
trick him i simply said look i'm a
policeman
we want to resolve this situation
our shared problem is this conflict
let's see if we can work it out and i
think every negotiator that followed me
took the same track
a
normal strategy and a negotiation and
like i say congressman i was a really uh
this i'm a rookie at this and the
experts are on my left but i think any
policeman
any special agent respects the sanctity
of life and i certainly respected the
sanctity of mr karesh's life it was
difficult for me because i had watched
him kill four agents and shoot 20 others
that that made it difficult for me well
i i want to tell you that our staff
studies that i've gone over
uh
recognized that you treated your
negotiating role with patients and
good listening skills
and that your your training as a
negotiator held you in good stead
now let me turn to your other role as a
law enforcement commander
in in which
you were trying uh you spent a
considerable amount of time into the
hours of trying to rescue
special agent king
who was caught in a crossfire and there
was apparently some difficulty in
getting to him would you
recapitulate that for us mr kavanaugh
yes congressman i think it's important
to know because some of the facts that
have come out in the other areas may be
cleared up here if you look at that
chart
the roof of the chapel is on the right
side the center line up and down
that's the window just on the right
where everybody's watched on tv the
three agents go in
kenny king went over the peak of that
roof
to the window on the left
could you show us where it is i i'm not
sure if i'm following
the ladder here
yes
[Music]
because they heard the ages of them and
bill buford who testified wounded inside
this room around who shot up those
rounds that missed him would have come
out this room
and the agents on the ground here would
have been shooting up this way through
this room
so i just want to mention that but katy
peterson
we have no man this is the apparent
extent of our teams
right here
now
uh
you were trying to reach king who was
indicating that he was seriously injured
yes sir and you
were you trying to get the davidians to
hold their fire uh or what were you
doing during that time and how was king
ultimately rescued
one thing congressman was we couldn't
reach a ceasefire agreement
and and the only thing i would impart
that's not shown on the videotapes on
the television shows
is that this wasn't a gun battle where
where a few men were on the roof
and a few were shot this was a gun
battle where thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands of thousands of
rounds were fired
that's the way it was the shooting
i remember didn't stop for 40 or 45
minutes and then when it did stop it
continued sporadically
small skirmishes would break out of a
few hundred rounds
and during the negotiations to get a
ceasefire this same thing would
frequently happen the davidians would
fire on someone
and uh we'd respond or they'd accuse us
of firing and so forth so the ceasefire
initially broke down three times when we
finally reached it
i radioed to
pete maston who was on the new orleans
side and i asked him i told the
davidians we're going to send four
agents they're going to get the wounded
man in the back
and
you know and they're going to stand up
you know that was king that was king
and and
he he was there caught between this
gunfire for what period of time
well he was shot uh probably about 10
a.m and uh
this he was there for at least two hours
when this was going on and he he had
been shot through the chest through his
bulletproof vest
uh with a submachine gun uh and back out
the other side and
i'd like to mention if you'd let me that
all the men who were wounded there and
also when we had six women there too and
one got the medal of valor
but all the men are wounded we saved the
only agents who died were those who were
killed immediately and i we were much
criticized for a medical plan and that
that's atrocious we had medics atf
certified paramedics who treated our
wounded on the ground who gave bill
buford plasma
when he was shot laying there that's the
only reason he's alive
i don't know that there's a law
enforcement agency that gives plasma i
mean we we went in there trying to be
prepared for for the worst well i i
may i commend you for the
really outstanding
services that you performed for your
agency and and for the men that and
women that were with you that day
thank you very much mr chairman mr boyer
you're recognized for five minutes
thank you thank you mr chairman
a couple real quick questions and i've
got a comment in a series of questions
one in uh mr jamar and
i was listening to mr brewster's
questions to you about some tapes and
what they were played and what they
consisted of would you please produce to
this committee uh those tapes you'll
hear either this afternoon or tomorrow
could you do that for this committee
please i'm uncertain of which type
there's some tapes about the kind of
tapes that you were playing
uh
[Music]
thank you very much
and the other question i have is who do
you report to
who
do you report to anyone in washington i
mean during during the yes the crisis
yes uh the person i reported to was
larry potts who's assistant director of
the criminal investigative division at
that time okay thank you
the other thing that that's been going
through my mind here is
uh several things first of all i
i want to commend all of you
to your service to country
a lot of times you know the military
always gets highlighted and sometimes
they forget about law enforcement who's
on the lines day in and day out for the
preservations of our securities and
economic opportunities here at home so
let me let me thank you thank you
likewise gentlemen uh you know a lot of
times there's been the analogy used
quite often with the military style
operations and
and uh when we have our hrt or our
hostage rescue teams and they're they're
trained in sort of the paramilitary
style tactics and
cqb close quarter combat training and
you know in our military you know
they're trained
uh very well in in the uh the mount the
military operations and urban terrain
that's basically they're going to go in
in indiscriminate fields of fire throw
the grenade and kill anything that moves
that only takes a couple days of
training
but but cqb and uh and laying down
discriminate fields of fire with our
highly perishable skills
and that takes many many months of
training
agreed
yes i agree with that all right
so so when i when i think about the
military aspects of this and i think
some of the military advisors and
are very very cautioned but you know
what i think about the military
operations and
and
when you have combat people die
people are wounded you do in fact have
casualties and a lot of the the battles
and the histories of a military
historian also
that uh how awful it would be to bring
in a company commander before a
congressional hearing when there was
loss of life because good men made bad
decisions
in battle good men make bad decisions uh
quite often
and and uh but what i want you to know
that while i give the military analogy
um
part of the reasons and processes for
this
is that we are a lawful society and in
the in a lawful society as bad as we we
now know mr koresha in fact to to be
um the ends does not justify the means
that would lead to a lawless society and
we do have the constitutional right so
you're presumed innocent until proven
guilty and we all understand that and
you understand it because you're on the
line day in and day out to preserve the
constitution by your oath no different
than our of
let me uh uh
ask a question
the thing that has concerned me
uh miss mr sage is
is some of your thought processes here
um
the uh in your april 15th meeting
uh i guess a uh a com telephone
conversation
with mr hubble
uh in reading the the justice report
it really indicates that that
you were really getting frustrated here
and that's my reading of this is you're
real very challenged at the moment
because huffle recalls sage saying he
believed there was nothing more here
than negotiators could do to persuade
koresh to release anyone or to come out
himself i still state that that's
slightly overstated but uh we had
reached an impasse okay um
see that could be part of the problem i
think what i walked away from
yesterday's hearing was is that there
was a tremendous disconnect perhaps
between
those of you who are who are the
negotiators on the field and the the
political appointees in washington
and if you're saying that's an
overstatement
are you are you saying that
the assistant attorney general hubble
may have overstated and then provided
not factual information to the attorney
general that she used as a basis to make
a decision i'm not i'm not speaking for
mr hubbell i'm speaking for my
recollection of conversation with mr
hubbell so you disagree with mister no
time did we abandon negotiations
so then you disagree with mr hubble's
perceptions of the conversation that you
had with them i have some uh concerns
about the uh
the degree to which it's expressed in
that report what about uh the fact that
uh hubble
you must have informed mr hubble that
law enforcement personnel waco were
getting tired and the tempers were
framed
i don't recall having said that we don't
our operations are not driven by fatigue
or frustration there's a
a level of professionalism here that is
going to ensure that we give the best
possible
uh commitment to a particular set of
circumstances i understand
i understand that but you've also we are
in agreement there are highly perishable
skills
and part of those skills also can be in
fact the negotiating skills and what i
said that is is that you know your negot
as a negotiator i'm not money morning
quarterbacking you well you're utilizing
your expertise your intelligence data
but you're also dealing with stress and
frustrations certainly and and and uh um
trying to put myself in your shoes
i can sense i would have some sense of
that but part of my concern is here if
we have mr hubble here on the 15th
saying these are my impressions of a
two-hour conversation with you
and then he is having been a
conversation with the attorney general
because on the april 16th we have the
attorney general basically disapproving
the plan to end the standoff
so if on the 16th they were disapproving
the plan
i'm there to me there's a real problem
here all of a sudden someone who in fact
must have tried to convince the attorney
general that we have to go forward
and and that this april 14th meeting
um
they're tremendous
they're tremendous disconnects here i
don't know i know i've just run out of
time and i'll explore this later and i'm
sure i'll be able to talk with the
attorney general and i'll be more happy
to talk to you i believe i'll be on that
other panel as well uh other
participants or at least people that
were in the room during the course of
that uh conversation in waco good then
we'll carry this on first thank you
thank you mrs thurman you are now
recognized for five minutes
there's been some conversation about
this
letter or something that was sent by i
guess by maybe mr
miron or
myron
myron yeah and just to clear it up there
was one last
who is he first of all
he's a professor of psycholinguistics i
believe at syracuse university was he
involved with this
apparently so okay anyway just i think
mr mccullum and one of the others had
mentioned i'm not sure who
had talked about this letter that there
might be an ability to work this out or
that things had changed on this april
15th however the letter that i have says
in summary i do not believe there is in
is in these writings any better or at
least certain hope for an earlier end to
the seed so just i just kind of wanted
to clear that up and know who this
gentleman was
um
yesterday i asked a question um
because we've like you have taken in a
lot of information over the last couple
of days
um and i have to tell you i
how you came to conclusions i'm not sure
and i want to find that out
i've been trying to reconcile in my own
mind
based on the information i mean i've
heard from
jewel sparks rodriguez
then i heard last night from lawyers and
theologists and are
each telling me different things
some telling me that they were going to
go through the prophecy some saying
there was a possibility we could get out
of this
in your training and through this
operation
how did you
reconcile all of these different people
coming to you with all of these
different
concerns
the
analysis by
negotiators who were talking to these
people constantly
they had a good feel
they understood people they were trained
to do this to get a feel for people
i think they were the most
reliable among the people who were there
among our people as to
um
what how reliable what the people were
saying is what uh how much they could
rely on what they were saying
um how accurate the information was
the we had a lot of people call us
offering all sorts of information
the
um
but we we had people
decide after each shift what was
significant
what happened this last whatever the
shift was whatever happened to be
what happened
during this period
compared to what we did before and then
analysis of maybe the previous 10
10 shifts or maybe the previous three
days what's happened what happened to
the recommendations we made or what
happened to the conclusions we made are
they still good
based on what's occurred the analysis
was constant because they were in
constant conversation these are people
who are trained to do this and it was a
a huge team
byron coordinated one shift gary was
overseeing the whole thing for several
weeks
and they had 10 and 12 people working
each shift supporting each other had a
primary person talking but everyone else
was absorbing what was going on and
helping them and pushing them
to ask questions or an interpreting was
going and the same time another person's
writing down highlights what was going
on so all these people to include
behavioralists and everybody else
absorbing this
and it was constantly reassessed and
reanalyzed over and over again
i'd like to respond to that certainly
there was a great many people that have
called in and and how do you choose
which theologian is the right one to
turn to
um we had a one occasion where a
gentleman in the cowboy hat in a late
model cadillac pulled up to the
perimeter and he he offered to negotiate
karesh out with certain he could do it
the troops thanked him for his
assistance but said we could handle it
and as he drove off his personalized tag
said god perhaps we should have turned
to him as well i don't i don't know
but i think in terms of uh some of the
armed chair theologists who have
criticized us i think a good question
would be how many times have they talked
to someone with a knife at someone's
throat a gun to someone's head or
someone up on a bridge about to jump
because the negotiators on our teams
have done this hundreds and hundreds of
times
and while we listened to their advice
and tried to take into account as many
different suggestions as we could
ultimately we had to use the experience
of some of the best negotiators in the
united states who'd been assembled for
this for this effort and i always judge
it on what would i do if my children
were inside that compound
and i'll tell you the very last thing
the world i would do would have some
untrained theologian try to talk to a
religious fanatic to get my child out i
would hope that an fbi or a law
enforcement negotiator with skill and
training and experience knowing how to
talk to people in crisis would be there
to do it and that's ultimately what we
did congresswoman how long have you been
doing this uh negotiating for 15 years
in the fbi for almost 23.
let me ask another question that i don't
think has been brought out
because we kept hearing about promises
kept promises broken and those there was
one last gentleman that came out of the
compound mr fagan i understand would you
like to give us the story surrounding
that and what how you believe what
happened under that because i think that
plays a significant role in this and we
really have not talked about it i
believe it does as well i think
mr fagan came out with a mission
um
the last person to come out prior to him
was on the 21st
in fact seven people came out on the
21st and at least my opinion that not
maybe not everyone shares that perhaps
koresh was beginning to have some
concerns about some people having second
doubts and wanting to come out and i
believe he sent out livingston fagan
with a very clear mission and that was
to fort the flow of people out of the
compound you may have heard our whole
strategy was trickle flow gush trying to
get as many people out as we could
every person that had been released from
the compound by agreement with koresh
would call into the compound to indicate
that they had been picked up well
received and well cared for
and that was a standard procedure in
almost every instance we in fact in all
instances we initiated the call to
follow through on that agreement when
livingston fagin came out as soon as the
tactical people literally put hands on
him he said you're mistreating me you're
beating me i refuse to call back in
then for the first and only time
not no sooner had he been taken from the
scene that david koresh calls in and
says i demand to speak to fagin
and he had never done this before
and of course we had to report that
fagin in fact refused to talk to crash
we believe kresh used that to convince
other people inside that look the fbi's
mistreating fagin they won't let us talk
to him anymore and attempted to use this
as a rationale to stem the flow of
people outside and we feel the whole
thing was was a plant by koresh
well i had more questions but my red
light is on but i want to tell you all
thank you very much for being here and
sitting through this and
certainly having to go through this all
again i can tell it's taken a toll thank
you mr barr you're recognized for five
minutes
thank you mr chairman
we've been engaged over several days as
i think you all can tell asking a series
of what i think are very insightful
questions and receiving a lot of
information
lest you leave from here with the
impression that everybody on that side
of the aisle is just can't say enough
nice things about you and we're all the
bad guys
uh specifically the gentleman from
michigan previously praised you and i'm
sure he was sincere in that
uh but uh just two years ago in in
testimony and when these hearings were
held he called what you did a disgrace
so
there's more than meets the year in
these things what we're trying to do
certainly over here is ask some
questions to avoid these problems coming
up in the future and i would certainly
hope that you all would would share in
that
um mr kavanagh i have in my hand here a
amount of play-doh
uh mr bush if you could
this is just just standard play-doh
if that were a flashbang grenade or a
stun grenade the same thing
uh which was live which pin had been
pulled would you feel comfortable just
holding that in your hand
well mr barr a flashbang grenade ejects
a cardboard tube about the bottom
so if you knew
you could probably have it hold it in a
proper way to have it eject a flashbang
grenade my answer is no i would not want
to hold it but a flashbang grenade
there's no fragmentation at all
i know that and don't don't anticipate
where i'm going with it i don't mean for
you to be defensive there's no reason to
earlier today there was testimony from
mr schumer uh that that these are not
devices that can harm somebody and in
fact they can can't they
well there is no fragmentation there is
concussion right and a blast is a
flashbang the same as a stun grenade
stun grenade yes okay are those are uh
classified as destructive devices under
uh uh 26 usc section 5845f aren't they
yes sure they are and as a matter of
fact the atf in court uh takes a
position in convicting people that
possess these devices that they are
destructive devices is that yes sir
that's correct uh that they can kill
people is that true well i think it
would be uh you'd have to hold it close
to your body or it but it's possible
certainly yes sir well uh a gentleman by
the name of warren l parker an
explosives enforcement officer bureau of
atf on may 11 1994 in court
said under oath that they are designed
to help kill the suspect while not
endangering the law enforcement officer
when they're used for those purposes
but anyway again i'm not being critical
of you or anything i think that there
were some mischaracters
mischaracterizations deliberately this
morning that i wanted to clear up with
regard to these
the question that i have uh re relates
to
what appear to be some some very serious
miscalculations on the part of law
enforcement officials trying to gauge
the response of the people inside
the the the facility there both at the
beginning of this uh we had agents
testified that despite the fact that
the folks on the inside knew what was
coming they had amassed large numbers of
weapons which is obvious from looking at
the questions and hearing y'all's
testimony the agent said they were
stunned they were surprised at what
happened uh and then on the other end
what we're talking about right now
going in with uh with i guess what you
all consider somewhat more benign
activities such as the the introduction
of the tear gas
somewhat some surprise on the part of
the firing that came out of there and so
forth
and the question um
i have i have here an autopsy photo and
i'm not going to introduce it because
it's it's rather gross
uh and it's very sad it it's a
photograph of a uh of a one-year-old
child
uh and uh the uh it's been burned and uh
right in the middle of the remains is a
ferret round
uh right right smack in the middle of
the remains of this one-year-old child
is a is a fair around with with the cs
gas
uh
i find it hard to to follow
y'all's thinking if the activities on
april 19th were considered to be benign
they caused a lot of deaths we may never
know exactly
who died a lot of the autopsies reveal
that people died from suffocation and
debris falling on them and we don't may
never know how much of that was caused
from the the walls caving in when when
the tanks came in and so forth or how
many others might have died from the
ferret rounds coming in
um
do you all feel uh and again i
i don't mean to be
critical but but i think there there was
some bad misgauging of
of responses on the other side uh do you
all recognize that that that in
hindsight certainly which is what we're
all operating under here uh that that
there were
miscalculations with regard to how these
folks in there would respond
uh to to what what they i think
correctly identified as aggressive moves
and i'm not saying the aggressive moves
were necessarily unjustified
uh is that is that of concern to you all
as you kind of look back on on this
whole process uh mr jamar
i think uh
the um
inability to get people to come out of
there with some gas was a surprise to us
the
fact that
made
the way of course was able to control
those people such that they didn't get
out
and the fact that they end up all
dying and i consider murder suicide
i think there were 17 who were shot in
there
when that was and how they were shot i
don't know
i think you're
saying uh here's a ferret round lying in
the remains of a one-year-old child and
then concluding that that child died
from that round is is
i think contrary to the
to the autopsy i would think um
but the
the
um
there's no question that
we were concerned about a mass suicide
we were
but other hand we were concerned that if
there was a mass suicide how could we
stop it
and the only means we had was gas
knowing and you all had accumulated a
great deal of information on on on the
branch davidians over the course of the
51 days i mean a great deal of
information both direct and and
conclusory uh
information on them
coming in as as happened on the 19th
with military vehicles
pushing cars out of the way and coming
in and interjecting
the cs gas directly into the building
and then as it progressed through i
think that the report says through every
window in the building
and my question is what what response
did you did you expect did you did you
really expect them just to come out no i
expected the tear gas to drive some
people out but you you didn't you
overstayed it these military vehicles
have been around here for seven weeks
this the the the view of the uh i know
they were in the area but they didn't
come up and started knocking down the
close the front door as you and i are
the uh the cars everything removed the
day before there was no crashing through
cars to get to the house
one tank approached the compound just
one
all the others were back
the bra the bradleys were behind the
concertina wire
they were announced we were not internet
the thing the semantics he was talking
about the assault
hitting the building and punching holy
building and ducking gas
is assault in any legal term but the
difference to us
when byron announced was not an assault
he
immediately fought that we are not
entering the compound was not an entry
we were never going to enter the
compound we would never fulfill that
aspect of the of the prophecy
but
the
uh the fact we used the military is they
had 50 calibers
weren't their walls knocked down
no not when they first approached just
punched a hole in and injected the gas
but but they're out there
after holes were made in the compound
i'm told
of witnessing everything else of the
nine survivors
seven are either directly rescued by an
hrt or came out of holes created by
those tanks
that's what i'm told from the survivor
mr wise you're recognized for five
minutes thank you i'm going to yield
some time but i just want to note uh
gentlemen
i i think you had an incredible task
ahead of you you're dealing with a child
abuser you're dealing with someone who's
molesting children who's knowingly
stockpiling automatic weapons uh who's
not wrapped real tight by anyone's
definition and yet you're supposed to
negotiate your way through that and i
think uh
that's why i'm greatly concerned about
some of the monday morning
quarterbacking that's going on on the
decisions that you had to make i think
you did the best you could in a terrible
situation at this point i would yield
two minutes to mr schumer and two
minutes to miss jackson lee
gentlemen for yielding
mr sage i want to take my chance my shot
at clearing up this business of whether
there was ever a real surrender
agreement as mr degaran and mr zimmerman
claimed yesterday so please answer the
questions as concisely as possible
first let me go through some of the
major previous occasions on which koresh
built
everybody up about coming out and then
cut them down and ultimately showed
himself to be a liar
first march 2nd this was the big day
when koresh promised that everybody was
coming out if a tape he made was
broadcast on the radio the tape was in
fact broadcast all sorts of preparations
were made for people lined up to come
out but david forest changed his mind
and broke his word did he not
uh and the reason he gave was that god
instructed him to wait did he not that's
right
second march 19th korres said he was
coming out in the next few days did he
not
yes
but in fact he never followed up on that
promise did he no sir he didn't
march 31st this was the passover promise
both of the attorneys who were here
yesterday the garen and zimmerman said
that korach had agreed to come out after
passover did they not
they said that yes and did himself not
confirm in a conversation on april 2nd
he was coming out after passover that's
correct
then there was some confusion about
exactly which date david recognized his
passover but after all those possible
dates passed again he again broke his
promise and did not come out did he
that's correct
so there were the just these three of
the major highlights of times koresh
promised to come out and broke his
promise now turning to the testimony you
heard yesterday and specifically the
claim that there was an agreement an
agreement a specific plan to surrender
not just some attorney's gratuitous
proposal but an agreement was there ever
such an agreement known to you
there was a hope embraced by the
attorneys in good faith there was never
an agreement that i was aware of thank
you so you never regard it as viable as
a firm deal as a real agreement the
proposal rooted through mr de garan to
wait until koresh had issued his
analysis of the seven seals you never
really thought that that was an
agreement so that you should stop
everything and wait did you
no sir
playing my time so that i can yield to
miss lee right i just had one final well
that's good enough
thank you mr wise thank you miss jackson
lee thank you very much mr schumer and
thank you very much mr wise
uh mr nasir i wanted to i asked you um
did you fail to take into consideration
uh david koresha's religious beliefs was
that something that was very much a part
of this ongoing negotiations and i just
needed maybe a yes or no in a sentence
that my time is limited as well we did
take it into consideration and were you
working with him then on
what he was attempting to get done in
order to get his word out
yes indeed i'm going to read
there was some discussion about
frustration these are not transcripts
that i believe are
done by the justice department i believe
these are summaries of transcripts given
to us by witnesses yesterday it reads
the transcript of the last recorded
words of david korish but it does
provide an interesting point because i
think these
individuals the theologians certainly
had concern about david koresh
it has the fbi saying i'm not frustrated
i went home and i'm back i'm no longer
frustrated i was never frustrated was
that the sense of the negotiations were
you continuing to try and do as much as
you could mr sage to ensure that these
people came out absolutely up to and
including the 19th
well i think that um
as we
looked at my
earlier questions i wanted to
come back again to the point of whether
or not we were going all the way to the
end and trying to make sure that these
people came out safely mr jamar had
asked you about the architectural
structure and whether you knew about it
i don't think you ever got to answer
that question and what was the
preparation in order for them to be able
to come out
what ways were you looking as the cns
gas was cs gas was going in what were
the exits that were clearly there for
them to be able to come out
i would appreciate it thank you
initial gas was going to be here in this
corner
it was there if you can speak louder i'd
appreciate it i'm sorry
the initial
gas was right
thought was we would here
this part of the building
and it would be clear to the occupants
what's coming next
that was always going to be
and the thought would be that they would
move
here but then
the hope was the realization that we're
not going to stop
the gas it's going to ultimately
make the whole place temporarily
uninhabitable that that was going to
come
we thought it would be some people would
still come out even with just one
one insertion
the there was this door
there were doors in the back
and they were not they were not
obstructed or they were not nailed shut
as far as you know we knew at the time
later on we discovered that this door
was there was no people coming out after
we put a lot of gas in there
the gas was not that effective
which i think we're going to get in more
detail later in the hearings but
the
we we thought people should be coming
out so we said let's see how bad let's
see if that door is blocked so we just
discovered that it was pushed up
and so we made it and your pushing was
what manual or by the uh oh it was pilot
with a ced all right
i understand vehicle
discovered that was not
uh that was barricaded so we put another
hole right here and was the whole
intention to cause an explosion or was
it to see if people would come out i was
to make an exit for them we discovered
by
we discovered this was blockaded we had
there was no other door in the front
that came out the windows which a couple
of people did come out the window but we
made a hole here so the holes were
specifically to be able to let anyone
who was finding an obstruction or could
not find their way here is a big hole
for you to come out of
we did that later over here
inside this little courtyard and we did
it over here
right in here by the visuals on
television would you say it was a
coincidence that as some of that grammy
was occurring the fire sprung up which
gave the impression that that might have
caused the fire well i think that from
television i think most people tell me
they saw this smoke here first and i
think about seven or eight minutes
previous
so there had been
the approach from here and the tank had
pulled away
now
from
the observation i was able to make after
from air there was a huge fire behind
this tower right here in the kitchen
area
there was another fire here it was very
easily discernible from
from the air
okay now the wire tap the microphone
prior
prior to
12 o'clock
right at 12 right in that area
not 12 15.
the log out i mean the transcriptase did
not have a precise time but it was after
11 40.
let's not let the fire go out
the fire is already going
prior i think to this but we hadn't just
hadn't seen it yet it makes me think it
was there probably because
the i think the microphone was right in
here somewhere
i think that's the fire we're talking
about we saw this shoot up
seeing it shoot up no i think this is
what you saw on tv i didn't see this one
for a long time
and but i believe i'm not over here
between 11th party and because when that
when the
uh whenever that tank entered right here
later that's when the microphone went
out well miss jacksonville your time is
inspired mr jamar will be back for two
more panels doing exactly this type of
thing thank you very much mr chairman i
wanted to emphasize the escape route i
thank you very much for giving me uh the
time thank you thank you mr wise
chairman can i make one comment in
furtherance of the topic of today's
panel negotiation well you may mr sage
as but mr zelf has time to have so much
do you want to do it at the end or
that's fine this has nothing to do with
miss jackson lee's question i assume it
does somewhat because of the may he
answered that then mr chairman yes
that's why i was getting around to mrs
jackson
rather wait to the end go ahead there is
a connection in that uh when we began to
uh
with the insertion plan of the of the cs
gas one thing that this panel please
needs to remember is that that did not
mark the end of negotiations it was our
intent and i was instructed to go out
there prepared to negotiate continue
negotiations from forward
to facilitate the safe and orderly exit
of those people for up to 48 hours
it did not herald the end of
negotiations we were hoping that it
would prompt
the end of the standoff
zello if you're recognized for five
minutes thank you chairman
you know
we have a great deal of respect for all
of you and the testimony you've given
today and we had equal amount of respect
for mr zimmerman mr de garan yesterday
they spent six hours in
very credible uh testimony and
i'm really torn in trying to listen to
them and then to you in terms of this
negotiation offer and i just want to
understand exactly you know your
apparently had a two-hour conversation
with webster hubble on april 15th
and for the record did you or did you
not tell him even in a general way as
part of that two-hour conversation
was there a surrender offer on the table
that had been discussed with karesh the
crash's lawyers the texas rangers which
stay in their testimony admitted to last
night and which mr jamar was aware
i will state again
that
there is much more importance placed on
this uh evolution than was in fact there
on the 15th of april you didn't mention
it let me finish it was not an agreement
i do not specifically remember
highlighting it because there was no
credibility to it at that time
we were hoping there would be but it had
not come to pass texas rangers felt that
there was
a
agreement of sorts uh they were aware
that um
we i mean it it's it's in my judgment
it's very hard for us to listen to what
we heard last night
and then with the seriousness of what
we're going forward with on april 19th
on a plan that and i guess what i'm
trying to figure out did anybody have an
open mind or was the gas plan going to
be the deal
the open mind is exhibited by the fact
that we probed this issue extensively
from the
14th until up to and including the
evening of the 18th
uh specifically attempting to determine
whether or not there had been any
demonstrated
progress in the area of this alleged
manuscript there had been none according
not according to us
according to steve schneider there had
been none
did what was mr hubble's reaction
to what sir did
did he did he ask you if there were any
last-minute plans discussed in terms of
any surrender
my recollection of the discussion with
mr hubbell was the the overall dynamics
from the perspective of a negotiator
that had been there in the trenches for
the entire period of time nearly 50 days
i again i don't i'm not attempting to be
evasive here at all i'm trying to be as
candid as i possibly can the reason i
can't definitively state it is because
it was not the issue that you're
portraying it to be
i'm just trying to think we're talking
about a plan and also in in the book
here on page 271 justice department
april 16th
uh
mark richard assistant ag met with
hubbell and carl stern director of the
office of public affairs according to
richard i'll advise him the attorney
general had disapproved the plan to end
the fbi standoff i will then ask richard
what he thought of the fbi's reaction
might be richard answered that the fbi
would not be pleased
i mean i i'm just trying to go through
all these conflicts and try to come up
with some reasonable base
that
and i guess we never
probably won't know
mr zella can i can i add to that yes
i think we're i haven't said this very
well today at all
we're going from
a
discussion of a surrender plan
and an agreement from the previous
early april to come out after
passover
we heard the overhears he was going to
change the day to passover it didn't
occur
mr de garan had put
his best professional ability and his
heart and soul into it and didn't it
just didn't happen he was
of course refused okay he didn't give up
he stayed after and he came up with this
one just like laura came up with a case
this is the case that's going to do it
and what he had here was a judge that
wasn't going to permit that case to be
considered
but it didn't stop him from doing it
didn't stopping us and listening but
for them to
imply that there was an agreement with
us okay we will hold off and not do
anything until this is resolved in 10 or
12 days is this not the case that was
never even close
i valued my relationship very much with
mr de garan and it bothered me for him
to say and maybe he had said it i'd read
it in the newspaper that i had lied to
him that day it's not the
case okay he took let me finish what he
did was he's trying he's a person used
to being successful he doesn't run into
failure that much
and he wanted to make sure and i think
he just like he took he took
uh the uh what chorus was saying
i think he maybe wanted more out of what
i said plus and then it followed very
soon thereafter which made him even more
upset i'm certain of that if i can let
me just go through one other then and
and again
i'm just trying to figure this all out
so to somebody ask me
at a town meeting i can explain it to
them and it makes sense and they'll
accept it and i think that's what all of
us really are trying to do how can we
explain it to the american people
there's a visual image that i have and i
don't know whether it was cnn or
whatever
that i saw the tanks going in and i also
heard the recording this is not an
assault
but the tanks were penetrating that
building and if i were inside i would
figure it's probably an assault maybe i
don't and i'll give you a chance both to
answer
um
but the problem let me just finish
because i'm going to run out of time
then you guys can take as much time
that's the way we've got it worked out
here
um
the
i want to just show that
and ruby ridge
the uh and i'll introduce and if the
clerk will pass a copy of this
um
on the marshall service crisis center
log
there was a little footnote in there and
it's article or it's noted as 567 crisis
center log august 22nd 1992
entering at 4 50 pm the log also stated
that weather was a major factor and by
the way somebody said there was no new
information the winds were 30 to 35
miles an hour at waco i believe on the
19th and i'd like to address that too
but
late that afternoon but might be passed
back because of weather conditions
concern was raised about the deployment
of gas into the residents because of
high degree of risk to small children
and the possibility that a one-year-old
baby was inside
and
and
and i guess
i'm just trying to figure out
as we move forward with the plan on
april 19th
um
and you know just this is just a quick
question
did you in the early morning hours of
the 19th or the late hours of the 18th
ever tell women and children inside the
compound that negotiations have come to
an end
and that this is their last chance to
come out before the gas was inserted
and
and and the biggest question is why did
we use the gas when we knew in ruby
ridge that it was wrong why would we use
it at waco and i'll let both of you
respond
the
decision to use cs gas was based on the
information we see in the research we
received we went on effect on the
decision was made based on cs gas as not
to be
could be possibly effective to them but
not to be permanently damaging or deadly
we went on that premise
it was not a cavalier attitude towards
children by any stretch of imagination
we were confident from the information
we had that this gas
is the is the tear gas is the best
if we're going to have to use tear gas
it's the the least
toxic caustic whatever everyone who said
that it's not toxic at all it's just but
it's but we did not
think that children would be permanently
damaged and or otherwise harmed by that
gas if we'd have thought that
i promise you mr zelda we wouldn't have
done that
if i believed that i wouldn't have done
it
can i uh answer that
first of all before i i address that
issue you mentioned earlier that the
texas ran something about the texas
rangers thinking that he was prepared to
come out
uh
by basically excuse me i don't want to
leave a false impression my
understanding of the conversation
yesterday is a matter of record that
that they were aware of a plan that mr
uh
uh
the guerin had had worked out with the
branch davidians okay they by this time
they were an integral part of our
negotiation team the rangers were part
of the negotiation team from
approximately mid-march
uh they should have been earlier on
that's that's a
one of the mistakes uh
my feeling is that i should have brought
them into it or made a recommendation to
bring them into it considerably earlier
but they were part of the analysis they
were part of the uh
of the negotiation team at that time and
they certainly agreed with the at least
my my recollection is that they agreed
fully with it
um so
they were of of a common mind with us
with the rest of the of the combined
joint
agency negotiation team that korach had
no intention of coming out they agreed
with that fully
um
you had mentioned that uh that or you
had asked whether or not we had told
them that negotiations were over and
that gas was to be tear gasses to be
inserted uh negotiations were not over
we stood ready to continue to facilitate
those negotiations the call was put in
there
as i mentioned at 5 59
approximately the morning of the 19th of
april steve schneider listened to the
initial portion of my
discourse to him where bonnie hung up
and shortly thereafter through the
window or the
phone out the window a little difficult
to negotiate with the phone out the
window
and we still stood ready to
re-initiate that if in fact they would
indicate
that the reestablishing of that phone
was to facilitate the safe and orderly
release
or exit of everyone in that compound we
stood ready to do that sir up until
the flames ended i guess the only
question i had and the only reason i
asked it again with the red light on is
did we at any time give them formal
notice that
that it was over even if it was two
seconds before you put the gas in before
the gas was inserted in the building yes
sir we gave them notice that that they
have two seconds to come out before we
start or no we gave them notice before
the first
cev had uh had made it anywhere near the
the compound to begin the gassing
operation they were notified both over
the phone and simultaneously over the
loudspeaker system because i did it
i had the phone to my ear and the
microphone to my chest
i guess the problem that i have and i
won't have it figured out yet is if the
stuff at ruby ridge if cs gas was bad
there why wasn't it bad at waco and i'll
have to figure out
sort that out
as we go through the rest of the
testimony
unless you want to add into it well i
think there'd be a full-length panel
discussion tomorrow about that
thank you very much mr zella i yield
myself the five minutes i don't believe
there's any other body anybody else who
has time left on this
and then we'll conclude the panel first
of all i want to uh though i will thank
you formally when you do get recess
thank all of you for the time today
several of you will not be back although
mr jamar i believe maybe mr sage will be
back i know you're going backwards three
times
uh all together
uh i do want to make the comment that i
i find almost everything today you said
to be
right down the line what i expect from
my fbi i think you you've explained this
very very adequately for most people's
consideration the only really disturbing
thing that remains here today and you
should be aware of it by the tone of all
the questions is the sense that i think
several of us get up here that
you didn't take seriously and maybe you
shouldn't i'm not saying you should have
but that you didn't take very seriously
the ideas that mr degarin was presenting
on the 14th of april that there was
really something new here um and what mr
tabor or dr tabor and dr arnold said to
us last night that they felt that this
was a real breakthrough with quresh and
that indeed he was looking at things
differently on the 14th in terms of his
prophecies and they really didn't intend
to commit
suicide if you will or be a martyr or
kill people or have people die at that
point that he had completely changed
and i can understand why you might not
buy into that but it appears that
because you didn't
that even if it were conveyed back up
there that neither you mr sage nor you
mr jamar
personally thought enough of it to make
a big point of it at least a point well
enough emphasized to potentially get the
full flavor of that back through the
chain to the attorney general and i
think from today's testimony it's pretty
clear that you two didn't do that now
i'm not faulting you for not doing it
necessarily but it is a point that i
think is worthy of our being concerned
simply because that is the point that
those who are most concerned about this
incident have raised with regard to the
negotiating part that is what they have
criticized most directly and i think we
now have a pretty good grip on why now
with that in mind just two quick
questions not related to that
mr nutsner i want to ask you something
uh the appear whether it's from mr revis
book or whether it's some testimony that
i've heard in the last few days and gosh
we've heard a lot of stuff i'm not sure
where but it's my impression that there
were tapes
that were shown back inside the compound
during the siege that were made of the
children that did come out or some of
the children and in order to demonstrate
they were okay and that in part one of
the critics has said that this upset the
folks inside not because the kids were
ill or anything but they were shown
eating candy bars and doing things which
would not have been permitted inside the
compound and that this was
extraordinarily upsetting and could
potentially have had some effect inside
negatively on all the negotiations could
you comment on that is that accurate did
those tapes go back in was that in
retrospect somewhat of an error no it
wasn't an error whatsoever in fact it
was a very innovative strategy and i
think we might have got one complaint
from one mother who was already
had demonstrated a great deal of anger
at us and was mad because her child was
eating ice cream something which she
never allowed other than that we think
they were extremely positive the intent
of sending the tapes in there
was to demonstrate to the parents that
their kids were being well cared for but
more than that when the kids would come
out they would have little notes saying
that my child is to be sent to a
relative or a friend to be raised as
negotiators we were concerned that this
was in essence the parents
taking care of the final responsibility
of their children settling their affairs
and now being willing to set the stage
for their suicide what we convey to the
parents is that no the children are not
being sent off to aunt sophie in des
moines that in fact they're staying
right here with the child protective
services and we're waiting for you to
come out and resume your parental
responsibilities and we also think those
tapes had a very powerful impact on
doing what we intended and that was
tugging at the heartstrings of these
mothers to try to rekindle their
maternal and
fatherly uh responsibilities to break
them from the hypnotic sway of david
koresh we also sent a very innovative
tape in david cress sent his first we
sent tapes to the kids and he sent a
tape out on march 8. we did something to
my knowledge never done anywhere we sent
in a tape of the negotiators
and i and four or five other negotiators
who had talked with them at that time
each of us were videotaped showing
photographs of our families
and personalizing the negotiations
saying
mr crash david my name's gary i'm one of
the ones that's been talking to you and
this is my family and i love my family
and i know how you love your family and
i want you and everyone in there to know
that we're doing everything within our
power out here to make sure that you and
everyone inside your children are going
to come out here safely and they're
going to be treated with dignity and
respect i think those tapes accomplished
a great deal in fact when kathy
schroeder watched the tapes
she was so moved that her child byron
needed her that john dolan now retired
fbi negotiator was absolutely brilliant
in convincing her that little brian
needed more than anything else right now
a hug from his mommy and she immediately
without consulting with david cares said
i'm coming out tomorrow and she did
well i think that point is well made mr
sage i want to ask you and then perhaps
have mr nesner mr smerk or anyone else
comment on this as you want about
the mass suicide commitment i'm confused
a little bit and i'd like you to express
this to me in the report the justice
department report it appears that near
the end of all of this the 15th 16th
17th when they're discussing this back
in washington they've reached the
conclusion based on representations from
you
that it is your impression that suicide
is not likely it's like it's not it's
possible but now at this point you
didn't think it was likely
however
we've heard testimony today i think mr
jamar you made it and i i'm going to
turn to mr sage first but i'm more than
happy to have you comment on it
that at some point afterwards whether
that's because of the fire tapes i'm not
sure what you need to clarify for us
that you concluded that there was a
suicide pact at least i'm thinking
that's what you said if not we need to
clarify it
however at the time you did not think so
i'm of the impression that the tapes
that were made of the last few days of
the discussions that went on and the
negotiations and so on or the perhaps
the eavesdropping tapes
that those together what was presented
to us in part last night by doctors
arnold and tabor
would demonstrate that the folks inside
weren't leading up to the seventh to the
19th
at all in a suicide attitude that that
perhaps since the
second or so of march they were for the
first time in those last few days
openly optimistic
talking about coming out
of being
an attitude that was just much more
upbeat in the last two or three days of
this or last four or five days
they attribute that is arnold and taber
and i believe the garen this attitude
shift that's shown in these tapes that
they say
they've reviewed that of course are in
existence and i'm sure you've reviewed
and you of course were hearing it at the
time
uh to the change in koresha's
viewpoint of the world in the basic
interpretation of the seals and so on i
don't want to get too much into that but
that's what they attribute it to but
nonetheless
whatever the reason may be
uh they say those tapes would
demonstrate and the conversations and
the attitudes of the people all people
in the compound that suicide was the
furthest thought from their mind
prior to the entry of the gas
at and the notice of that in the early
morning hours of the 19th uh for the
previous several days
which is it now we look back i'm just
asking this
do you how do you reconcile this
was your first impression right
and that would of course been consistent
with the tapes
of their interpretation of the tapes
tapers arnold's and the garens
that the folks inside were not
contemplating suicide
up through this point and
or was it that they had a suicide pact
and they were ready to release it
uh or is there a way to reconcile these
two
and uh i just knowing what you know
about koresh
and the people inside the compound all
these negotiations
before we dismiss this panel today
and negotiators part of this i'd like to
know
i would too
throughout the course of this 51 day
period of negotiations as i mentioned
before we address this issue head on
which is a recommended approach do you
intend to commit suicide i have
several examples where he steadfastly
denied any intention
uh nor did he embrace the concept of a
mass suicide
the bottom line on this
sir in my estimation is that this man
was an absolute master of deceit
he also exercised absolute control
over his followers
i
he may well write a new chapter in the
behavioral science books and so forth
we took him
at his word
not just from these quotes but from some
of the the subtle
responses that we elicited from him that
were
and from others in there that were
survival oriented we now know with the
luxury of hindsight which we did not
have them but we all now have today
from testimony of some of the surviving
branch davidians that yes they did have
a suicide pact and it's it's very clear
that they
did in fact at the direction
or at the hands of david korsch consume
the lives of over 78 branch davidians on
the 19th
mr jamar or mr nasser
uh let me let me count you you comment
you also will frequently see some
ambivalence with suicide
um and that is some uncertainty in doubt
there are those who suggest and i don't
necessarily agree with those who say
david kresh
was was planning every moment knew
exactly what he was going to do and had
a specific end in mind i don't
necessarily buy that i believe david
kresh was stalling and playing day for
day he'd certainly prepared his
followers for suicide that was part of
his theology and i think based upon the
events as they unfolded and how he
interpreted them impacting on him that
was the determining factor as to whether
or not any suicidal act would follow and
i think ultimately on that final day for
david to give up his kingdom and all his
special privileges to go to jail was
more than he could do um it's just he
even mentioned at one point in time we
have it a tape he said he said i don't
want to become bubba's love toy in
prison but refrain but again i don't
want to elaborate because my time's
expired i want you to answer but tabor
arnold and de garan would interpret it
as meaning that he decided on suicide if
he did
uh or the group did after the gas was
being inserted or at the time it was or
in preparation for it when they knew
about it that their attitude was
different in the preceding five days and
none of you have addressed that whether
you think that the tapes show show that
their attitude was inconsistent with
suicide for those preceding days and
whether the hypothesis that's been put
forward by
arnold tabor and de garin
could be
debunked or not well i'm not sure if i
fully understand but i do think that the
insertion of the gas certainly triggered
in david koresh's mind that he was going
to begin this suicidal
plan there's no question if you're if
the question is did the insertion of the
sewer got
excuse me the insertion of the gas
triggered david koresh's implementing
his ideas about suicide i think yes he
did
anyone else want to comment i don't want
to believe it i just wanted to follow a
negotiated negotiator there um
the analysis we did
was how serious is the suicide
pact in there from
march first on
well we didn't hear anything specific
until victory and hogsworth came out on
march 21st
okay her statement was corroborated by
marjorie thomas who was one of the
survivors of the fire and by um
kathy schroeder who came out on her uh
or expelled i think by courage
that was in our minds but the analysis
if we do this are we just going to have
a mass suicide
and our thinking was
that
if there is a plan for mass suicide that
we don't think there was at the time and
it starts how are we going to stop it
only when we can stop it is to put it
insert cs gas
i don't but we were hopeful that
when we did this it would drive the
people out make the place uninhabitable
we were extremely hopeful there was no
suicide plan were we certain of it
absolutely not
i think but the analysis and the
recommendations that most people
analysis recommend that it was not based
on all this conversation for all these
weeks
i think that
when you
the reading of something if you really
believe something you're going to read
into it anyway
i think what i will do is i'll re-read
those with with
what you described to me i'll give that
as
open mind as i can give i'll re-read
those the tapes the tapes with that in
mind
but uh
again i didn't say it was it was bogus i
didn't i didn't really reject that plan
all i said was give us something this
weekend that'll show that you're there
that you're serious
but they didn't all they give us was the
stall language i haven't seen the first
tape i haven't seen the first page i'm
going to edit it you're not going to get
it till i edit it i haven't seen the
first page if we get that on sunday
that's what we were getting i i wouldn't
when getting any of this
uh
i think uh hopeful description of we
have a new light and everything's
wonderful in here i never get that at
all but i will re-read those both the
the overhears
and the negotiation transcripts i'll
read with that in mind with nothing else
in mind i'll read that will you be back
with us and i appreciate it if you would
do it be very helpful to us i want to
thank this panel for spending the much
of the day with us today it's been a
very extraordinary day and a very
important day uh we will resume with two
or three of you in the future but that's
it for now we're going to have the the
second panel be commenced
after you've had a chance to to get up
and the other folks can come in thank
you mr chairman
thank you
yes
appreciate it i appreciate it
[Music]
if we could we're not really in recess
we need to have
as much expedition as we can here we've
got several people who are coming in as
witnesses i'd like to start introducing
them
uh if we can if we can get the first
panel cleared out
i know that's not quickly and easily
done sometimes but we're as we know
we're running long hours in the
subcommittee
our second panel today i will begin the
introduction of and please have seats
there are name plates up here for your
position and i will swear you in and
then we'll talk about the procedure for
this panel dr allen stone has been the
tour of
glick a professor of law and psychiatry
at harvard university since 1982
dr stone has been board certified in
psychiatry for almost 30 years he is a
past president of the american
psychiatric society as a professor of
harvard he holds appointments on both
the faculties of the law school and the
medical school at harvard
dr william marcus our second witness on
this panel is senior science advisor at
the office of science and technology of
the environmental protection agency he
is board certified in toxicology by the
american board of toxicologists he is
also the associate editor of the journal
of environmental pathology
toxicology and oncology
dr paul rice our third panelist today is
a medical doctor and pathologist since
1987 he has served as head of pathology
and general toxicology
for the chemical defense establishment
important down salisbury england
our next panelist is dr david upshaw who
holds a phd in toxicology and is a
registered toxicologist in england as a
manager of a section of the chemical and
biological defense establishment
important down salisbury england he is
involved in research on inhalation and
cellular toxicology research
our next panelist is dr george eulig he
is professor of chemistry and
mathematics at the college of eastern
utah
he also is vice president for research
and development at thermic laboratories
in new york city
dr eulig is a 23-year veteran of the air
force retiring with the rank of
lieutenant colonel
and our last member on this panel today
is mr hayes parks a special assistant to
the judge advocate general of the army
he is an expert in international law
relating to military operations and has
served as a member of the united states
delegations for law of war negotiations
on many occasions he has taught at the
army air force and naval war colleges
and is an adjunct professor at george
washington university mr park served in
vietnam as an infantry company commander
and later as a judge advocate he retired
from the united states marine corps with
the rank of colonel now if he'd ask all
of you to please rise i will swear you
in
raise your right hand
do you swear affirm that the testimony
you're about to give today shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
please be seated let the record reflect
that all of the witnesses answered in
the affirmative
today's second panel will be a little
different in that four of the witnesses
by
pre-agreement will give 10-minute
testimony each
i'm going to introduce you in a certain
order for this so you can prepare
yourselves for that as i described the
rest of the procedure dr eulig will be
first
dr upshaw will be second doctor marcus
will be third and dr rice will be fourth
to try to just give us the flavor and
balance it's a our best estimate of how
this should be proceeding so dr euleg dr
upshaw dr marcus and dr rice in that
order now the way this is going to work
is that you've got 10 minutes i'm going
to turn the timer on when each of you
begins the timer is scheduled to run for
five minutes not 10. so you'll see it
come on a yellow light will go off
you'll have then another five minutes
and it'll run down to a second yellow
light and we really do have to keep with
us just as we do up here with our
questioners or we won't get through this
this will take us a while to do
but the better part probably in the next
45
minutes or so but we need to try to keep
on this as much as possible but i think
it's important for the cs gas questions
that you're going to be discussing for
us to give you a chance to explain this
to us since there's a lot of technical
stuff here rather than just starting out
with a question session
so with that in mind if we could begin
with you dr euleg i will turn the timer
on if you're ready to proceed and you're
recognized for ten minutes
dr mr chairman thank you so much for the
opportunity to come here let me start
out with a very positive
side i've heard a lot of negative today
it's been about 15 years since i've had
a good helping of collard greens and you
serve some real good ones downstairs in
a restaurant
let's go ahead and press on on cs
i'm a chemist
i'm not an expert in cs the first time
that i experienced what the effects of
cs were
was when my
research assistant danita dingman and i
made a videotape that i've got here of
the combustion of cs methylene chloride
on
cardboard worked very well i should say
and that video is
is there
i'm not going to try and
bamboozle you with a lot of fancy
equations we're going to make reference
to amounts of cs agent
uh being an educator i like to use
little tiny saccharine tablets
so that you get a feeling for the size
and weights of cs
based on force we all know about what
the heft of the quarter is
now cs is an abbreviation that many of
us would use for brevity sake
as a chemist it stands for alpha chloro
benzilla dean malono nitrile that's a
mouthful and a half especially at this
time in this
hearing
it really takes its name from the two
scientists that discovered it
poorson and stouton
they prepared it in 1928.
it's been the standard riot control
agent of the army since about 1959.
i was horrified to find it in the
possession of my female students in my
classes is a self-protection device
10
cs and methylene chloride and they carry
these little tubes
in their purses
the physical state actually of cs is a
powder
usually a cream-colored powder not a gas
you disperse it
as an aerosol cloud of finely diverted
particles
by blowers bursting grenades
ferret rounds or burning a mixture of
the powder
and a fuel
the effects of cs are described in army
publications that i was able to get my
hands on
as impressive
you need about 20 milligrams per cubic
meter
to affect incapacitation
this little tiny saccharine tablet that
you barely can see
is 20 milligrams actually about that
it's a way some of them weigh 18
milligrams some of them 20.
so that's about the size in a cubic
meter
now a cubic meter is about the volume of
your standard 36 inch diagonal tv set
okay
now if i were to go and that's contains
about 35 cubic feet
of air
if i stuck my head in there with one of
these little tiny tablets
for one minute i would breathe about 1
64th of this tablet if the army
calculations are correct and they seem
to be to me
and that would incapacitate me what does
it mean to be incapacitated by cs
now understand this is for the
usual dosage
the affected persons experience severe
burning sensations in the eyes with
copious tears
my research assistant danita dingman
experienced this
in making this video
the eyes close
involuntarily the nose runs and moist
skin stings
amnesty international produced the
report towards the end of the 1980s
they were concerned about the excessive
use of cs by the israeli defense forces
or the idf and the occupied territories
their findings
about what it meant to be incapacitated
in excess of amounts of cs
intense tearing of the eyes
shortness of breath
irritation of the respiratory tract
similar to an acute asthma attack
chemical burns
intense nausea wretching abdominal
cramps
and particularly in children severe and
protracted diarrhea that's a quote from
their report
i tried to get some feeling for the
amount of cs used at waco
very difficult
to get your hands on accurate data
but nonetheless it appears that about
400 of these
ferret rounds were used or in excess of
them there are some sources that
indicate a flight right
round was used
some folks would go as high as
oh
as much as 500 pounds of csus i have a
tendency to discount that
i think it was more on the order of
around four and a half to seven and a
half pounds
uh if you're an animal
we understand very well
what the toxicology of cs is
if you're a
pig for instance
about 5600 milligrams which is the
weight
of about two and a half dollars worth of
these quarters
and this is injected in the space of a
cubic meter over one minute if you're a
guinea pig
it's about a dollar and a half the
weight of a dollar and a half worth of
quarters now don't go quoting me that a
guinea pig's only worth a buck and a
half
it's a weight of the quarters
i ran across an article when the british
tested elon fire extinguishers on humans
they found that the toxicity levels were
considerably lower
than that for rats and i'm going to
quote from them the british have a
marvelous way of expressing themselves
this may be because of the greater
mental complexity of the human organism
and the different body chemistry or
maybe simply the rats were
feeling rather odd but nobody knew
now the best i've been able to do
uh making a calculation of what it would
take to completely kill people
in quresh's size facility would be in
excess of a thousand pounds of age
applied in that facility i think that
that's just totally inconceivable in my
mind
i tried to get a better estimate of the
amount of cs that could have been
injected based on the fireball
seen by survivors and assuming
that the dust would carry that fireball
through the hallways
i was fortunate in finding a publication
from the fire institute at leicester
england
that gave me a range of dust particles
so if i were to take about a quarter of
a sack of this
equal
right here
and dispense it into a cubic foot
then i would have
sufficient material by the way equal
does burn very nicely so does sodium
bicarbonate at about those ranges soda
cement powder at about those ranges
okay
so it could have happened
but when you do that
and you cut things down and you look at
an orders of magnitude less
than that you reach the conclusion about
75 pounds to 750 pounds which i still
think is excessive
i looked at the logistics of bringing
that kind of that amount of material in
a 55 gallon drum according to
manufacturers literature contains about
200 pounds of cs
if i'm looking at an agent called cs1
which is a much more persistent agent
uh this comes ten eight pound bags
packed in a 55 gallon drum so the
logistics of the situation
to bring a thousand pounds on site would
be five 55 gallon drums
13 55 gallon drums of the
cs1 material
methylene chloride by the way in and of
itself is a toxic material
i really
the amount injected at
waco that day the probably the lowest
estimate would be sufficient to
incapacitate people in about
two hundred thousand square foot kmart
stores just to give you a feeling for it
it was probably two to four times the
amount that you would need to
incapacitate people in david koresh's
complex
just to give you a feeling for that
particular number
i think attorney general reno and this
is my opinion uh may have gotten her
wish
regarding the children gas masks don't
fit children very well
they probably
have taken a look at some of the data
the bodies and number of children were
found in the vault area
these people were probably asphyxiatedly
early on in the game either by the
carbon dioxide injected or
by the methylene chloride vapor and all
the methylene chloride would have been a
vapor
calculations using the ideal gas law
you'll indicate this you can take me to
task because i didn't do all my
sums but you know
there isn't that much hard data
available
in my in my opinion
the attempt to bring the siege at the
branch davidian complex
to a conclusion was really botched
i think it was congressman connors my
time is up according to my watch
congressman connors made the statement
that a lot of money was being spent to
look at this
in my opinion perhaps the law
enforcement agency should have gone
ahead and admitted
to making some boneheads
and just pressed on and told this
committee what they were doing to take
care of it it's a lot like a cat that we
have at home we call snoozer
we play hide and seek with snoozer
when it snoozer's turn to be found she's
got just her head either under the
curtains or under the couch she gets
terribly annoyed when we find her
but you know quarter of hers under the
couch three quarters hanging out similar
to this type of investigation my time's
up mr chairman thank you thank you very
much dr eulig and i won't dispute uh
you're taking the amount of time you did
but for all of you knowing that the
green light's still on over here you you
would you would have still had time
under my keeping for at least one more
minute but i'm happy
that we can save some time because you
did that very well and i appreciate it i
think all chairmen do
next i would like to uh introduce dr
david upshaw dr um could you give us
your thoughts
thank you mr chairman
um dr rice and i are providing a joint
statement so he will not be can you uh
turn on your mind i don't know i'm sorry
all right i'll bring it up closer one of
the two i apologies
thank you mr chairman
dr rice and i are providing a joint
statement dr rice will not give you a
separate statement at the end thank you
i'm dr david upshur and i'm accompanied
by my colleague dr paul rice
i'm a technical manager at the united
kingdom chemical and biological defense
establishment which is the united
kingdom defense establishment
responsible for research upon chemicals
in warfare
i've worked at this establishment since
1966
after returning from a postdoctoral
fellowship the university of california
and pesticide toxicology
i'm a biochemical and inhalation
toxicologist
and was closely involved in much of the
research which contributed to the uk
hemsworth report upon cs following the
first use of this material in northern
ireland
my colleague dr rice
is a medically qualified pathologist
with experience in both human and
veterinary pathology
and during his 10 years of the chemical
and biological defense establishment
he's been responsible for advising the
military on the care of chemical warfare
casualties
and more recently has been actively
involved in advising the british home
secretary on the use of cs by british
police forces
we are here today to provide expert
opinion on the use of cs at waco
before proceeding further it might be
helpful to you for me to provide you
with a brief resume of cs and its
properties
as already mentioned cs is a chemical
first discovered in the united states in
1928
and developed for use as a tear gas
for the control of civil disturbances in
the mid to late 1950s
it's been available commercially and
widely used by law enforcement agencies
throughout the world for over 30 years
tear gas is perhaps an inappropriate
technical description since it is not a
gas and when used it is generated either
as a smoke or a fog
when used it may be generated from a
pyrotechnic device that's a burning
device
or from a solution in methylene chloride
and it was this formulation that was
used in general at waco
when exposed to cs
human beings experience a burning
sensation of the mucous membranes of the
eyes
the nose the throat
and to a lesser extent the skin
particularly if moist
this is this produces prolific tearing
of the eyes
mucus secretion from the nose and
salivation from the mouth
and there is intense blepharospasm and
what that means is an uncontrollable
blinking of the eyelids
similar to that which we all experience
when we get a piece of soap in our eyes
the effects produced are in general
dependent upon the concentration of cs
in the air surrounding the individual
and some useful numbers are
that four milligrams per cubic meter of
air
which is a volume of about 39 inches by
39 inches by 39 inches
will disperse disperse most members of a
rioting crowd
and 10 milligrams per cubic meter of air
will deter trained troops
however humans can detect cs in their
environment at concentrations about a
thousand times lower than this slight
prickling of the nose
now this is true of course for
unprotected individuals
those wearing gas masks would be totally
unaffected
while it is once it is the concentration
of cs in the air that determines the
response
it's important to remember that is the
time for which one is exposed to this
concentration that determines the dosage
to the individual
you may hear during discussions with
this panel the term ct
this is merely the result of multiplying
the concentration the c
by the time t
in minutes for which one is exposed and
is a measure of the total exposure of
the individual
i'll now move to a summary of our
assessment and conclusions of the use of
cs at the waco incident
using the information provided to us by
the fbi and available within the report
to the deputy attorney general on the
events of waco we've made an assessment
of the concentrations of cs achieved
inside the building's complex
to do this we made a limited number of
assumptions
based upon the knowledge that there were
four phases of cs insertion
from cylinders mounted on cev vehicles
and supported by ferret rounds
in total around 380 ferret rounds were
used
and in general were fired in support of
the cylinder insertions
we have assumed that one quarter that is
about 95
of the total number of ferret rounds
were fired during each of the cev
insertions
we assumed that all of those ferret
rounds entered the building
though in reality we know this was not
true
we also assumed a very low rate of air
change
within the building's complex about one
change per hour
though in reality we know that this also
was not true
since most windows have been broken and
many large holes have been created in
the building walls
the wind speed was also high i believe
it should be up to 28 miles per hour
this higher rate of ventilation within
the building would have reduced the
concentration of cs
below that which we have calculated
and would also accelerate the mixing of
cs
and air inside the building
despite these assumptions we calculate
that the concentrations of cs within the
building
did not exceed around 110 milligrams per
cubic meter of air at the time of
insertion and would decay rapidly after
this time
though it must be accepted that close to
the point of release for a short period
of time it would have been higher than
this
assumed that all of those ferret rounds
entered the building
though in reality we know this was not
true we also assumed a very low rate of
air change
within the building's complex about one
change per hour
though in reality we know that this also
was not true
since most windows have been broken and
many large holes have been created in
the building walls
the wind speed was also high i believe
it should be up to 28 miles per hour
this higher rate of ventilation within
the building would have reduced the
concentration of cs
below that which we have calculated and
would also accelerate the mixing of cs
and air inside the building
despite these assumptions we calculate
that the concentrations of cs within the
building
did not exceed around 110 milligrams per
cubic meter of air
at the time of insertion and would decay
rapidly after this time
though it must be accepted that close to
the point of release for a short period
of time it would have been higher than
this
to put this in context this would be the
concentration a person would experience
approximately 60 feet
downwind from a ride control grenade
when functioned in the open air
our general conclusions are
that the concentrations of cs achieved
inside the building were not excessive
that the concentrations would have
achieved the desired effect of
encouraging the occupants to leave the
contaminated spaces
and that even if the occupants chose to
remain in the spaces for the entire six
hour period
between the start of the operation
and the commencement of the fire
they would only have accumulated a
dosage of cs that was approximately 10
to 12 times less than that estimated to
cause us
to cause serious harm to humans
finally i'd like to add that in
reviewing this case
both dr rice and i were greatly saddened
and moved by the tragic loss of life
that we saw
particularly of the children at waco
however it's our sincere belief that cs
played no direct part in these deaths
thank you
thank you very much uh dr
do you have anything to add at this
point mr rice dr rice
all right well you've done it in five
minutes so i must commend you as well
for that expeditious handling now
i that doesn't mean uh
dr marcus that you have to have a
problem that you take 10 minutes if you
want but you're next up and
the floor is yours and you're recognized
for what time up to 10 minutes you may
consume
you need to turn the mic on mr chairman
it is okay good
mr chairman members of the committee i
am
very honored to be here to present
a talk
i'm a senior science advisor at u.s epa
i'm in the office of
actually the office of drinking water i
usually confine my studies to compounds
that
may get into drinking water and cause
problems in public water supplies
i was asked to look into cs gas
and
i did my usual
analysis
because at epa i've been there for about
21 years
and my job has been over that time
to look at all the information i could
gather
about a particular chemical
whether it be animal
or human data
analyze the data and determine what the
effects are on people
try to
elicit which particular subgroup is most
susceptible
and then based on all these
considerations
determine at what level no effect would
be found
in the most susceptible subgroup
uh as a government toxicologist i have a
no particular axe to grind i'm not a
republican or a democrat
i'm just
a government employee
there have been some interesting
speculations about the flammability of
methylene chloride
the mercant
the merg index lists
methylene chloride as non-flammable
now you can get methylene chloride to
burn
if the concentration in air
is exceeds 12 percent
but when you exceed 12 percent in air
you have a sufficient amount of material
to cause respiratory depression and
death
methylene chloride is toxic on its own
it has the following characteristics
of all
organic solvents
it causes central nervous depression
causes dizziness at high doses
it causes some nausea it causes
confusion
and it can cause
people to become disoriented
cs gas is a very interesting
proposition
i was trying to determine as
our distinguished colleague from england
at what concentration would there be a
problem with people
and it came to my notice that cs
is approximately three times heavier
than air
the way it works and i think it was so
elegantly
explained
is that it's really a very fine powder
that forms a suspension in air
in order for it to get into the lungs of
people it has to have a
diameter no greater than eight microns
and no smaller than two and in the cs1
and cs2 preparation
where the
solid cs is ground to a what they call a
micro fine powder those are precisely
the dimensions of the particles
when it's dissolved in methylene
chloride
injected in using a ferret round
the
material
is burst into the air with some heat
methylene chloride
leaves it and you get this fine powder
the problem that i faced in trying to
determine the concentration was
it tends to fall down
and the closer to the floor you get the
higher the concentration is going to be
and
the irony of that struck me is that the
children are the shortest the smallest
and the most susceptible
and they would get the highest
concentration
children
are physiologically
different than adults they have a
greater surface area in their lung
then do adults
their respiration
rate is
can be 40 times a minute an adult is
about 15 times a minute
the very very young children
given exactly the same concentration not
the elevated one we know they must have
received
would have taken in approximately eight
to twenty times as much material
simply because they breathe faster they
have higher
surface area of their lungs
and they absorb it across their lungs
at a higher rate
so the problem with children as i see it
is that not only are they smaller
but given the same
exposures adults they get a tremendously
increased amount
and if we were to use the figures of our
colleagues from
england in which he said that the
they were 10 to 12 times less material
available that would cause any harm
that would be sufficient to really make
a problem with children
because they would have absorbed at
least that much greater amount of
material
this is the same sort of analysis that's
done
when children
are going to be exposed to materials
from drinking water
and it's
an accepted methodology it's been
published in drinking water and health
and it's been approved
by the national academy of sciences
so we're not talking about some unusual
off-the-cuff analysis
so i'm very disturbed at the idea
that even with a uh
even with the analysis that shows that
it's 10 to 12 12 times less for an adult
it's the same
for children it is not
i would like you to keep that in mind
children are different
secondly
the skin of children is thinner
the vessels that the skin are
much closer
and
the material we're talking about
attacks that
now doctor
in the beginning
we had an explanation of what the
chemical
structure
of
cs gas is
and it's a melonite trial
but actually
since i don't expect any of the members
of the committee are chemists and know
what i'm an
eye trial is a nitrile is cyanide
and this material has two cyanide
radicals on it
when it enters the body
the body can metabolize rather easily
one of those radicals and free it as a
cyanide
the material
that they were exposed to
methylene chloride produces
at normal
metabolism
carbon monoxide it doubles sometimes
triples the amount in the blood
the irony of this is that children who
have fetal hemoglobin
have a greater affinity
for the carboxyl hemoglobin
and therefore the ability of their blood
to carry oxygen is reduced
the fact that cyanide works on every
cell in the body reducing its ability to
utilize oxygen
makes the effect worse and in some of
the papers that have been
written that is the mechanism mechanism
of action
uh
in fact one nobel prize winner dr
hayman's in the 18
talked about nitriles as that's the
mechanism of action the production of
the cyanide radical of metabolism
they had the honor of working with his
son who also received the nobel prize in
medicine
so i determined that the
most susceptible subgroup was in fact
the children
now i brought with me
a respirator
this is not a gas mask this is what's
used
by people who spray
pesticides or who are exposed to
chemicals that shouldn't be
uh intrigued in that's what it looks
like
one puts on these two openings
a uh cartridge
and i just brought it along because i
wanted
the committee to have the opportunity to
find out how difficult it is to operate
this
and a gas mask is worse
you must push the material out here and
you breathe it in through these valves
i'm a
very vigorous adult a child would have a
tremendous problem with this and i
invite any member of the committee to
just try it
and see for themselves
what i'm talking about
i'd like to thank
the
national national library of medicine's
specialized information services group
for providing me with support so that i
could
get a hold of and and present to the
committee
many of the papers that are available
in the published literature
they were very helpful
and they provide this service to many
many scientists
and physicians looking for information
i'd also like to thank the committee for
the opportunity
of talking about
the problems
of the exposure
of toxic chemicals and children
and the problems that were faced by
our brave
people at waco
thank you
thank you very much uh dr marcus uh
without objection the statements of all
of the panelists on this panel will be
admitted to the record
as well as uh the accompanying
documentation that you may have with you
and the tape i think that dr ewling has
is offering into the record
we are now ready to proceed with the
questions of the panel uh i will yield
first to mr schiff for five minutes
thank you very much
mr chairman uh
just before asking questions i'd like to
make a brief observation and that is
we are now at the point where we are
we've already discussed a great length
and we'll probably discuss again i
assume
the decision of the federal bureau of
investigation to try to end the siege
and we've had a great debate over
whether whether they should have waited
longer and could have waited longer or
not
this is now a more focused issue on once
the fbi had made the decision to try to
end the siege whether one agrees with
that or not
was the use of cs gas in this plan
appropriate or was it dangerous
and therefore we're focusing on a
technical issue and i just want to say
that i've received a great deal of
information
about cs gas from all different sources
and
i have to say mr chairman as a former
prosecutor
as a member of congress
i'm accustomed to witnesses having
different recollections of memory of
fact and i'm accustomed to
witnesses having differences of opinion
and judgment i had this image that the
scientific community at least would all
be in agreement we could all at least
get past this issue one way or the other
very rapidly and it appears not to be
the case as we've seen from the panel
here
and so with that in mind i trust that
perhaps when this panel is over
we'll have a have a more of a background
as to why there are the differences uh
in the scientific opinion of whether cs
gas was appropriate or not
with that mr dr eulig if i may turn to
you sir
you have a military background as well
as being a chemist is that right that's
correct sir and uh
did your military background involve
chemistry also
it did in fact in 1982
i spent about four and a half months
putting together a document regarding
chemical warfare agents for the air
force
for the air force right aeronautical
laboratories in dayton ohio
um
let me let me come right to the point
the uh
the
dr upshaw testified that in his judgment
uh there was no
toxicity problem with respect to the use
of cs gas in the compound
and i believe that you said
that you believe some of the people in
the compound in the vault were
asphyxiated
as a result of the use of the gas did i
understand you correctly
you did congressman i would
submit that
the use of carbon dioxide methylene
chloride these agents would have sunk to
the bottom of the building
where the vault was used to
protect children in particular
and these are these are suffocating
agents in and of themselves
i wonder if you'd ex expand on that are
you saying that the cs get the cs gat
the cs gas is actually a powder to be
detected is that right that's correct
are you saying
that this is a suffocating agent by
itself are you saying that things
produced with it or accompanying it are
suffering no i'm saying the material
used to dispense it
in this particular case it was dissolved
in methylene chloride
the methylene chloride is an agent that
does suffocate
uh not only methylene chloride but
carbon dioxide
and so far in testimony today i have not
heard anyone be concerned
about the use of carbon dioxide and
methylene chloride all the methylene
chloride would have been a vapor
all right now the methylene chloride and
the carbon dioxide is that was that
accompanied with the cs gas in both ways
it was delivered
congressman as far as i can determine if
you look only at ferret rounds
and the
model 5 espress system those two were
specifically mentioned and they in do
indeed do use methylene chloride
as injection devices
uh if there was if there was carbon
dioxide used it would have been with the
mark v
fogger unit that's a u.s unit maybe we
should take a moment and and let me ask
you please how is it how do you
understand the gas was was inserted into
the compound how did the fbi go about
doing that
congressman i got so many doggone ideas
on that in my investigations
the official version that i have
is they used
a
model 5
israeli design system
to inject
the cs methylene chloride mixture
ferret rounds in and of themselves
contain
10 percent
cs in methylene chloride
if the calculations are correct the
mixture in the
model 5 ejector bottles
could i interrupt you at this point is
there a difference between model 5
injector bottles and fair grounds
there is would you please explain and
both were used in this both both were
used in this situation that's correct
congress how are they different could
you explain a ferret to ferret round is
about 40 millimeters in diameter
typically 37 to 40 millimeters
uh you use a launcher these were
fired by bradley
uh combat vehicles
that's a typical ferret round the the m5
or the model 5 ejector bottle
basically contains
roughly 30 grams of cs dissolved in
almost
1100 grams of methylene chloride
and 700 grams of a carbon dioxide
propellant to expel it
i have to interrupt because my time has
also run out i believe i will have more
time in a little bit but the the bottles
were inserted by the tank moving right
up and putting the barrel into the
building is that right that's correct
sir
and i just want to ask to make sure i
understood correctly
it's your opinion that the gas or the
substances with it may have directly
caused the suffocation of people in the
compound
the
methylene chloride and the ejectant
carbon dioxide could have done that in
my opinion
how how certain do you feel that it did
oh dear
with the children
i think there's a good chance
and dealing in probabilities probably
sixty percent or point six
point seven
thank you very much my time has expired
thank you mr schiff mr scott you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
mr parks the cs gas is subject to
some discussions about treaties can you
tell us
some background of
where the cs gas
is affected by various treaties
on military use and what effect that has
on civilian use of cs gas
yes sir
first i submit a written statement and i
appreciate the comments of the chairman
that will be incorporated into the
record so i'll not go through the entire
long answer for you
let me make several critical points here
first the united states does not
consider riot control agents and i
include cs in that to be a chemical
weapon
second could you say that again
the united states does not consider ride
control agents and i include cs in that
to be a chemical weapon
second the 1993 chemical weapons
convention does not apply to law
enforcement at all
third the chemical weapons convention is
not yet in force
and fourth the united states is not a
party to it
the riot control agent says the previous
panelists have
described were developed in 1928
as we were developing our chemical
weapon deterrent capability
at the time that they were being
developed and subsequently however
there was a concern
that the use of a riot control agent on
the battlefield
might be misperceived by an opponent as
use of a lethal chemical weapon
resulting in an escalation in the
chemical weapons environment on the
battlefield
hence restrictions have been placed on
their use on the battlefield
so that the
opposing force would not respond in kind
however riot control agencies you mean
not you know mean and khan you mean they
might just
by a more serious lethal type chemical
weapon
however riot control agents as the
previous panelists have indicated have
been widely used in law enforcement and
it was not the intent
in any of the treaties related to the
use of chemical weapons on the
battlefield
to restrict the use of cs or other riot
control agents in domestic situations
so in this case it was not a violation
of any treaty and whatever treaties
there may be
the danger of cs gas was not the reason
for it being a violation of the treaties
that other countries
are parties to well the particular
treaty where i think everyone is to
which everyone is referred is this 1993
chemical weapons treaty and it is not
yet in force
there would have been no violation of
that treaty in the use of cs in a
domestic law enforcement situation
thank you i'm not sure who this question
ought to be aimed at but um
we focused all of our attention on cs
gas
if we were going to use
a
tear gas or use that term generically
what other kind of gases should have
been considered
would have been considered and can you
state the relative
danger
to um
relative danger of the other
alternatives to determine where cs gas
would have fallen into that mix mr
upshaw yes sir
the two commonly used tear gases they
both are aerosols or smokes uh cn
chlorocetophenone and cs the gas with
the the smoke we're talking about
cn was used in the first world war and
was by and large the tear gas that
preceded cs
it is about five times more toxic
and has generally been superseded by cs
in most police law enforcement agencies
throughout the world for that very
reason it's still available i believe in
some police forces
did anybody else want to comment on that
is it fair to say that of all the gases
that could have been selected cs was the
safest
least lethal
and most appropriate unquestionably yes
does anybody disagree with that
i have to disagree in the sense that i'm
not sure you want to select a guest to
do that but if you were going to select
a gas
cs would be the preferred choice well cs
you have to remember ycs
got developed the british were having a
lot of trouble in cyprus with riots
and the cn that they were using
didn't control the riots very well so
they attempted
they use a cn gas
they tried to control the riots with cs
and they managed to do it much uh more
effectively so it turns out to be a very
effective riot control agent
which means it gives a
much better
response
at a lower concentration and therefore i
i think the british felt
that it was less toxic well did
mr upshaw you you just said that it was
not
as lethal as
cn
let's clarify that
cs was developed because it was safer
it is more irritant therefore the margin
between the effective dose and the toxic
dose is considerably wider than that of
cn and that's why cn has been superseded
by cs
the safety margin for that compound is
considerably greater
thank you
how should it be administered and what
kind of considerations should you take
into
what sort of factors should you take
into consideration like the wind
and
other factors that may have been um on
site
perception
it it depends on what
situation you're considering but if
you're considering
riding crowds in the open air for
example you would be considering the
wind because you would want to know
which way the wind was blowing and at
what speed it was blowing obviously or
you might miss the the target that you
were aiming for
and in closed areas you're considering
the concentration that you might achieve
in that enclosed area so you have to
consider the massive material that you
wish to insert
uh let me ask you and my time is almost
up what kind of
pred how well can you predict the
reaction that people will have if
they're subjected to this gas
there was a fairly
exp
tense situation
exp
tense situation and with the people
coming in and shots being fired and with
the kind of person we had in david
koresh
how accurately would should we be able
to predict
the reaction of the
of the people in the compound whoever
wants to answer exceptional mr rice
i i think it's true to say that
above a certain concentration in the air
the signs and the symptoms that people
excuse me
develop in response to the exposure
above a certain point
are
not exceeded in other words once you get
above a certain concentration the signs
and symptoms don't get any
more severe
that concentration we we believe from
from studies we've done is around 10
milligrams per cubic meter that is the
concentration if you remember that will
deter
uh trained military troops
above that concentration
the symptoms persist but they don't get
any more severe
we can't deny that those symptoms are
nasty they're horrible they're not very
pleasant but the whole
reason for using an agent such as a tear
gas is to induce these symptoms the
point being above a certain
concentration they don't get any more
severe in proportion to the increase in
the concentration
did mr upshur want to answer the
question
no i i agree with what dr rice has said
we're talking we're talking about the
irritation produced
thank you very much mr scott your time
has expired mr shabbat you're recognized
for five minutes thank you i'll yield my
time to the gentleman from new mexico mr
schiff
thank gentlemen for healing
dr euleg i would like to return to you
please
as i indicated before i have been told
everything from that cs gas is the
mildest form of substance that could be
used if one is going to use a substance
in this situation
to the to the opposite that it could
have potentially lethal effects at least
with the
gases that might be included with it and
i want to come back to your testimony
about asphyxiation
i'm told that or possibly a six a sixty
percent chance of asphyxiation which is
what i believe you said
i'm told that in the studies that have
been done on cs gas
that there is no documentation of any
lasting injury from the use of that gas
even if its effects could be temporarily
unpleasant could you respond to that
please i'd be pleased through
congressman amnesty in an international
report
indicated that the excessive use of cs
in the
occupied territories by the israelis
resulted in deaths
both of children and aged people
my colleague here from the united
kingdom has another document before him
that i was able to get a hold of as well
that documented some canadian studies
that were made during the vietnam war
that indicated again
that there were deaths attributed to cs
in very high
concentrations
albeit in this particular document that
the canadians have furnished and that my
compatriot has here
those particular devices were
pyrotechnic
dispensers
where the heat
of a charge dispenses the cs methylene
chloride mixture or the cs
gas is a powdery charge
i might also add congressmen that if we
wanted to clean out this room
it would take about the weight of two
quarters
to completely
incapacitate us at about
10 15 milligrams per cubic meter
so it's not it's not much of an agent at
all to chase you out
mr chairman i'd like to reserve the
balance of my time at this time
i yield into mr heinemann what time i
have left you have left
all of my time to the gentleman from new
mexico mr chef
i i thank the gentleman for healing i'm
sorry for that dr euleg we have certain
procedures to follow in control of time
back to you sir let me just ask you uh
maybe i i didn't mean did you complete
your statement uh
about the reports i did sir
let me ask you this question as as
you've just heard and as you know
the british government has used uh i
believe has used cs gas extensively in
various situations do you have any
knowledge of of reports from the british
use of cs gas that you could refer to
the only report that i found uh and had
access to was the one that is laying on
the table right here from her majesty
stationary office
and if i could borrow that please
this is a report of the inquiry into
medical and toxicological aspects of cs
and in that particular document
oh let's see it's
i think you can go through it it's
around page 20 or so the deaths they
talk about deaths in vietnam
through the use of these agents
now the interesting observation out of
this document basically is
that you'd have to fire 40 to 50 of the
pyrotechnic
flight flight right devices
into a room and correct me if i'm wrong
10 by 10 by 8 roughly
in order to cause death is there a name
is there a name to this report that
you're referring to if you yes i said
sir i just gave it to you would you say
it again please let me borrow
or drop shall we if i might add it's
commonly called the hemsworth report
thank you very much go ahead dr you look
please okay
it said that the use of 40 to 50
projectiles in a room
was clearly outside the realm of
possibility
and yet at waco
400 or so approximately 400
of a non-pyrotechnic realm but having
about the same volume of agent were
fired into that complex
that to me
would suggest
that it was excessive
now
are you aware if any autopsies were
conducted on on the people who died in
the compound and whether they
confirm asphyxiation and if and if they
do is there any way to confirm what the
source of this
asphyxiation was given the fact that
there was a fire in other circumstances
there
i don't know that you can confirm what
is after the fire situation that you can
confirm
how much of the deaths or how many of
the deaths were attributed say to
cyanide generated by the decomposition
of
cs
cs in my opinion decomposes to give
ethylene ethylene when it's ingested in
the body would more than likely be
converted to ethanol
the carbon monoxide concentrations in
there
typically in a fire situation you have
large quantities of carbon monoxide
generated
be very very difficult to ascertain how
much
hydrogen cyanide in the autopsies was
due to cs
and how much it was just due to normal
decomposition of materials within the
structure
a great deal of emphasis has been placed
on the fact that there were hot
relatively high winds blowing in the
area of the compound and the day that
the cs gas was used and i and and i
believe stated or at least implied that
the windows if it had been broken out so
that there was a lot of a lot of air
going through the buildings at that time
wouldn't that have dissipated the
the gas whichever gas we're talking
about with the cs powder or the
methylene chloride or the carbon dioxide
enough to
reduce them certainly to below lethal
levels
that might be the case i
i didn't calculate 110 milligrams per
cubic meter congressman i calculated
more on the order of about
40 to
50
milligrams per cubic meter
of cs gas in the facility
and that was a little bit lower than my
colleague from the united kingdom uh
calculated that was the back of the
envelope calculation i think we're both
hunting
in here to me that's
anywhere from two to five times more cs
and you need to incapacitate a person
even with the winds do you know what the
uh so so even with the winds there in
your judgment you're saying there's an
excessive amount of cs gas in my opinion
it would be as a as an observer from the
outside
in in the vault which is where you
testified to or that were the bodies of
people who if they died in this way most
likely did do you know what the
ventilation and the vault was my
understanding is it was windowless there
wasn't any ventilation in there so every
room in the compound didn't have a
window
as far as you know as far as i know
that's correct congressman
okay
um
what information did you receive do you
ever receive any official information in
looking at this as to
how much gas cs gas was actually used
congressman i tried hard to find that
and i ran up against a brick wall quite
frankly
people were very reluctant in the part
of the government to give me any
information and i understand that with
many many people calling in and i'm sure
they would say gee whiz who is this
fellow from a rural community in utah
who wants to know
and get a firm fix on what we've done
and i'm and i'm sorry congressman i
didn't get that the information
some of it came second hand as to how
much had been injected
my time has expired again thank you mr
chairman miss jackson lee you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you very much mr chairman and
thank you gentlemen i
say this as we proceed with these
hearings that we're really trying to get
uh to the solution and acknowledge the
great tragedy that was experienced and
we hope that you gentlemen may be able
to
cast a lot of light
on either what happened or how we can
avoid it perspectively
i think one of the points that was made
in reference to a study that might give
us some pause dr upshaw and dr rice for
concern
i would be the amnesty in a national
study and i'd like for you to
expand on that as it relates to cs gas
is that a document that we can rely upon
and what do you think of it is it
reliable as to this particular gas
and i might add let me be corrected i
noticed that dr upshaw said it was like
a smoke or a fog so in actuality not so
and i have another question but i do
want you to take the time that you need
it's a very important point for me
uh can i go right here
we've looked at that amnesty
international report and it contains
testimony um to several cases in which
people were exposed to tear gas and
that's all the report says tear gas it
doesn't specify which particular tear
gas
the problem we had with that particular
report particularly when you read on to
the end of the report
where it says that the israelis
access to both cn and cs tear gases say
that again c
s and c n in like a nancy yes all right
tear gases is that
those people could have been exposed to
either one
or both
now from what we've already said we
clearly know that cn
is far more toxic than cs that's the
first point
looking at the actual medical
documentation of those cases that were
exposed
there is
reasonable doubt as to what the cause of
death of those people
were
mentioned in that amnesty report i think
it's not beyond reasonable doubt to
suggest that a lot of those people died
of cardiovascular disease
okay
may be induced by the stress of trying
to get away from the gas cloud that they
were exposed to but i see nothing in
that report whatsoever
that links unequivocally
the exposure of those people to cs
was the study done by chemists and
physicians uh this amnesty international
did they uh retain uh
scientists to do this analysis
to your knowledge i'm not sure of their
expertise
not to my knowledge but i mean i haven't
really gone into that report that deeply
um
whether any analysis was done the report
on first reading to me appears to be a
fairly anecdotal one where these cases
were were accounted in a fairly
historical way and i saw no evidence of
any deep scientific investigation of
those cases
and i'll let you answer in a moment uh
dr stone is that dr stone but let me say
since uh we are all fairly here looking
for solutions
uh we might then cast great doubt on
relying upon that document if we're
trying to solve and or prevent
a future tragedy in terms of the
reliance of what
it says about cs
what said in that report and what said
in a lot of these reports that that
account
human exposures to to tear gases
particularly is that it's very difficult
from the all those reports and and the
international report is just one of them
what the exposure to the gas is in terms
of concentration and time
and those two parameters are in
essentially very important to be able to
gauge whether the exposure has been a
near lethal level to the gas or not
and we don't have that information from
the amnesty international reports
let me
pursue just a moment with dr upshaw to
ask him
in his analysis and in his report
you made the point that or at least it
appeared to me
that individuals would not be
immobilized there might be the tearing
that comes from a soap in the eye and
certainly some other physical
ramifications i want you in your answer
to include the impact on children i'm
now at a point now where there are
large gaping holes inside the building
hopefully debris is not in the way and
an opportunity for individuals to escape
however there is this smoke and this fog
can they get out are they still mobile i
read something here that said they might
even be able to do math problems i'm not
sure which document i was reading that
so they might have some certain mental
capacities but share with me whether or
not if you were seeking to get out if
there was gaping holes and sunlight
coming through
could you get out with the gas
smoke smog around you
yes i share with you the thought that i
couldn't do mathematical problems if i
was exposed to cs my main objective
would be to get out of the environment
as quickly as possible that would be my
chief concern um
there is no
evidence documentary evidence and that
is also true within the hemsworth report
that children are more susceptible than
adults to the sense the sensation of the
irritation to say yes the evidence would
suggest that most human beings are
equally sensitive regardless of their
age
cs is uh in in a military context termed
a physical incapacitant as distinct from
what i would call a central incapacity
in other words in other words it has no
effect whatsoever on your cognitive
functions
it only has an effect on on your your
the sensation of pain it's a peripheral
sensory irritant it irritates the mucous
membranes in that sense
there is a
tight blinking of the eyes because of
the irritation to the eyes but in my
experience and i have been exposed to cs
many times the urge to get out of that
environment allows you to peak and move
and you know how to get out certainly
and there's no physical impairment of
your ability to
to leave that environment
uh you are a independently associated
with a facility in england is that my
understanding
i'm a government employee in in the
chemical and defense biological defense
establishment which is now part of one
of the minister defense's defense
research agencies you have no actual
link to the department of justice or
you're not an employee of the department
of justice none whatsoever and as i
conclude my understanding your voice is
kind of soft you're suggesting to
me in the answer that i asked for or the
question that i asked that there was no
impairment to the mobility of an adult
or a child
if there were
opportunities to escape again
neither one of us being present but if
there was a door open a window open or a
gaping hole
that was
going out to an outside area
with that cs inside people would still
as i understand it and children be able
to move in the direction of getting out
correct thank you very much thank you
miss jackson lee uh mr sauder you're now
recognized for five minutes
i wanted to ask dr upshaw and dr rice um
have you always been government
employees have you ever done any work on
behalf of the gas manufacturers or any
representatives of the gas companies no
none whatsoever okay thank you i yield
the rest of my time to mr blue
thank you very much i thank my colleague
for yielding and i want to thank all of
the panel for their testimony i'd like
to focus my attention uh now to dr stone
and welcome him as a fellow
massachusetts resident
you're a distinguished member of the
harvard university faculty in in both
psychiatry and law is that correct
yes
my thought when i read that was that
that combination of disciplines is
probably perfect for trying to
understand this waco tragedy but having
said that i know you also did a report
on behalf of the department of justice
is that right on the waco incident
right right i did and i was very
critical of the use of cs gas
in the presence of children i understand
but before we talk about that you also
were critical of the government in
general i want to touch on some of those
issues and move to the cs gas you you
wrote the new york times
that you found the government's
investigation seriously deficient now
does that mean that you read the
treasury report and and you found that
deficient
and i found both reports what if you
could comment where you found them
deficient
well
let me just
we don't have too much time so let me
just
give you the high points um
i think one of the critical issues that
the committee hasn't gotten to
is we had 80
atf agents come to the compound
in cattle cars
we have heard the branch davidians
described as killers in a deadly ambush
now
you might ask mr jamar when he comes
back because he told me this that they
could have easily killed all of those
agents
before they even got out of the cattle
cars with
the kind of weapons they had 50 caliber
whatever right they had enough weapons
to kill all those agents right
now that's the first point the second
point is
only four agents got killed
and they got killed up on the roof
right now i want you to think about that
the whole purpose of this raid
was to get to the armory which was
supposedly locked on the second floor
those poor officers are up on the roof
going in to an armory that is supposedly
locked well as soon as they get shot at
they know that
you know the armory is unlocked
now whoever is responsible for this in
terms of killing agents or whatever the
sheer stupidity of this is unbelievable
i don't think you have focused
adequately on this fact here these
agents came
as soon as they were shot at that meant
there was no longer a locked army now
the second floor they also knew was
where the women and children were
okay so i think the whole presentation
of those issues
was not added i think the reports missed
a lot of the important uh facts in my
view and approaches that might have been
taken you also go on to say that they
never the government never gave us a
candid account of what went wrong that
infers something different what do you
mean by that now the question in my mind
was after reviewing all this stuff and
being briefed by the people in the
justice department and the atf was
why was it necessary to carry out the
search warrant in this way
i i was convinced that they had
reasonable cause to serve the search
warrant i only didn't understand why
they had to do it with 80 armed men
right
now
i accept the fact that koresh was
molesting a sexually abusing young girl
but that still doesn't explain why you
you deal with that situation with 80
armed uh
atf agent so
now the now that i find the atf has been
slippery about that and and
i'd like to know why was it necessary
at times they said that the the atf
would say that these people were
dangerous to their neighbors
i have never seen any evidence that that
is so
all right let me move on if i could
because we do have limited time to the
question of the gas because you've also
been outspoken on on the use of the gas
and in your report you
talk as others have
on this panel talked about what the gas
can do and flame the eyes nose and
throat produce choking
um you write that it is difficult to
believe that the us government would
deliberately plan to expose 25 children
most of them infants and toddlers to cs
gas for 48 hours
uh that statement is very strong i
wonder if you'd elaborate on that well
first of all toddlers and babies cannot
run out of a compound
right because they can't walk themselves
right
so somebody has to take them if the
parents were immobilized by this gas
that the children would be totally
defenseless to even getting out so we
have to remember there were lots of
babies and toddlers who don't have the
ventilatory capacity to use a gas mask
that's the first now the second thing is
i took care of babies who have chemical
pneumonia
it's an incredibly debilitating illness
now
although we've had lots of talks uh
about this we haven't heard how it works
and what i'm concerned about
this is an agent which burns mucous
membrane which inflames and irritates
mucous membrane so after a baby freeze
it into its lungs
just like a sunburn right hours later
then
the lungs will start to have blisters
just like the sunburn comes on your face
and then the fluid
comes into their lungs and they get
pulmonary edema
and i spent many nights trying to keep
babies alive with just this problem okay
so and and the research
that the british have done you will see
that when they keep their animals in
the atmosphere long enough it's not that
they die
immediately it's eight or ten hours
later when they develop pulmonary edema
your final conclusion here because that
we're running out of time is that
although it may have been justified to
use this gas
against adults in a riot or in some
other uh valid law enforcement matter it
is totally inappropriate in any case at
any time to use this gas against
children
i i think yes
thank you mr chairman thank you very
much we have a dilemma but we haven't
had the second bells yet but i think
that it would be prudent
since we now have a series of votes on
the floor they've been holding for us to
take a recess
before we conclude this panel with other
questions we will be in recess the
subcommittee will be then until five
minutes after the conclusion of the
final vote on this series subcommittees
are in recess
this guy says about them suffocating
from you see our turn
the joint house subcommittee hearing on
the waco investigation will continue in
just a moment
first some program information
this weekend we begin our live coverage
of the national governors association
summer meeting in burlington vermont
saturday at 11 a.m eastern time c-span
brings you the opening for final
testimony in the waco hearing witnesses
are epa toxicologist william marcus
harvard university professor alan stone
and hayes parks of the defense
department
the joint subcommittees will come to
order
uh when we recessed it was going to be
mr brewster's turn and i
will yield to mr booster five
thank minutes mr chairman
first off uh
i have to agree with dr stone
that the plan was fatally flawed when uh
the assault started on the compound
uh back february 28th
secondly
i think the execution of the assault on
april 19th was almost equally flawed
as to the context to the way it was
happening and i happen to be one who
believes that had there been a time
frame of of weeks days weeks months
uh allowed to continue that many of
those people would have come out maybe
not koresh but some of the other
but some of the testimony here
concerning the gas
seems contradictory to me
dr euleg you said that uh methylene
chloride was a flammable agent in the cs
gas
uh and best i remember the halogen
family
most of the halides at least are used as
flame retardants in many cases it would
have taken a concentration of very high
amount of concentration of methylene
chloride
for it to be flammable far more than the
number of canisters that were used
no sir the data on this that we ran
would not suggest that
the second thing
a congressman if you get it in a vapor
form it
i think the flammability limits the
lower limit is about 13 percent
so it will uh it will go in the vapor
form none of it was puddled
the second thing i'd like to
also state that when i was a
young first lieutenant
in the military
my secretary was cleaning her typewriter
in those days of course we had
typewriters that hit ribbons and so on
she was using a preparation with
methylene chloride in it from the time
it took me to get from her office to the
men's room and back again she had
literally passed out over her typewriter
we got her out of there and were able to
revive her happily
but the flammability of this stuff it
does burn there's no question about it
now you're right
carbon tetrachloride is also known as
cte in the industry
first used by i believe the german luth
lafa
to put out engine fires
but i'll guarantee you that methyl
chloride methylene chloride and
chloroform
all will burn
bromides fluorides chlorides in general
the halogens are flame retardants as
opposed to flame
there's a different that's a horse of a
different color as soon as you start
looking at bromides and iodides i have a
letter from the industry that says it
would have taken 300 canisters
of cs tear gas
in a room of 840 square feet as opposed
to this building of about 370 000 square
feet to make a flanneable flammable
concentration
dr marcus uh
i find it interesting that you're
testifying
in this and that you're an employee vpa
uh do you also testify
for plaintiffs uh on occasion uh for pay
yes sir
is that common among federal employees
epa employees
other epa employees do do that yes sir
is it common do most epa employees do
that
no not mostly
how do they do that in their work
schedule um
i'm guess i'm curious about that do you
do you have an office in the epa
building here that you work in regularly
i do not but when i was
consulting
i did
as you know federal employees get 210
hours a year annual leave
they
i happen to participate in something
called
flex time and i get one day every two
weeks as a day off
there are also
holidays and the weekends
have you ever ran into a situation that
could be a
problem as far as that testimony is
concerned
going over extra days or
in a case where it could be
indirectly connected with epa or the
government
first
in order to avoid a conflict of interest
i always explain
to the
lawyers that try to hire me
that if the government is a party even
peripherally to the case i cannot
appear
because by definition
i'd be serving two masters and i think
that is a conflict of interest
and a worm for the fact that i'm
appearing here for epa i would consider
this a conflict of interest
and uh you don't have an office at apa
do you work out of your home yes sir
do many epa employees work out of their
home why do you not have an officer
i was one of
several hundred people who were injured
in the epa building because of um
i'm sure you know
toxic carpets that were put down
no sir i don't know i'm new here i've
only been here four years what
what did the epa you mean our
environmental protection agency our
agency put down toxic uh materials in
their own building well actually
i guess that's the correct that's
correct the uh
there were uh
well over 600 people who were made ill
of that about 10 about 60
work either at home or in alternate
spaces and i'm one of those 60. did you
receive any disability out of it or
anything like that i had to go through
the entire
process
that would have awarded this disability
but since i was able to perform my job
at home
they decided to allow me to continue to
work at the capacity as a senior science
advisor okay
and dr euleg is one who has some
background in chemistry pharmacology etc
uh cs gas
is that a does it affect the central
nervous system autonomic nervous system
is it a cns depressant cns stimulant
nerve synapses what is it where does it
affect the body and why is it
inconsistent in the way it affects the
body
oh that's a very interesting question
it does not affect the central nervous
system it does affect the peripheral
nervous system in that
market
go ahead
yeah
in that it attacks the nerve endings and
makes the makes them very sensitive and
as i explained earlier part of the
mechanism is by the production of
cyanide
wouldn't a lot of things produce cyanide
under certain circumstances the burning
of a lot of household materials would
they not also produce cyanide
plastics in particular at high
temperatures some of them
especially those like teflon will
produce cyanide gas that's correct was
there a substantial number of people in
this fire that had cyanide in their in
their bodies upon autopsy
i did not read the autopsy reports but i
am informed
that there were levels of cyanide found
in those
unfortunate people
with whom there was enough
material left to do that sort of
analysis
and as i think thank you i think my time
thank you mr brewster mr klinger i
you have five minutes thank you very
much mr chairman i apologize the panel
for not having been here for all of your
statements and your
uh the questioning period
may be a bit redundant but i think given
the uh the importance of the issue we're
addressing here and that is the
uh the use of this gas uh the quality of
this gas the
the what it does to people or doesn't do
to people i think is extraordinarily
important
so
we had some earlier testimony mr sage
pointed out where gas had been inserted
into that structure
over the period of the raid in about
four or five different places
which would seem to me at least to
suggest that the the levels
of cs gas that were injected at that
time were were
very very high
uh dr marcus can you make any assessment
of as to the amount or the the uh
the degree of uh cs gas that might have
been present
whether the the level was how high the
level would have been
well um
i did submit
some uh a report to the committee and
i'd like to have that
made part of the record
everything you've submitted is made part
of record sir thank you sir i did not
attempt
to determine
um the actual concentrations
because they depend upon two very
difficult
things to evaluate in addition to the
amount and the time
they depend upon the temperature
and the humidity and uh
as i said both methylene chloride and
the uh the powder the very finely
divided powder
tend to
fall concentrate in the lower reaches of
any
place they use if they used out of doors
they would concentrate in the swells and
if they're used indoors they tend to
float down
into the lower reaches of the building
so this what this would suggest is that
the concentration would have been much
higher for those least able to
to absorb that and that would be the
children who would be presumably
very low to the ground in that
building that's correct
uh
i guess i'm not sure this question has
been answered or not uh but
just for my purposes so there's been
some dispute about whether the
flammability of this gas and has anybody
done any testing to determine the degree
of flammability or if in fact it is
flammable
congressman the only thing i have is the
very non-professional
videotape right here
that my research assistant danita
dingman and i did at the college of
eastern utah
and it does burn we
put it on we're initially we're going to
spray it across across the flame front
of a propane torch
but the material came out in a steady
stream to the point where it made that
move
so what we did is we sprayed it on a
piece of cardboard the cardboard being
the supporting agent
then took the cardboard put it into the
propane torch flame as an ignition
source and by the way a zippo lighter
works just as well
and
the material did burn no question about
it when it got too hot for me to hold i
tried to shake it to put it out and you
can see that in the video and through
the piece of material in the back of the
foot
where it continued to burn for a time
when the
cs or whatever whatever the products of
combustion or gasification time of the
cardboard were completely exhausted the
cardboard extinguished itself
from that i believe that it is
thank you for mentioning zippo lighters
are made in my district so i'm
always uh i'd like to answer your
question also yes dr mark i have with me
a um paper written by a
dr danto d-a-n-t-o
in the american journal of forensic
medicine and pathology in 1987
called medical legal challenges and he
entitled his paper medical problems and
criteria
regarding the use of tear gas by police
and as part of his paper he gave three
cases
case two talks about
when police come to remove
an abusive husband
who was intoxicated
and they managed to
extract his wife
even though the
gentleman pointed a rifle at them
less than 24 hours later he had the
police were
recalled because he
the gentleman the husband was yelling
and
brandishing a shotgun at his neighbors
and
a co-worker of the husband
tried to calm him down and
entice him out of the home to get a beer
and when the police cut the
person off who was a co-worker because
he wasn't part of the force
gave the gentleman the five-minute
deadline to come out and when he didn't
they
lobbed tear gas shells into his home
they lobbed 40 of them at the
at the residence some of which bounced
off the walls
and uh
when he finally
became quiet that as the husband
the police went in to remove him the
house was already burning and he had
died from the exposure
in the
second case
let me i've got one more question i want
to get in if i may doctor before uh
before my time is going to expire here
if i might uh and that has to do again
this this there has been conflicting
testimony as to the toxicity
of this gas and i guess this is what you
were leading to as well but mr
janner said absolutely not to
characterize it as a relatively benign
substance and and in no way was a toxic
uh
in your opinion is is cs gas toxic yes
there's no question about it being toxic
to
every paper that i've read that's
independently scientifically produced
calls it toxic the only question is
what's meant by that
and
these materials are very very nasty
that's why they're used
and
here's a paper just off the top of the
stack written by dr beswick in human
toxicology in 83 and he talks about it
he said the
um
the suff before going to the eighth of
the sufferer you have to decontaminate
him his eyes
um
the
intraocular pressure would rise if he
had glaucoma he might go blind
the skin they get erythema and at high
concentrations with more moist
conditions blistering occurs
in the cardiovascular system as a result
of the fright and pain
is an increase in blood pressure and if
he's a cardiac [ __ ] you could cause a
heart attack
the respiratory system recovers quickly
but as dr park explained
prolonged exposure can predispose to
secondary infections
gross exposure uh produces edema and
death due to expixia
and these would be exaggerated people
who have asthma and bronchitis the
treatment uh recommended for these is
unchanged higher talks about the higher
nervous system and how that's affected
so it really is a total
misrepresentation to say that this is
not a it's not a toxic substance and i
guess my time is expired
chairman can heal issues in relation to
that question certainly chairman
i think it's true to say that everything
that we are exposed to is toxic
and nobody would actually argue with
that what's an issue here is at what
level is the substance toxic
just to take an analogy
we would all take aspirin for a headache
but if you took a whole bottle of
aspirin
in that situation they are toxic enough
to kill you
i can't see the argument
whereby we sit here and we say cs is
toxic yes it is toxic
but it's all relative it depends on how
much
causes signs of toxicity
and i think what my last panelist has
just said
gives you a false impression of what we
mean by toxicity depends on dose
thank you very much your time has
expired mr klinger by previous
understanding between both sides of the
aisle i will recognize mr scott on mr
conyers time and then the next round we
will recognize mr schiff in the absence
of mr chabot so
on his time so
mr scott you're recognized for five
minutes to begin with um mr brewster
wanted to clarification i'll yield one
minute to to the gentleman
mr chairman i have a letter here from
the house and aids solvents industry
concerning flammability of methylene
chloride i would certainly like to
submit for the record
okay the second part mr marcus maybe i
misunderstood you a moment ago
uh i thought you said that you worked
for the epa and were here representing
epa apparently immediately after you're
in my discussion epa called very quickly
and said that you were not representing
epa here is that correct
well i'm not representing epa in terms
of policy or anything i say
can be attributed to them but i am here
as an epa employee as opposed to a
private citizen
i'm getting paid on government time and
i'm getting paid by the government to be
here
you're getting paid by epa to be here so
you are representing epa then
well
i can only explain that i you're not on
a daily that's correct
and and they were aware of that and knew
about it
they received that okay so you are here
representing epa then the epa higher-ups
told you to be here
uh when i asked them
whether i should attend and showed them
that i had received the generous
invitation they said by all means
okay we'd like the information who uh
uh approved it and that sort of stuff if
we could because it's our understanding
epa said no
uh the second part was uh
did you say there were 600 of you that
don't work in the building that were had
toxicity to the carpet or something no i
said about 10 of that about 60. about 60
of the 600 employees
and all of you work from your homes no
some of us
work in alternate workspaces
were moved out of headquarters into
places that
were much more tolerable
they're about i think somewhere in the
neighborhood between 15 and 30 people
that work out of their homes and it
varies depending on
whether or not they receive
disability
and you don't receive disability that's
correct but you do contract out your
services on the side in lawsuits and
that kind of stuff i have done that in
the past yes sir and i
would do if i had an opportunity
statement
i'm just now told that we have a fact
statement on epa stationery saying
you're not here representing epa well
that's what i'm saying is i'm here in
epa time as an epa employee but i'm not
anything i say is not policy or
represents their opinions
and your statement is owned epa
letterhead right that's correct
thank you
i'd like to ask dr offshore and dr rice
to just comment briefly on the
flammability issue
whether or not the cs gas is flammable
the issue is whether or not it could
have started basically whether whether
it could have started the fire that's
what we're looking at do you have a
comment to make yes i'm not a
flammability expert
however cs is normally generated outside
the usa by pyrotechnic devices in other
words it's a burning grenade and in that
situation the cs does not ignite
it forms a cloud as a fog
off that device so it does not catch
fire in that device which is actually a
pyrolysis burning device and that's a
normal method of use in a right control
situation
and if it's being dispersed without the
pyrotechnics what happens
when it's ejected from a methylene
chloride solution and i believe from the
ferret ground it contains freon
it the methylene chloride evaporates and
you have a fog of small particles of cs
free of any of the breakdown products
that also are associated with power
attacking devices
and is that what that caused the fire
no that would not cause a fire in fact
it is deliberately chosen i believe in
the usa to replace the pyrotechnic
device
because your buildings
have a very high wooden wood content
they would frame buildings and therefore
in the past the protecting devices they
tended to catch fire
thank you let me get i want to get back
to the impact that the gas has on
on children
we heard speculation and theories about
how it could theoretically affect
children do you have any
studies or evidence to show what actual
impact
cs gas has on children
i think probably what you've been
referring to is a paper by part and
geomona in which they describe
the accidental exposure of a four-month
child
in a building to cs
when that report was written
back in 1972
we believe that that child was exposed
to cs but from a pyrotechnic device
i don't think there's any doubt from
that paper that that child suffered
and as
dr stone has already said
that child developed a chemical
pneumonia of its lung
i think the important features to pull
out of that paper is ultimately that
child survived
we are not sure at this point in time
whether that exposure was purely due to
cs as i say at the time the exposure
occurred it is
very likely that that was a
pyrotechnically driven
cs device
and the importance of that is that from
pyrotechnic devices one would also
have exposure to
a large range of toxic gases that would
also injure the lung
purely from the products of of the
burning part of the munition
so i don't think it's at all clear
certainly to us
that one can ascribe that case
solely to cs
yes it was a nasty case and the child
was admitted to hospital
in a poorly state
important fact is that that child
eventually survived
and certainly there is no evidence of
any long-term effects on that child that
we know it
has widespread use so there are other
cases that we can determine whether or
not it has a disproportionate adverse
effect on children dr offshore i'm i
mentioned that case because that's the
only
real case that we're actually aware of
that is is reasonably well documented
as far as we're concerned the the
evidence for
uh
life-threatening injury to children
specifically
is limited to that case
uh mr mr chairman i think dr was
answering answering the question too
i was just wishing to answer
report which is the most comprehensive
study of cs ever done in response to the
british government inquiry does mention
the case in northern ireland of a child
exposed in one of the buildings
uh 2cs gas
that was used at the time of 1969 the
child suffered the effects was removed
in the room and recovered very rapidly
after being removed which is the normal
response that you see
when a human being leaves such an
environment
thank you mr scott now i recognize mr
schiff under that arrangement for five
minutes
thank you mr chairman
and dr euleg let me say uh
since you did not receive all of the
information about the
actual amount of cs gas used in this
particular situation
if we get you that information would you
be willing to to recalculate your uh
your investigation to this matter to see
if anything changes your conclusions
all right i think that would be fair to
you and to and to the fbi that use the
gas and and to everyone uh that that be
done regardless whether it changes your
conclusion or not okay um
let me ask mr mr marcus i think that you
have clarified that you are an epa
employee but that you are not testifying
on policy matters for epa here today
as an epa employee though i'd like to
ask you this question could you briefly
tell us what your background is uh by
which you you are essentially testifying
as an expert on the use of cs gas and
its effect
in the beginning
as i said i'm a board certified
toxicologist and general toxicology
which which entails a very long and
involved test and a retest every five
years
on the technical knowledge of three
different areas
and
my professional life three different
areas include air
yes my um
i did my original work in both my phd
and masters in inhalation toxicology in
inhalation toxicology that's correct
thank you but i i'd like to give one
quick response there are more uh
materials in literature talking about
children and i have before me an old
report by uh cookson and nottingham
englishman and an english lady
in which they talk about a physician who
treated people who were made ill
that were exposed to cs gas
and
he talks about the mortality rate in
adults is about 10 while the mortality
rate in children is about 90 percent
i have only kept accurate records of the
numbers of such cases that i have seen
since last june since then i have seen
seven cases of which there was one child
of six years of age who died one of
fifteen who survived one lady of forty
who died and four adults who survived
now i don't know
enough about this particular gentleman
to know precisely what happened
but they're talking about children
and being exposed in enclosed areas
bunkers or shelters
i understand
dr dr upshaw and dr rice
uh i i believe the british government
still uh uses cs gas from time to time
is that correct
that's correct for in civil matters as
opposed to yes indeed
um is there any guidelines or policies
under what circumstances cs gas should
be used and what i'm talking about here
is in terms of the environment that is
is there any policy about it being used
outdoors or indoors let me let me just
stop there for a minute
i don't think we have any strict policy
i think probably what you're getting at
is
as to the question as to whether cs
should actually be used indoors
most of the cs that's been used on
mainland uk has been of pyrotechnic
devices but we certainly do have access
to other devices
and it would be those that would be used
indoors purely because of the risk of
fire in an enclosed area
we have no policy that that would
prevent the use of cs within enclosed
space i think the important points
to make
with
that in mind is that
it's the concentration that one
developed in an enclosed space
that's certainly very important and one
has to have a view to that
and also the time that anybody in that
enclosed space might be exposed to that
concentration
dr dr stone did you want to respond on
the question of the use of cs gas either
indoors versus outdoors
i think
i don't see microphones
i i think uh the analogy to one aspirin
today
is a little misleading because as the
point just made is the problem is
duration right
now i want to emphasize to you the plan
here was to expose people
for 48 hours okay now if you look at the
research done by the hemsworth people in
the report names with report you'll see
that
even at relatively lower moderate doses
after 40 minutes or an hour the animals
will start to die subsequently
of the same illness i've been talking
about namely a chemical pneumonia right
so uh if you keep the animal in the
atmosphere for long enough it's going to
have that reaction it's not just the
dose it's how long they're exposed now
children
with duration yeah exactly okay so as
long as the child is breathing that it's
burning its lungs mr and that that that
result will be eventually
to have fluid in the lungs
dr stone let me ask you this question i
think it's the obvious question
this gas at
at best is unpleasant that's its purpose
yes and yet very few people came out of
the compound
uh after the gas attack began do you
have a conclusion as to why that was the
case
i'm sorry trouble with that i think
maybe party because mr shift so far over
there okay i'm sorry
um
i i think uh if you
uh as you may know i was on the attorney
general's panel to look into what
happened and and as you go through the
the material i i think
that the adults had gas masks
right so so the adults put on their gas
masks as a way of dealing with when i
spoke to mr jamar at the time the real
question has always been the children
did the children have gas masks how were
they going to be protected if they
didn't have gas masks and how are they
supposed to endure 48 hours of gas okay
so you have a situation where maybe the
adults are protected
but actually the children who are at the
greatest risk are not protected and the
children presumably particularly infants
can't get out by themselves that that is
a point yes
because i didn't think you have the
microphone to you would you mind
repeating again just about dose plus
concentration would you just mention
that again briefly please yes i think
the important thing and i think that you
would agree with me that you if you keep
the animals which the research has done
on animals
in the atmosphere that contains it long
enough
they all will develop pulmonary edema
and die right
so it's not just how much it's how long
and that's what this calculation that
was being described to us earlier
and pulmonary edema is wet please
basically what happens is the the this
uh substance is designed to inflame its
purpose is to inflame tissue right so
when you get it in your lungs it inflam
your lungs are all this tissue right so
it inflames it and then fluid moves
across it's just like getting a blister
where you got fluid
so the fluid goes into your lungs and
you develop pneumonia chemical pneumonia
and and then you can
this child that went into the hospital
was in intensive care
and was in hospital for 28 days
with positive pulmonary pressure and
everything to keep it alive now if all
those babies had come out
uh where was the equipment
to put them all in intensive care
right
so i i i you know there are real
questions i have about the children and
their exposure
i'm inspired thank you mr chairman mr
taylor you're recognized for five
minutes
dr stone on notice in your opening
statement you use the words a careful
reading of the atf before it indicates
so that lead me to believe you read it
carefully
that mr dr stone you in your opening
statement use the words a careful
reading of the published atf report
indicates
is that to lead me to believe that you
read it carefully
yes okay
in your statement you took issue with
the
characterization of the shootout at waco
as an ambush in part because i'm using
your words
only four agents got killed
how many law enforcement officers in
your expert medical opinion
would have had to be killed that day to
establish that there was an ambush
would 10 have been enough to satisfy
your professional opinion with 20 how
about all of them
dr stone i can't believe you said that
would you walk out of the hospital today
and say we only lost four patients so we
shouldn't
well i please sir i do
the man
what
where's
you know you go on to say that you cited
evidence that there was no ambush
because the fact that the davidians
didn't open fire as the agents still
allow the driveway
isn't it possible that the agents that
the davidians chose to hold their fire
until the guys were out in the open
where they had no place to go
i am truly appalled at so many things
you said you said it was a bot straight
and you made them statement that four
agents died on the roof again you said
you read the report carefully report
clearly says that two of the agents were
killed on the ground yes i understand
that
dr stone what's your point
are you on the side of the anarchist
i i truly cannot believe that a man of
medicine is gonna say only four agents
got killed they had children
one of them volunteered for desert storm
they left widows behind
they were serving a legal warrant
have you listened to the testimony no
one's
a legal warrant
they said they were fired at first a
former green beret from vietnam said he
had never been ambushed that badly and
the whole time in vietnam had never been
that outgoing
cheese on pizza
i i will not question your capability
but i will say i'm glad you're in
massachusetts and i'm in mississippi
and my family in particular is 1200
miles at least from your from your
hospital
well you're entitled and asked this
panel the same question i've asked
everybody
you're entitled to your opinion sir i i
disagree with everything you said no
sorry i'm quoting you please tell me
how what did you mean the ten agents had
to be killed that all the agents had to
be killed
sure mr uh dr stone you may respond
the the important issue and the reason
this was an issue for me uh congressman
was to get some idea of what kind of
people we were dealing with at waco
that was a very important thing because
the whole
task
i was charged with by the justice
department
was how do you deal with unconventional
groups
right
they considered this an unconventional
group
not just a group of criminals
so
one of the things we had to consider was
how they behave in relationship to this
raid right
now
it was explained to me and i will repeat
to you
what agent jamar said and you can ask
him
he said that in the tactical advantage
the branch davidians had
they could have killed many more agents
than they did
if they were determined just to kill
people
now i'm repeating what jamar told me
which was part of my inquiry
during the time i wrote my report
if you doubt it
ask jamar
you're claiming my time since there
isn't a great deal of time left i would
like to make two observations
the two gentlemen who said that the
doses of gas were non-lethal
in the amount that they were given
happen to say in their own testimony
that they are experts from the british
army that's what they do best
i'd also like to make note that the
opening statement of mr
euleg
in paragraph one he goes on to say that
he is not an expert per se in the use of
chemical warfare
i'm making note of all of that sir
i also want to now ask this panel same
question i've asked every panel because
i'm really curious to see what dr
stone's going to say
has anything that you've seen or heard
or read
justify the murder of four atf agents by
david koresh and his followers and dr
stone
i'm not a doctor but it was murder
well
what is the question you want me to
answer is anything that you have seen or
heard or read
justify the murder of those four atf
agents in the wounding of 20 more
by david correction as followers
no i don't think that killing people
in that situation is justified but i
think that's totally to
mislead yourself and the american people
above what the critical issues are
mr marcus
anytime
gentlemen
as brave as these atf officers in the
field prove themselves to be die it's a
tragedy and there's never an excuse for
that never
lies
i can see no justification at all
i would agree with that there's no
justification whatsoever
no there's nothing that justifies that
congressman i think that's a very
difficult issue this committee is
wrestling with and i think that's the
decision you have to reach
rather than me well no sir i'm going to
turn that around i'm asking for your
opinion you've been called to testify
uh i don't recall inviting you so and i
don't know who invited you but you've
had an opportunity to review the
testimony
and i'm asking your opinion no sir i
have not had an opportunity to review
the testimony i believe congresswoman
that the congressman is a former
prosecutor
no sir i'm a former corrugated box
salesman all right i take great pride
i apologize if you can't answer a former
corrugated box salesman's question sir
and i'm saying as a former prosecutor
that a case of murder could be brought
i'm not sure based on the facts i have
heard and i've not heard all the facts
in this hearing that that case could be
proved in a court of law
thank you very much
thank you very much mr taylor mr barr
you're recognized for five minutes thank
you
uh
mr could you very briefly describe a
ferret round
the third rounds that i've seen pictures
of congressman
and it's only been a picture
okay
is a device that's about uh when you
take a look between 37 and 40
millimeters in diameter i've only seen a
picture of it all right
ferret round apparently has a
is propelled out of a launcher as best i
can determine
okay
and it's a fairly lethal device
i looked at looked at the manufacturer's
literature
apparently you'll go through three
quarters inch of plywood at 75 ft plate
glass at 200 feet
the cs is released at impact
with a solid material and the cs is
dispensed in a vapor
micro particle aerosol
dr
upshaw indicated that there was a freon
charge in there as well to dispense the
the cs
thank you
because i understand dr stone and i
think mr marcus you also testified and
perhaps uh dr eulig
would inflammation in the throat and
lungs be consistent with a child being
exposed to a cs
yes sir i'd like to like to expand on
about that a little bit well
in just a moment uh uh that was just my
question we've heard a great deal and i
don't know whether you all have followed
these about a young lady named kerry
jewell
she came in here i think was on the
first day of testimony in a
very nice clean very pretty dress
her hair was perfect
her dad was dressed impeccably and was
next to her and provided tremendous
support to her
and as i sit here and sat there i have
no reason to doubt
that what she went through according to
her testimony was very traumatic
and we all sympathize very much with her
but i have a picture here of another
young girl
nameless
burned so badly
we don't even know her name she's
identified on the medical examiner's
photo here as doe 57.
six to eight-year-old girl
cause of death asphyxia
inflammation and throat and lungs
she's wearing what
probably any six to eight year old girl
would wear
some slacks
and some running shoes
and a over shirt all very badly burned
she wasn't able to be here
in a nice new dress and with a parrot
with her
because of what happened on april 19th
of 1993.
i have another
report here
of child doe number 62.
burned so badly
we can't even tell whether it was a boy
or a girl
we do know that
she died or he died of suffocation
we also know
that this little child
maybe a year old
it was planned in a hooded long-sleeve
jacket
a knitted sleeper
a disposable diaper
and a loose knitted shirt
this little baby also was not able to be
here
so that she could be paraded
to show what a horrible person somebody
might be and indeed he was a horrible
person but who's going to speak for the
jane does
and the child though that we don't even
know what sex they were
we have heard today
from you all
about the effects of cs
now the other side can parse words
and talk about
changing a number here or there
but the fact of the matter is what was
injected into that
living quarters into those living
quarters
was a at best a very painful
substance
and it was injected in there knowing
full well that there were dozens of
children in there
we have heard expert testimony
and the other side may parse words about
this as well
that it is entirely possible that some
of the children in there
trying to take refuge
in one of the lowest most secure rooms
in the house may have inadvertently or
their parents inadvertently expose them
to death by asphyxiation
because of the substance that was
injected in there and it wasn't a small
amount of substance
the report of the attorney general
says that after they injected
all of the cs gas that they had they
sent out for more
as far away they queried
every fbi facility in the country from
quantico send us more
and they interjected more in there
according to this report
through every window
in the structure
the other side doesn't have a lot to say
about this yet we keep hearing about
kerry jewell
well mr chairman i think it's time we
heard a little bit about the jane does
and the child does and the baby does and
what happened to them
and i think it is a very legitimate
question to ask in light of all the
information none of which i believe is
secret that we've heard here today
that we certainly should presume
that the fbi knew about and that the
attorney general knew about
the possible effects
of this
on children
and i think it is a very legitimate
question for this panel to ask at least
on this side
that's why was this decision made
so that hopefully it will never be
repeated so we will not have to have
pictures like this
which at this time mr chairman i would
ask unanimous consent to be placed in
the record
and i'm not asking these to be placed in
the record as official autopsy photos
because we don't have the medical
examiner here
but that is what they are purported to
be
in an autopsy report
on child dough
and hopefully we will hear more about
them and not just to carry jewels
because they died as a result of what
happened thank you
mr barr your time mr barr your time has
expired mrs thurman you're recognized
for five minutes
mr chairman thank you and at this time
i'd like to yield my time to the
gentleman from west virginia mr wise who
has been doing some of his own
work on this issue and we thank him for
his time he's spent on this
thank the ranking member
i just want to say in response to the
gentleman from georgia please don't be
mis don't misspeak and think that we
don't have a lot to say about it i do
uh initially what i have to say is that
david koresh was such a coward sir that
he left the he may had those children
stay in that compound when he could have
let them out when he could have let them
know sir my time and that uh so all this
talk about the tragedy that happened
david koresh is responsible for that
child being in that condition uh
that you described so graphically but i
would like to just follow up very
quickly on that dr stone
and my time is brief so i need to ask
you to help me out on that on page 15 of
your report you state there's
unequivocal evidence that the branch
davidians started the fire and ended
their lives on koresh's order
additionally on page 20 of your report
you state that the branch davidians were
willing to die defending themselves in
an apocalyptic ending or kill themselves
and their children yet we've heard
testimony that the fires could have that
the branch davidians
the british davidians die died and were
accidental uh would you comment on the
assertion that the fires were
accidentally set
up
let me say this uh i was told when i uh
became a member of the panel that there
were certain things
that were redacted
would be redacted and there were certain
things that
one couldn't speak about right
now i i i'm sorry who told you that sir
uh the various people at the attorney
general could you just point out i'm
just curious
i'm sorry chairman are we instructing
witnesses from your side not to no no
sir
no no i don't believe so i believe
that's an instruction from the attorney
general's office right he was on their
official review team uh so it was there
now if you tell me that i i don't have
to adhere to that i'll be glad to tell
you in front of the committee i don't
think you have to adhere this is already
published
okay okay well i even though it was
public i take confidentiality very
seriously i was told not to do it if you
tell me i can do it
sir
okay so they told me
that they had listening devices inside
the compound
that they could not uh
develop and enhance that sound
in time to use it
but the night before they heard various
members of the inner circle of the
branch davidian saying that david has
decided that we are to step out onto the
sun
that we are uh it's going to be really
bad
but that's what david has decided and
and
uh i accepted that evidence
uh uh as unequivocal that they intended
to start the fire yes thank you dr rice
uh let's talk some about the gas uh and
i understand you're
certainly an expert in that
i think we need to get back to how much
gas was put into the compound and
whether it was lethal have you had a
chance to review how much was injected
into the compound
we as you know from our opening
statement um
tried to calculate on the information
that we had available to us
um
not what really happened at waco but
as realistic as we could
given the information that we had from
various sources
the outcome of those calculations
that we've made suggest that some 2006
grams of cs were deployed
and a total of 38 540 grams of methylene
chloride
were deployed
we
then went on to work out um given
certain assumptions which we've already
outlaid in our statement as to what the
peak concentrations of cs could be
within the compound
and our figures suggest that the peak
concentration of cs was probably around
100 to 110 milligrams per
meter cubed
we have to say
in addition however that is a peak
concentration
and given the way that some of the cs
was deployed in the building i.e the
advancement of cv vehicles towards the
compound
the
opening of the walls of the compound to
inject the cs
that
in all likelihood the maximum
concentrations actually within the
building would be a lot lower than that
because the ventilation of the buildings
would have been much higher than we
actually assumed in our calculations
did your calculations assume one change
of air uh per hour yes indeed they did
and is that a conservative
measurement
that figure we use because we knew
from
work done for the hemsworth report that
we could actually have we actually had
figures for that rate of change of air
in terms of how the cs cloud would
actually decay in terms of concentration
that's the only reason why we use that
figure do those calculations also factor
in the 35 mile per hour winds
no they didn't and were those winds a
factor in your opinion
most certainly a factor yes in what way
winds of that speed going through a
building and i i believe that the winds
would have actually entered the building
through the large holes in the sides
through which the cs was injected uh
that would just
greatly increase the ventilation of the
building
i'll be back but in my final question i
would ask
then given what you calculated uh
what percentage of that
is is a lethal dose
a lethal amount of cs
my point is i think that what you found
is that there was far less than what
would have been a lethal administration
of gas
sure
the peak concentration um
we're not saying is is low
but certainly if that was breathed for a
period of 10 minutes would be
significantly below
what has been estimated to be a lethal
dose of cs for an exposed population and
that is and that is without factoring in
the 35 mile per hour that's without
factoring in the 35 mile an hour wind
um taking into account the volume of the
holes that were made in the building
certainly yeah dr upshaw were you trying
to add to that in this case i made i
could
um what i would like to add is that we
estimated that someone stayed in that
building for at least six hours they
would still be some ten times below what
would be an estimated lethal dose i'd
like to take the opportunity to correct
a piece of information that that is is
frankly incorrect and has been stated
previously the idea that that cloud
would have settled
so that persons close to the ground
would have had a higher concentration
that is not true
the cloud behaves as a gas would behave
in that situation for that particle size
and there is no settling of such a cloud
it moves as a gas cloud would move
and
the settling that would take place would
only occur if the concentration was so
very high and that is exceptionally high
that the particles would aggregate and
literally precipitate out of the air and
fall onto the ground so as long as those
particles are suspended in the air they
would move as a glass cloud move and mix
accordingly so that information is
incorrect
mr cobo you're recognized for five
minutes
i think chairman gentlemen it appears
you all bring a an impressive array of
credentials to this table and it's good
to have you all here
i know my friend from new england wants
to pursue a question so
in the spirit of generosity i yield my
time to the gentleman from massachusetts
thank you very much and i thank my good
friend for yielding his time
dr stone uh i was kind of shocked at one
of our colleagues a line of questioning
earlier uh i thought that you answered
it well when you said that
the person had misled yourself and the
american people as to the critical
issues in this case what they are i
think that's a pretty good description
of uh what a lot of people have been
trying to do in this case the white
house included and some
members of this panel i also thought to
try to link you with the an anarchist
movement last time my knowledge of
harvard would leave me to believe there
aren't many anarchists at harvard
university
but beyond that
i think that the overreaction to your
testimony
is linked to the fact that number one
you're independent uh you were chosen by
the attorney general herself presumably
because of your academic credentials and
your independence to assess what
happened in this case and frankly you've
come down with a different opinion than
others have about the government's
investigation i want to quote you said i
found the government's investigation
seriously deficient
uh you said that the quote the
government never gave us a candid
account of what went wrong
and finally you welcomed these hearings
by saying that
these investigations should dispel
bizarre conspiracy theories that have
flourished in the past two years
so let me just say that i appreciate
your testimony i appreciate everybody's
testimony whether they agree with my
conclusion or not and i certainly would
see their independence
and their credentials before this
committee let me ask you about uh
something you've said about the fbi
because this is a strong statement also
you said the fbi's ultimate strategy was
to try to force the branch davidians out
of the compound by threatening the lies
of their children
now was this in your opinion a conscious
strategy or
was it a strategy that happened because
they left themselves no other option
a conscious strategy i i think there was
uh
one agent who told me that they were
hoping to stir up
the
maternal instinct of the mothers that
when they saw their children suffering
maybe that they'd get some sense in
their heads or something like that i
certainly
do not believe that the attorney general
thought
that the cs gas was as dangerous as i
thought i certainly don't think that the
information she was relying on was
flawed the
information that you got on the cs cam
now now this is a problem here are
people who worked in the context of the
hemsworth report who have been
testifying and they are not apparently
as concerned as i am
about the long term
uh by by that i mean 10 12 24 hours of
inhaling this gas for a child i have no
doubt in my mind at all that this would
cause a child to get pulmonary edema
so
but you see there there are still people
who are
have a different view and i believe
that's the view that the attorney
general was given i saw the material
that she was given it was mostly from
this british source and you say that uh
that you did not doubt and i don't doubt
that janet reno was concerned for the
children i think she was
uh but that and you felt that she would
never have felt justified in ordering
the gas attack if she had understood the
risk to them as i think you and others
have indicated and then you finally say
i can only conclude that she was
misinformed or misled which one do you
think is more likely well i i don't
think that she
what was critical to me in terms of my
uh particular report
was finding out
what had caused her to change her mind
right that was absolutely crucial to me
because her first reaction was just
right in my view you don't use cs gas
when there are babies right so somehow
she changed her mind so i kept trying to
find out what is the information she got
to change her mind now i was uh uh
unable
to get a coherent answer to that
question
i was told she talked to this person
you're going to talk to salem
harry salem
uh i i doubt that he has
well whatever he will say you will find
out but i couldn't understand how it
would convince somebody who was
concerned about the children well
thankfully we're going to have the
opportunity to ask the attorney general
herself later on about some of the
information that she relied upon how she
came to her final judgment and why she
changed her mind on the gas issue let me
ask you another question and maybe mr
marcus could chime in here also on the
issue of the children and gas masks now
it's pretty clearly understood and i
think it's already been mentioned
that gas children have difficulty or is
it impossible for children to use a gas
mask they don't they don't have enough
ventilatory capacity to pull the air
through
the mechanism that cleans the air out
right so they just if if you see that
kind of mess they just don't have enough
mr chairman that may have possibly could
make it sure yeah correct
during the last war i was born in 1939 i
was issued a british child respirator
and carried it to school for several
years
norway and israel currently produce and
manufacture and stockpile respirators
for children over the age of two years
old but do they work effectively no no
no this is no no this is just
he and i agree entirely for children
over two years if they have the proper
gas mask they might i'm talking about
children under two years of which there
were many in the compound and are we
aware at all in any of these
investigation yours or the treasury
report that there were child sized gas
masks in that compound i never was able
to mr marcus could you comment on that
yes as far as i know they were not i
just want to introduce the record to
meteorological data your microphone
microphone
i'd like to introduce for the record the
meteorological data for that day
uh i've got this from the u.s department
of commerce national oceanic so on and
so forth and it shows that the winds
never got to that kind of velocity
and i i must commend our british
colleagues for suspending the laws of
physics
if he is correct that is that you get
the dispersion in the cloud it doesn't
fall to the ground
if you have a situation which is static
that is this little to no wind you would
never have to shoot another round
and i don't think that ever happens
thanks jim your time uh mr kobold's
yield has expired
mr wise you recognize no you want to mr
schumer you're recognized for five
minutes
uh
no go ahead
uh
oh i saw you read
why is yes all right mr wise you're
recognizing mr upshaw or doctor i saw
you reaching for your button uh i think
you wanted to respond to those comments
yes i i just find it uh unbelievable
that the last statement was made
as long as the particles are suspended
they will behave as a cloud
given enough time they will aggregate
and fall out of the air but the time
frame that we're looking at
is vastly different from the it's it's
hours that we're talking about for this
kind of particle size the only way in
which that changes and the documentary
evidence is in the hemsworth report it
was actually looked at in a 20 meter
cube room which
i'm sorry that's metric ten foot by nine
foot by eight foot room if you fire a
twelve and a half gram grenade into that
room it will decay to very low levels
within about half an hour if you're
changing the air within that room about
once every hour
that is documented experimental evidence
which is in this hemsworth report
uh
dr stone spoke about
his concerns about toxicity for children
and particularly for infants
given the amount
of dosage that you've calculated was in
that compound at the time
given the winds that were going through
the compound
was there an amount that would have been
present that could have endangered
even
infants i would address that to dr
upshaw sorry for dr rice
given the concentrations that we've
calculated in the decay there
the the point is we don't believe those
concentrations
were sufficient
uh to cause serious harm
to adults or children i mean we keep
pulling on the children here and and i i
can see why you're doing it the the main
point of the argument as far as cs is
concerned is that there is no evidence
to suggest that children or the elderly
or any
any other extreme of age is any more
susceptible to the effects of the gas if
the concentration is high enough
the effects will be seen in everybody
and yes i don't
deny that they're unpleasant but the
concentrations that we have calculated
in the decay of those concentrations
even if a child was in that
environment which i think is extremely
unlikely
for the whole period of the gassing
operation i.e six hours
we don't believe those accumulated doses
of cs
would have led to any serious long-term
harm
may i add to that because a statement
was made earlier which again was
incorrect
we were relating the the dosage to these
children and the only point that was
made with the respiratory rate of these
children the fact that it decides how
much gets into the child is not the
respiratory rate it's the minute volume
it's the amount of air that that child
breathes in every minute
and and not just how fast it breathes
and that determines the dosage to that
child and the minute volume of the child
is considerably less than an adult so it
will take in considerably less than an
adult
for for its given body weight well
apparently it wasn't the gas wasn't all
that strong as far as adults went
because it didn't drive anybody out
well i i don't think you can actually
conclude that
we know
or our calculations suggest what the
concentration is
that assumes that they weren't driven
out if they were actually exposed to it
we have no evidence that they were
exposed to that con concentration for
any length of time they may well have
one
pardon me but my time's gonna be running
short it's one reason because it was a
very big compound we're not talking
about your ten by nine by eight room no
this time yeah um uh
incidentally i just so the record shows
interestingly enough one of those
children that was found perhaps it was a
child that mr barr was holding up a
picture was found stabbed
gas doesn't stab people does it i think
if you look at the autopsy records
without exception the bodies of all the
children were found in the bunker area
mr marcus you said that the winds
couldn't have been that high do you have
any estimate of what the winds were
um yes i actually had as i say have the
meteorological data
for that day by hour and the winds uh
from uh
let's say uh six o'clock we're 25 gusted
to 25 miles an hour 25 miles
or 25 knots
18 knots 15 knots 21 knots 26 knots
uh the highest gust was 26 knots
at any rate we're not talking about a
static situation
correct but remember these were this was
inside i understand that i understand
there were holes in this compound uh
after a while too
large holes
um
i want to shift just a second if i could
uh dr rice and dr up show off this is
not an area that you feel comfortable
talking about an area of expertise
please let me know i want to talk about
law enforcement's present practices
following the
following waco
is it not still the practice of law
enforcement to use cs gas
in the united states i believe that's
the case
what is an interesting comment that
deserves to be made is that the
himsworth committee
recommended that for internal use in
buildings if cs was used grenade should
contain no more than five grams of cs
the waco ferret round in fact contains
3.7 grams which is even less than the
hymnsworth committee recommended would
be the maximum to use
well i just i found it interesting
according to the fbi 867 states and
local law enforcement agencies that were
contacted still use or maintain cs gas
688 maintain it in their inventory the
fbi has used it
six times in the last five years not
including waco three before and three
afterwards a number of law enforcement
agencies local law enforcement still ucs
gas not only in the hostage situation
but also as a spray and i think that
ought to be pointed out much of the some
of what i'm talking about are using as a
spray outside but so cs gas still seems
to be
considered by law enforcement to be a
viable
to be to be a viable usage in certain
situations
i'll uh yield back my time well i'll
give the balance of my time whatever
might be left to mr schumer when he's
available
black has run
come on now
thank you very much mr chairman let me
just
ask a few more questions about the gas
and then ask some questions of mr parks
it's my view that and i agree with
what's been said by dr stone and others
that
and let me quote dr stone given my
current information about cs gas it is
difficult to understand why a person
whose primary concern was the safety of
the children would agree to the fbi's
plan and i think that's to me that's
fairly clear
that in any other type of law
enforcement situation if you had a
hostage situation where one a kidnapper
two kidnappers had taken hostage of an
entire
family of five or six children seems to
me that the local police's
motivation would be to do anything
but to endanger those children that's my
understanding of how
law enforcement at least at the local
level reacts to these types of
situations and i think that perhaps the
religious component of the branch
davidians and a kind of misunderstanding
and a group
analysis that they were all branch
davidians so that they were all somehow
guilty of something and worthy of of
gassing and attacking that maybe that
had uh a part of the the issue there
uh let me turn to uh mr parks uh mr
parks you're an expert in the body of
international law relating to armed
conflict is that right
that's correct congressman and you're a
member of the united states delegation
the international conventions at which
these types of laws with regard to war
are made that's correct
what are the current treaty obligations
of the united states with respect to
this cs gas and military conflict well i
would stress that the point that the
congress made the current
obligations
do not include the 1993 chemical weapons
convention which made some slightly
different rules with regard to riot
control agents the united states is
bound by the 1925 geneva protocol
which basically prohibits the first use
in war of chemical weapons
and as i stated previously the united
states does not regard rye control
agents including cs to be a chemical
weapon
so in from your opinion and the
department of defense's opinion that
this gas is not prohibitive this is not
considered a chemical weapon
well it's been we've heard from a number
of people that perhaps it is uh
prohibited i understand that there may
be a technical problem there as to
whether uh it's a it's prohibited you're
saying it's not others i think have
testified that it is prohibited does
anybody else on the panel know about
that aspect of this whether
our treaties prohibit the use of csgt
all i can say is the uk takes the same
view as the u.s it's it's permitted for
the use and civil disturbances but not
military
well i'm sorry it is used for military
purposes as well and there's no
prohibition to your knowledge of it in
the military i can't answer congressman
if i can clarify that there is a policy
restriction on the use of cs in combat
for the very simple reason
that if you were to use cs on the
battlefield
and the enemy were to observe it's being
used say through binoculars rather than
someone inhaling it
or some sort of detector they might
perceive that you have used a chemical
weapon and escalate the level of the
conflict with chemical weapons so it's
more of a tactical issue it's a policy
that's a policy decision so as not to
escalate
which is contained in an executive order
11850 that's been in effect since uh
president ford's time i'm glad you've
cleared that up let me just clarify one
other thing i would point out that even
under the 1993 chemical weapons
convention
the policy would be that we can use
these in other military operations short
of actual armed conflict peacekeeping
operations such as somalia or haiti
rescue operations and things like that
so our policy is quite similar to that
for law enforcement operations
all right let me ask you one other
question in your experience and your
knowledge with the dod
has any and i know we've had testimony
from a number of people uh that the
military uses this gas to train on a
regular basis is that correct
i was trained on it three years ago
even
said that they were trained on it my
question is to your knowledge has any uh
soldier in training ever died as part of
that training with cs gas i don't have
that knowledge i can't say
thank you very much for that let me ask
a more general question of the panel
we've talked about the the fact that
that there were children inside the
compound and that perhaps this is a very
pretty good reason why not to use it let
me ask dr rice and dr upshaw if you
agree with that that it went in a
situation a law enforcement situation
where there are children particularly
younger children involved would you
advise law enforcement not to use this
gas
it would
it would depend entirely on the
operational situation uh it is a balance
of risk and and consequence and if if
the child was deemed to be of greater
risk from the consequences of not using
cs i would advise to use it if it felt
it would resolve the situation
but in this case this was not a pure
hostage situation we've heard testimony
in that extent some people think it is a
pure hostage situation clearly there
were opportunities for some of the
davidians to leave the compound on their
own and they chose not to for religious
reasons because they believed for
whatever reason this was not a pure
hostage situation so how do you use a cs
gas to drive people out of a place
that they don't want to be driven out of
who are
potentially innocent children some of
the women some of the
i
older
people
that all i can tell you is that the
concentration of ces would drive people
out of those buildings um the
operational decision to use is something
i can't comment on so what you're saying
is that the uh the effort to drive the
people out of the
the compound was unsuccessful uh
obviously because if it if you believe
that if they were successful uh the
people would have had no choice but to
get out of there
they should have moved out of those
buildings but in terms of after six
hours of building exposure the first
exposure would have moved them from the
room however we should clarify what we
mean by moving them out they could have
moved to another part of the same
building where the cs concentration was
lower they didn't need to come out of
the building
as long as they moved out of that cloud
of cn smooth
well i would like to thank the panel for
their testimony i think it's been very
informative and very important thank you
very much
ms lockman have you been recognized i
don't think you have would you like five
minutes
i recognize you for five minutes i am
i've read through um the material and
the scholarly arguments but i'm trying
to is is cs gas what was used
in on college campuses in the late 60s
and 70s and then in the demonstration
isn't that the same substance
perhaps i should answer that purely
anecdotally i was at berkeley between 63
and 66
and so you have personal experience with
this substance
i certainly saw what went on
my belief is that about that time cn was
being used but wasn't there a switch to
cs late in the 60s because of the lesser
risk i have no knowledge when the switch
was made within the states or when a
particular police force in the united
states switched from cn to cs but in law
enforcement there was a switch from cn
generally to cs because it's less
hazardous isn't it that is that is
correct
one of the
questions that has been asked to me and
i don't
i'm pretty sure the answer is there is
no such thing but i promised i would ask
it anyhow some people have said well
isn't there some gas that could have
been used that rather than
creating an adverse reaction that would
would actually render someone
unconscious and resolve the situation in
that way is there any any gas that is
currently available or being developed
that could
be utilized in that way
that's the answer in an ideal world but
uh currently there is no such case and
none being developed to best of my
knowledge
all right the final question i have is
if the choice was between
the use of cs gas which is non-lethal
and
the next alternative which appeared to
be a more aggressive perhaps arms of
some sort
wouldn't that affect your choice on on
the use of this non-lethal weapon in my
personal opinion yes it would very much
so i would always go for the
the non-violent
use
thank you i'd like to uh yield the
balance of my time to mr schumer i thank
you uh miss lofgren
and i thank the witnesses for bearing
with us on into the evening
i would like all the witnesses i have a
few quick questions where about this and
there may be nothing involved here at
all but i beg your indulgence and so i'm
going to ask you a series of six or
seven questions if the answer is no do
nothing this is for the entire panel but
if the answer is yes please raise your
hand
okay and i want to ask you if you've
ever discussed the testimony you gave
today or discussed anything
relative to this hearings or were
assisted in any way with its preparation
by any of the following persons okay
first a representative of an
organization called failure analysis
associates
has anyone talked to anyone from that
organization
you have sir okay
wait i'll i'll follow up
but the record uh dr stone has raised
his hand
second to john moe
moali
wally
okay the record will show no one has
raised his hand
anyone known to you to be a member of an
organization known as the waco team
no one has raised his hand
uh mark barnes
no one is raised his hand jim warner
no one is raised his hand
fran haga
okay dr stone
and any representative of the national
rifle association
dr stone okay so we can take it that
none of the other witnesses have talked
to any of those people
all right thank you um
and i'll come back to that in a little
bit
my next question is i just related for
dr marcus uh i understand that there is
some dispute about whether you're here
as an epa employee or not and in fact
i'd like to introduce without objection
because you your um
your letter your testimony came on
official epa stationery a letter from
robert
i don't know how to say his name either
purchase sepi who was just simply saying
that you are not appearing as a witness
on behalf of epa mr
you're just on somebody else on if i get
an extension of the time that's fine
with me yeah certainly your thank you
date of the letter and the time you
received it july 26
today because we asked officially after
we saw the testimony um would the
gentleman yield on his reservation
certainly it's really not a reservation
well you asked you actually admitted i
just want to clarify that i've read the
letter and there's nothing in the letter
that's inconsistent with what dr marcus
had to say himself about the fact he's
not appearing here officially
for epa they have not said he couldn't
appear here and they have not said that
he did not
have the right to appear here and be
paid for it while he's here which is
what he said he was they've simply said
he's not representing exactly official
epa
uh because he didn't go through the
screening procedures or whatever his
studies or his analysis i don't know
whatever okay and that's fine and i
without objection i would
i mean i believe i have a right to
object to find out
the date and the authenticity of the
letter it came today can you tell me
about what time 7 13 p.m
uh yeah it's 1913 so must be seven it's
on the facts level it must be 7 13 this
evening and that's because you requested
it the minority question no
they were watching and they sent the
letter over at their own volition all
right
without objection you have an additional
minute oh it's more than a minute mr
chairman well but i i've been watching
it it's amazing how fast these things
can be done all right let me just say uh
for dr marcus or mr mark or some excuse
me
we have some order please
thank you mr chairman order in the house
i understand um
that your work for the epa's office
uh is in the area of drinking water is
that correct
okay and have you ever published any
scholarly article or anything else on cs
gas i have not you have not okay thank
you now my next questions are for dr
rice and uh dr upshaw and let me just
ask you a series of them and let you
each answer them siri autumn because and
i just want to say one thing i admire
your composure i can sort of tell by
your facial expressions that when some
of the other witnesses are speaking
you would like to
scream
and uh
your british composure is something that
i very much admire and say aspire to um
[Music]
just aspire but let me uh
let me ask you these three questions
first
was cs gas a good safe choice to use it
way go under all the circumstances
where children or no i'll do them all
three at once and you can
go on a little bit it's a technique each
side is picked up here as a way of
extending our time uh was it a cs gas a
good safe choice second were children or
adults likely to suffocate as a result
of the use of cs gas
and is it likely
that either cs gas or any agent used as
a vehicle for cs gas caused or
contributed to a fire the third one is
the most important question because i
don't know if that has been asked it
hasn't been while i was here
and who would like to go first doctor
we'll do an alphabetical order dr rice
the answer to your first question is
categorically yes it is the safest to
use
having made the decision that you wanted
to use a tear gas
uh the second question can you remind me
of the second question is uh were
children or adults likely to suffocate
as a result of the use of
excuse me were children or adults likely
to suffocate as a result of the use of
cs gas
based on the analysis that we've done of
the situation
uh and the concentrations we believe
that were
within the compound no
and the third question
is it likely
that either cs gas or any agent uses a
vehicle and i wish we could call it cs
tear gas you know gas ever since the
world war ii has a sinister notion to it
and cs gas sounds somewhat
eerie mysterious if we called it cs tear
gas which is what it is it would for the
audience and people out there in america
just catching a snippet it would sound
less ominous because most people are
familiar with tear gas but is it likely
that either cs tear gas or any other
agent used as a vehicle for cst or gas
caused or contributed to a fire
uh i'm not a fire expert but from what i
understand from the toxicology of cs and
methylene chloride which i think are the
main compounds to be looked at here now
okay and dr up show
the reply to your first question
the reply to your first question is
unequivocally yes
the second and not at the concentration
is used
and again i'm not an expert
on fire and hazards but at the
concentrations used i believe that not
to be the case and in particular
that's the reason why cs was formulated
in methylene chloride to minimize the
fire risk thank you thank you mr
chairman
thank you mr schumer uh let's see who
would like mr micah you're recognized
for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
dr stone you participated in some of the
review this
document
produced by the department of justice i
believe you have
some pretty outstanding credentials
it i'm just wondering if you were aware
also of some of the previous history and
the government making decisions
to use cs gas for children
i have a department of justice crisis
center log from ruby ridge eight months
before the waco disaster
that shows that the department of
justice
and uh this is a copy of it and i'll
submit it for the record
uh and it it's
uh i guess mr larry potts is in charge
and
the comments here are the deployment of
gas into the residence presents a high
degree of risk to small children there
may be a one-year-old baby inside so
we'd had a history of using this where
there were children in fact
is that correct
were you aware of this
the other thing
uh
that will haunt me i think
if i live to be a hundred years old uh
of course i'm i'm most disturbed by the
loss of the agents and i saw them
uh shot in this
uh in this
situation the first situation but
none of the folks
who were davidians worked for the
federal government but somebody in the
federal government made a decision to
use this gas and i also read from the
report and it says it's impossible to
know how many of the persons inside the
compound
inhaled the tear gas because
the last gas
insertions were made nearly an hour
before the fire ended the lapse of time
would have been sufficient for the cs
gas to have dissipated from any of the
bodies
it might have been present in earlier i
read the autopsy report and that's
really what haunts me and what mr barr
talked about
and
the autopsy report is page after page of
children
one year old child suffocated and bunker
one-year-old baby an another one
suffocated and their their remains were
so destroyed they're identified by you
know doe 69
five to six year old girl
body found in in bunker
it goes it goes on and on children a
baby girl not even the age pages of this
that a decision of somebody to use this
gas
and i'll never know maybe we'll never
know if they died from inhaling the gas
but nonetheless they died
should we have a policy dealing with the
federal government uh using this type of
gas where there are children involved
yes i certainly think we should i think
that if we if we're non
political about it yes
and
uh we get out of this adversarial mode
i guess uh i think our military believes
what the people from england are saying
to you today i think that's the line
you're going to get from them i think
the military thinks this is a very
valuable weapon
they are assured by the police the
british use it to disperse
mobs they have been they have
the police use it now all the time i
think it's very important that we get
some good solid evidence
about children i don't think we've heard
any solid evidence about the risk to
children i think if you would get the
national academy of science or someone
to answer this question so that the fbi
when i push them
and i consider mr jamar an incredibly
conscientious man and when i pushed him
and pushed him about the children he
practically
became tearful and then he says well the
army told me we have the best people
right so i think it needs to be
clarified what we should have a policy
and we should have a policy particularly
children i haven't even gotten into the
women or other folks that may have been
innocent i thank you and i promise to
yield
to my colleague mr schiff he was
gracious to me yesterday thank you
two things i think gentleman feeling
first
for anyone who says suggests that
government employees don't work late
i think that we should proudly refer
them to the environmental protection
agency's employee estate in the office
past seven o'clock
at least when there are congressional
hearings going on that they might be
concerned about
let me ask more seriously
at the very least we know this gas is a
heavy irritant
and yet i believe that the plan was to
insert this gas for 48 hours
does anyone on the panel know and can
say briefly why was this gas going to be
inserted for 48 hours why did they
expect it wouldn't work right away to
get people out can anyone can anyone
explain that
dr stone
it's my understanding that they thought
that there were enough gas masks not
taking into account the children
that they may be able to protect himself
and after a while the canister doesn't
work so you've got to get another gas
mask and so forth so they thought that
eventually the place would be so
contaminated they'd have to come up
did they expect even with gas masks did
they expect people to start coming out
in the first hour or two hours or three
hours if you know
yes the the plan was
that we're going to start injecting the
gas at one place the military told them
they they told me that we should inject
it everywhere at the same time
massively in it and so they developed
this fallback plan that they start to
inject the gas if they shoot at us then
we'll inject it in everywhere okay so
then they started injecting it
everywhere and they quickly used up
everything they had trying to inject it
in and
according to mr jamar at least he would
never have ordered it if the wind was
blowing that's why the wind is blowing
is a big question
because it wouldn't make sense to do
this with the wind blowing but that for
the first two hours the wind wasn't
blowing were they expecting people to
come out early at least
and people did not come out early right
then they just kept up with their plan
anyway well at that point they had they
as they report they were shot at and so
they'd move to this next plan of putting
the gas in everywhere
my time has expired thank you very much
mr chairman i wonder if i could uh add a
comment to that uh you may comment dr
upshur just to justifiable record my
understanding of the situation of waco
was that the gas was not put in
continuously it was put in in four
discrete
at about one to one and a half hour
intervals and there were gaps in the
period and according to our calculation
of between half an hour and one hour
when the gas concentrations or the cs
concentrations would drop to very low
levels indeed so it was a pulsed
input not a continuous input just for
the record doctor you look you want to
comment as well for the record we can't
have everybody doing it but once we get
this started i think all of you are a
fair game go ahead
i would like to make a comment during
the time
between the major gas injections
my understanding is that the ferret
rounds were continued to be fired
so that would be a continuous injection
of the cs methylene chloride and if i
may make a clarifying point with uh
congressman brewster congressman
brewster i understand now where you're
coming from you made the statement about
halides being flame retardants there are
two types of chemical compounds one
organic and one inorganic you are
correct inorganic halides are flame
retardants however organic
halides
do burn like the dickens with the
exception of some such as carbon
so there's two different compounds
involved here sir
thank you
dr marcus you may uh
everybody else has jumped in you may
very briefly
just want to say that this material
causes adults to vomit
when it's in high concentration it also
causes children
even young children to vomit
if they're small
and if they've been knocked down by the
gas
or in this case the powder there the
chance of in
aspirating their own
um vomit is very high and this causes an
aspiration pneumonitis which cannot be
differentiated after all is said and
done
from what would have occurred if it was
cs alone
thank you very much
um as i understand it the minority does
not have any more right now wants to
pass only has one uh questioner left
so i will recognize mr ehrlich
first for five minutes thank you mr
chairman i am going to yield the
majority of my time to mr chabot but i
have one question and and mr wise asked
a very specific question
uh
mr blue that's a fairly general question
and i want to re really re phrase mr
wise's question and get a if i can a
very short concise answer from each of
you i suspect i know what the answer is
going to be but
with respect to this entire issue i'm
not on any particular side and we've
made that point time and time again my
purpose in this hearing
is to come to some definitive
conclusions in my own mind so that i can
tell the people i represent in maryland
what i think
and that is the reason i'm asking this
question there are no sides
and my question is this
in your view
and you've all we've all laid a great
foundation for all of your all experts
was it appropriate or inappropriate this
is a very subjective question
i want the factors to be taken into
account the factors that were present in
waco
was it appropriate or inappropriate to
use cs gas
in the levels you understand
were utilized
in light of the totality of
circumstances knowing one
infants were present
and two
the agent was to be delivered at least
to some extent
within confined spaces
it's a very specific question i'd ask
for a very short answer from each of you
appropriate or inappropriate dr stone i
think not appropriate
please before you go on that could not
be heard by anybody but okay i think it
was not appropriate thank you dr stone i
think it was definitely not appropriate
and i just want to show the the
committee this is a book called the
harriet lane handbook it's put out by
johns hopkins university and it really
is put out because
uh
pedia pediatrics is a different kind of
science it's a manual pediatric house
officers and if the general
gentleman from england were correct we
would need no manual such as this
thank you
thank you sir inappropriate uh dr rice
uh
it's a tough question to our answer uh
i think if you can
create the concentration in the building
uh that has the desired effect then yes
it is appropriate but it is an
operational consideration and it's a
balance between risk and benefit and i
don't think there is a simple answer to
your question thank you sir very very
very very honest answer sorry i would
agree entirely with that it's a balance
of risk and benefit and it's an
operational decision at the
concentrations that you would require to
receive in order to uh into it to move
people out of those buildings
thank you sir uh dr julie
i would say no judging from the from a
chemical standpoint
and from the reaction of my research
assistant when she accidentally got into
contact with the stuff i didn't think
it's appropriate
thank you sir
mr park
congressman if you saw my high school
and college chemistry grades you would
be assured i am not an expert on how to
employ i assure you mine were far worse
and i can't answer this question thank
you sir i appreciate each of you giving
an opinion as to really what is the
bottom line issue with respect to this
hearing thank you very much i yield my
time
i i thank the gentleman uh dr stone you
were asked by the attorney deputy
attorney general to help prepare this
report for the justice department
correct
you see there are two reports
i think what you're holding up is the
investigative report
that was done by the justice department
then there are these smaller reports
which i was asking but it was the
justice department that asked you to
prepare the report and i believe in fact
that uh the deputy attorney general knew
you well because i believe you two are
on the harvard faculty together
absolutely yes okay now
i i'm disturbed that in your written
statement uh you report that when you
requested documentation
about cs gas from the justice department
you were given and i quote ambiguous and
irrelevant material now do you think the
justice department was withholding the
information you needed
to do the job they had asked you to do
or and may be equally disturbing
do you think that the department had not
done its homework so that ambiguous or
irrelevant material was all they had
i asked
as i said earlier i was concerned about
what information had convinced
attorney general reno to change her mind
so
i was told that she had had a
conversation with harry salem and that
had been important so i said could you
please tell me what she was told i then
got a document
that was uh incoherent incomprehensible
and i cannot tell you i've been asked by
many people well what did he say it
doesn't say anything
okay thank you uh and finally doctor um
i know you've been here a long time as
we all have
uh and but you've studied this matter
intensively
at the request of the justice department
uh and you've i'm sure given a lot of
thought
because the central purpose of these
hearings
is to make sure that we've learned as
much as possible from the mistakes that
were made
let me ask you
what one or two points you think it
would be most important for all of us to
learn from this terrible tragedy
well i think the first most important
point ought to be that we have different
rules of engagement
when police or other law enforcement are
dealing with children
right there ought to be a red flag go up
and they'll say okay whatever we do
ordinarily there are different risks and
benefits when there are children that's
the first thing we ought to do the
second thing we have to do since as mr
wise as congressman wise has pointed out
since
police all over
america are now using cs gas
we ought to find out whether it really
harms children
in the ways that i think it does because
if we don't if even one child
more dies from this and i've read
reports of children who died from it of
adults of children who died from it in
other countries and they were actually
studies although
it was said that they were not
physicians one of them was my colleague
dr hugh
who is a a
very well-trained physician and mph
right so i believe this is dangerous to
children i think we should clear that up
the next thing i think we need to know
is this relationship between
the attorney general
and the fbi
how does that work
who
who in the attorney general's office is
coordinating the stuff with the fbi
in my own reaction in both situations i
found
the people in treasury when they first
heard what i think is an incredibly
incompetent overreaching plan the first
response was they said no
then they changed their mind i'd like to
know why they changed their minds the
same thing with janet reno when she was
given this plan of the tank and gas
attack she said no
and then somehow she changed her mind so
how these decisions were made
and how they will be made in the future
it seems to me is absolutely critical
thank you very much thank you the time
has expired mr boyer you're recognized
for five minutes
thank you mr chairman i'd like to move
into uh the justice report itself on
page 270. discuss it
actually excuse me on page 266 it
discusses an april 14th meeting in the
justice department and by this i take it
there was a
so this was also written based on an
interview of the attorney general
at the bottom it said the attorney
general this is in this conversation
with dr harry salem
about uh
the effects of cs gas on children
pregnant women and the elderly
uh
the last sentence she the attorney
general recalled that although there had
been no laboratory tests performed on
children relative to the effects of of
the gas anecdotal evidence was
convincing that there would be no
permanent injury of course that is based
on the assessment from dr salem
who must have been present to say here's
what the effects of the gas would be
would you agree with that statement
i don't agree with it i as i've said
repeatedly i would be concerned that the
children would have the long-term risk
of pulmonary edema all right the reason
i'm going to go down the line here real
quick because we have uh uh
dr uh harry salem who obviously we've
got a very tight meeting here we got the
the uh
meeting with reno and mr hubble mr
kinney mr in control
along with the director sessions fbi
representatives clark grove potts
coulson rogers uh betts chief of the new
mexico domestic terrorism units a really
small group of individuals in dr salem
so let me go down the line here you
don't agree with the recommendation of
this doctor that's giving advice to an
attorney general that has to make a very
important decision
mr marcus
i know harry salem and he works for the
military he has most of his professional
life at the edgewood arsenal
and
i don't think it was appropriate i
assume he shares the same opinions as
our
uh
gentleman friends from england all right
well let me go down the line they can i
don't think it's agree with the
recommendation he gave the attorney
general
based on the evidence we have i will
reiterate we do not have any any
evidence to suggest that
young children all the elderly or any
more
wait a second the question i have to ask
is very specific here because we have
the attorney general recollecting advice
that was given to her by dr dr smith and
that advice was this sir
she recalled that although there were no
laboratory tests performed on children
relative the effects of the gas there's
antidotal evidence
was convincing that there would be no
permanent injury
is on the boat available evidence
he has a point i i don't see anything to
disagree with that advice okay
on the basis of the available evidence
there's i would agree with what his
advice was okay
i would disagree simply because of the
fire conditions that existed in the
formation of the
decomposition products of cs
well
it's great we got the experts
disagreeing
i i i think that
i think it's a really
important point they may disagree here
but i i guess now i'm
confused at the moment because we had an
answer to a question here from mr
ehrlich who went right down the line and
all of you went down and said no no we
shouldn't be using this against children
the two the two gentlemen here in the
middle have said well this is really a
balancing question uh risk versus
benefit
well if we're talking about a balancing
question of risk versus benefit it
throws me then into this realm of i
agree with you sir it's pretty obvious
uh uh that the gut reactions from the
attorney general mrs reno were pretty
accurate didn't want to really want to
do this
somehow she gets convinced or pressured
to do to do this i don't know we'll have
to find out we'll have to ask her
but then but then when she finally makes
this decision to go ahead
and she's going to make this decision to
use the gas
and it's that risk benefit analysis i
guess to use them on children and the
elderly
on the 18th she then
she works for somebody doesn't she
she works for the president of the
united states so then she says well geez
i better tell my boss about this risk
benefit assessment so then on the 18th
since she's made this decision she then
has to sit down and discuss the plan
with the president united states
who also i'm sure could say yes or no to
the plan of operations somebody always
works for somebody in our government
we're always accountable to the people
that's what's magnificent about our
system of government and we'll have to
wait till we get the attorney general in
but uh dr stone we will move forward on
your mystery
question because it's a mystery to me
and i think it's a mystery to a lot of
american people because the buck doesn't
stop with janet reno
stops with the president i yield back
the balance of my time
any other member on our side wish to use
that time uh mr zelic would you like to
i um
first of all i think we we know
the some information on dr stone and
where he's from and um i think a few
questions were asked dr rice and dr uh
upshaw um
i want to just just uh ask you
were you involved in any consulting with
the justice department or anybody to do
with waco whatsoever did you just come
over here on on your own
no we didn't come over
on our own we were obviously invited um
the department of justice invited us to
come department of justice that's right
did they pay your way
they're paying they're paying there's a
contract with the defense research
agency which is the organization which i
work for okay being paid in in a proper
and formal sense okay so are you being
paid to give testimony i'm not being
paid by the department of justice being
paid
no there's a contract with my
organization the chemical defense
establishment for my presence here as as
a toxicologist i'm giving my time and
that is being formally painful
okay i understand thank you and uh
dr stone um
and just to put it out um you're uh
you were
invited in why why were you invited to
participate in this review do you think
right no not here tonight but
why why were you
invited to to be a part of the review of
what happened at waco what do you think
why
why do you think you were particularly
chosen
uh i i think i was chosen uh i know i
was chosen as a last-minute substitute
because
the person they uh
that i had recommended was
someone that the scientologist objected
to
uh boyer's time has expired i yield
five minutes to mr shatty
let me begin by uh joining mr schiff
i've got to say
i thought i had heard it all when the
justice department was able to flash
over here within minutes of testimony in
this hearing a press release responding
to testimony in the hearing that
happened during the working day i was
impressed but i will tell you
today we have the environmental
protection agency at 19 minutes after 7
pm
flashing over here not at your request
not at the minorities request but on
their own because they happen to be
sitting back watching tv
um watching these hearings glued to the
tv 17 19 minutes after 7 pm in the
evening and they flash over here a
letter they got a typist on staff
this is impressive i mean this is truly
impressive i am impressed i will never
criticize a a a government official
again for not working hard because
clearly when the clinton administration
tells them
great deal already mr
clinton administration has apparently
everyone so scared of the results of
this hearing i'd like to know if
anything's going on in washington other
than their officials watching these
hearings and responding to what's said
having said that
let me follow on another point i i've
got to tell you
i am uh mr schumer
pointed out that he had great respect
for the restraint of the two gentlemen
in the middle i want to point that out
um i i've got to tell you
i think it's fine that you have
restraint
i find it a little difficult that you
can be that restrained i have a
nine-year-old and a thirteen-year-old
and i can't be that restrained
i want to clarify something the record
mr
barr here next to me held up these two
autopsy photos which are ghastly i'm
sorry the press wasn't here when mr
schumer holds up things like this the
press arrives and takes a gazillion
pictures it's called a photo op
but moments later
moments
i'm trying again myself
moments later uh one of my colleagues on
the other side elicited a question that
in fact um one of these two children had
a stab wound i have reviewed and i think
it's important for the record to show
one is
baby doe 62 the other is babydoll girl
57 i have just reviewed both the
department of justice report which lists
the cause of death
and the autopsy that we have and neither
one of them list a stab wound so i think
the statement the question that that was
uh that either one of them died as a
result of a stab wound was disingenuous
would the gentleman yield i will not
i've got just so i can clarify that you
can say that those pictures did i said
the record shows that hey valentine's
day oh you don't want the facts i
understand i want the time i like my
time
um
mr
rice you characterize the amnesty
international report
on the israelis as anecdotal
have you read it
yes okay one of the anecdotes deals with
the death of a five day old baby does it
not i believe so yes okay and indeed it
begins with an inductance that says they
have received the names of 18 babies
under the age of six months all of whom
died as a result of this and you kind of
dismiss that because that's just
anecdotal is that right no the point i
was trying to make is that that report
doesn't actually say
what those babies died of they refer to
tear gas it could be cs it could be cn
and i think there is a distinct
difference okay
i i only want to point out that uh the
testimony that was just brought out from
the justice department report reveals
that the attorney general recalled that
sent there since there had been no
laboratory tests performed on children
relative to the effects of the gas she
relied on
anecdotal evidence i presume she was not
given this anecdotal debit
evidence of the death of these children
i can't comment on that i i'm sure you
can't
i also heard you say earlier that when
you did all these analyses it was not
what really happened at waco and i heard
your colleague
mr upshaw say
that what should have happened was that
people should have left the compound
but they didn't leave the compound
i want to go into a question that that
troubles me
my wife and i
uh have been married for many years
she has a different tolerance to
medicine than i do
when i get a headache it takes me a
minimum of three aspirin sometimes more
to knock that headache down if my wife
takes more than one aspirin she becomes
ill
i can tolerate advil i can tolerate two
or three advil at a time my wife takes
one advil and she's violently ill it's
too much for her
i've experienced that in other friends i
have a good personal friend
who if he drinks a cup of coffee
he immediately goes into the shakes and
can't sleep for at least 12 or 14 hours
i mean i've watched him it gets to him
he cannot tolerate it
now
i drink that stuff by the bucket load
every day
you've testified here today very
dispassionately about how there is no
evidence as to how this affects
women and children differently
i want to talk about children what
studies have you done on children
between the ages of
say 14 and 6.
personally none
dr upshaw no studies have been done on
children affording the sex so we don't
know
i would add to that you don't know but
the reports that you have in front of
you the ones that you've just been
pointing out also do not know because
all they're quoting is
anecdotal information that's come from
an exposure that took place in other
countries and the information was gained
after the event so that the exposure
agent was not known the dose of the
exposure agent was not known and the
sequelae were reported precisely my
point dr upshaw we don't know we do not
know the effects of this gas on children
what we do know i think we know i think
the record will reveal is that there
were
gas masks in that compound for adults
there were no gas masks in that compound
for children indeed as i understand it
it is impossible to create a mass a gas
mask for a child under the age of two
and in fact while i heard you testify
that the israelis have created them for
children to and over there is no gas
mask for a child under two but we do
know we do very much know
that
those children under two were going to
be exposed to this gas and the children
between two and fourteen or two and six
who couldn't wear a gas mask we're going
to be exposed to it and we now have no
studies not one study on its effect on
children not one we don't know whether
it will affect me the way an aspirin
affects me or whether it will affect
them the way it affects my wife and in
that circumstance i find the use at
least scary when i have a 13 year old
and a nine-year-old thank you
mr chairman may i make a comment
okay
i agree with the congressman's statement
because in going through the various
biochemical processes of ultimate
toxicity
it really is highly dependent on
metabolism and disposition factors
and these factors are species sex
genetic factors environmental
stress on the individual their diet
their age pathological conditions
tissue and organ specificity
dose and enzyme induction inhibition
so that's what gives you a different
response to medicine than your
wife would have
and it may account for
differences in people's response to this
particular agent
for those comments mr bryant you're
recognized for five minutes
uh dr stone
uh you were asked number of questions
about who you may have talked with uh
about this uh about this situation
i would like to clarify would you say
exactly how you originally got involved
in the waco tragedy and who or what
agency got you involved
how i originally got involved was
somewhat reluctantly i accepted the
appointment uh in the
deputy attorney general's panel to
investigate waco so you were a member of
the official panel of the department of
justice to investigate the waco
situation that is correct
and you were selected by the uh office
of the attorney general for that
position that is correct this attorney
general's office that is correct thank
you
um let me turn to uh could i just say
yes please
because uh uh congressman schumer asked
me about these
if i ever talked to these two people
these two groups you know you said
yes and and i just want to say that uh
the people i told you one called me on
the phone
and the other i just met in the hallway
for the very first time yes
i'd like to go to dr upshaw and dr rice
i'd like to ask if at least in general
terms do you agree with dr stone
that possible side effects or direct
effects i should say of cs of cs gas or
whatever might be contained with it
is in matter not only of concentration
but of concentration plus duration
do you agree with that statement dr
upshaw yes and the earlier statement of
dr stone included a misunderstanding of
that concept
it's the the dosage is determined by the
concentration uh to which the individual
is exposed multiplied by the time for
which that individual is exposed that
gives a measure of the total exposure
and the amount that that person then
inhales is a measure of the total dosage
so so you are in agreement then and i'm
sorry if there's any misunderstanding
that the effect is a matter of
concentration times duration let me just
clarify that there are two things that
we're talking about here one is the
irritation and the irritation that you
get on exposure to cs is a function of
the concentration
the dosage that you get uh to
is is related to toxicity and it's the
duration for which you're exposed to
that which is a critical factor in that
area so they're both both important
factors
one is more important for the irritation
that you get the other is more important
of the the determining factor in terms
of the measurement of the toxicity
and the more important factor for
toxicity is duration then if i
understood you right duration and
concentration because if the if the gas
is not there you can be exposed for
hours and nothing happens well it's the
two together
absolutely all right now as you know
there was a plan here to pump cs gas
into this into a building
for 48 hours
i'd like to know if in the united
kingdom you either of you who are
professionals in in this type of
chemistry in inhalation toxicology can
think of an example
of where there was a comparable plan by
the british government
uh to pump cs gas into a building for 48
straight hours under any circumstances
no
dr rice you can't think of any no doctor
dr upshaw can you nonetheless
um
can you think of a
of an example regardless of the amount
of time
that the gas was going to be put into
the building where cs gas was used by
the british government knowing there
were children inside a building
dr rice
uh i can't think of any no
doctor sorry i can't answer that i don't
have the knowledge
i i'm just going to hear your doctor
absolutely i i don't have the knowledge
so i can't answer that i'm afraid well i
i just want to observe that that both of
you gentlemen are testifying and as
professionals and as experts
but in a situation that that i've given
two factors at least the use of the gas
for 48 hours at least as a plan and when
children inside a building and when
children were also inside a building
regardless of whether it was 48 hours or
48 seconds and neither of you has an
example that you could at least can
think of here
where your government has uh has chosen
to do
either of those two things let me ask
another question about the use of cs gas
in united kingdom has anything happened
to
um i don't know if it has but has
anything happened to cause the united
kingdom to change its uh use of cs gas
over the last several years do they
still would they still use it now in all
cases they used it say 10 years ago or
is any modification and policy occurred
i know of no modification of policy but
i'm not really experiencing that area of
government policy right
dr abshalla you were i would agree with
that entirely we're not knowledgeable in
the area of government policy but we're
not aware of any change
all right um dr stone i believe that you
you were commenting at the really at the
very beginning an hour at the very end
on some other observations that you made
about the handling of the waco situation
and uh there wasn't time to get into
that in any detail i'm going to like ask
you to come back to that when you're
asked about
what you saw and what you do differently
is there anything you want to add at
this point
well um you know
from my perspective i was concerned
about this point about who were the
people inside the compound
and what were they like
and
i just want to say in terms of this
whole thing
that one of our harvard law school
graduates was inside
the compound
a man by the name of wayne martin an
african-american there were many
uh people of color in the compound
because the compound was drawn from
seventh-day adventists
and so they had come there because they
were impressed
uh with uh david koresh as people have
said but but what they haven't said is
and i
i was very disturbed at the testimony of
the fbi because i feel very strongly
that for them to keep insisting
that
david koresh is an anti-social
personality
is totally
uh
un
it's it sort of doesn't
fit the facts at all david koresh as a
young man would as as a boy would spend
hours memorizing the bible
that's not true
let me just ask you to clarify one thing
though
you mentioned people of different races
would that be relevant in this situation
i asked you that as a physician
it was relevant would it matter that
would it matter physiologically
i don't think that mattered at all okay
thank you mr chairman i i yield that
mr schumer you're recognized for five
minutes
thank you uh very much mr chairman and
uh
i guess the questions i want to ask i
want to just wrap this up matter up with
dr stone in terms of who he who visited
him who called him i was surprised to
see you raise your hand uh dr stone who
called you of the three you said you
would had contact with failure now why
don't you tell us each one first failure
analysis associates which is i i met
someone outside during the intervention
who introduced himself to me okay and
what about fran hager is she the person
who called i think
that is a woman who called me when did
she call you uh
long before the hearings how long before
uh two months ago i know it was before i
went what did she say why did she how'd
she identify herself she said that she
was doing research
did she say who she was working for she
said she was doing research for the
committee for the committee yeah
and uh
and um
and she associated herself uh in some
way with the committee i see did she
ever mention the national rifle
association she told me she was a
lifetime member of the nra but working
for the committee you're clear on that
uh she said she was doing work for the
committee yes it's your words thank you
that's very illuminating um
and then i mentioned the national rifle
association that was the third one you
raised your hand i thought i raised my
hand about two
but you raised your hand about three
failure analysis associates miss haga
and the national rifle association well
uh well that's because miss hager was
those two and one i see okay you learned
that because she was a lifetime member
doesn't mean she's working for them
necessarily
okay you wanted to just be sure and i
appreciate it i didn't want to leave
anything up no stone unturned right
gotten that many times congressman
in any case
okay
please we heard even a worse joke from
the staff um
i guess my next i'd just like to make a
comment here and this is my own opinion
and as usual it's
somewhat
pointed let's say
um
[Music]
he i you know we've heard many in modern
day america decry quote moral relativism
which means that every opinion has equal
weight
even those that are morally
superior to others
i find this panel an example of that and
i'm saddened by it with no offense to
any members of the panel
we have two people here dr rice and dr
upshaw who are world experts renowned
throughout the world
in this subject
of cs tear gas
we have two people
dr euleg and mr marcus
very capable
people in their own right
who by their own admission are not
experts in this subject neither has
published a single article on the issue
of cs tear gas
and then we have conflicting opinions
and we find
that
many
first the way the panel is set up all
the opinions are equal the years of
study and research that dr rice and dr
upshaw did
is equated to the
in my judgment less studied opinions of
mr marcus and dr eulet
and then we find
very discouraging and disturbing without
putting a value on it that all those on
one side not all but most of those on
one side of the aisle choose to believe
mister marcus and dr eu ligand just
about everyone on our side chooses to
believe dr rice and dr upshaw
one of the staff people commented to me
on making that point that he loses faith
in the real fact-finding ability of
congress
because in my judgment and i think in
the judgment of most objective people
the opinions of rice and upshaw would
have more weight than those of marcus
and eulek on this subject
and
moral relativism
welcome to this hearing i yield my
remaining time to uh mr wise i thank the
gentleman i'm going to ask the panel of
following up on the gentleman's remarks
i'm going to ask the panel to respond
very quickly
uh dr stone you're a psychiatrist as i
understand it you are not a toxicologist
are you
no i'm not and you've published no
articles in that regard no mr marcus i
believe that already has been
established that you're not a
toxicologist is that correct oh yes i
have a phd in pharmacology i have an
inner ecologist as designated by the uh
united states environmental protection
fine and you published their
toxicologist for 21 years okay fine well
no and i'm happy to have you put that in
record in writing but what articles have
you published on cs gas oh i'm not an
expert in cs are you in the safe water
drinking act enforcement or in the safe
water i don't do any enforcement no but
well that's good because the people on
the other side are going to cut the
enforcement budget about a third and
you'll have a lot of time to re watch tv
uh in the clean water act uh dr i'm
charles dr rice you're both toxicologist
published uh i believe is that correct
i would like to incidentally ask if it's
not been asked that you submit your list
of publications for the record uh both
of you gentlemen uh
dr ulig
ua
toxicologist phd and cs i'm sorry is
your specialty in cs gas
no sir mr wise it is not and i believe
you opened your statement by saying i'm
not an expert on cs gas that is correct
thank you and mr parks you don't you've
never professed to be an expert in csgs
the chemical aspects that's correct so
the only two that are toxicologists
published uh
recognized as such are dr upshaw and dr
rice
and i thank the panel for making that
clear
you've yielded back your time
the only and the only thing i want to
say for the record is yielding back my
time the only two that are experts in
the area of cs gas which is the subject
before us the others are experts in
other areas but cs gas is the issue
before us uh and the only two that are
experts that are published and
recognized as such are dr rice and dr
upshaw thank you thank you very much
on the other side can i get mr wise's
time if he would you he wants to yield
to you certainly yes ma'am i'll yield to
doctor to mr jackson mr schumer schumer
would you mind dr rice dr abshaw
i started out with these questions
because we've all been talking about
children
and i don't think that there's any
distinction
on either side of the aisle of the
compassion and the feeling that you have
for the children that were lost
the african-americans that were lost
hispanics that were lost the asians that
were lost the anglos that were lost the
women that were lost and the children
that were lost and the men that were
lost again i asked you the question
about cs gas not cn gas with cs gas
if there were holes put in or doors
opened and we don't have all the facts
would the cs gas as you understand it
and your study
determined
immobilized
mothers with children or children such
that they could not find an exit to get
out which all of us prayed that they
would have been able to do can you tell
me that
the cs gas would not have immobilized
them and and my instincts would tell me
that mothers would pick up their
children and take them with them
dr rice please i would concur with that
view and have nothing else do you want
anything about suffocation
i think at the concentrations that were
likely in that building given the amount
that was put in over the time frame that
it was put in that uh starvation of air
was not a problem the concentration of
cs was not high enough to exclude air
from the building
thank you
thank you
you're recognized for five minutes i'm
going to
give my friend from maryland bob ehrlich
for 30 seconds i just feel compelled to
make a short statement with respect to
mr schumer's representations
as i said earlier i don't think anyone
here
is on anyone's side i don't choose to
believe or disbelieve anyone on this
panel
i thought it quite clear from the record
that i asked a very specific question
with respect to the appropriateness of
cs gas use
at waco under the particular
circumstances as described by witness by
witnesses before this committee i
appreciate the honest and forthright
answer from every witness claiming
regardless of your side thank you
thank you um
you're you're a chemist aren't you dr
yearly
yes sir that's
correct with fairly decent credentials
darn the final i guess that's your
interpretation i would no i'm i'm giving
you
you've got a patent right so you know
what you're talking about when it comes
to when it comes to chemistry right okay
thank you very much
um then in the line of chemistry uh you
stated in your opening that the children
could have died from asphyxiation from
cs gas could you expand on this point
and does cs have a different effect on
children than it does an adult so if you
want to mention toxidity as well if you
could be brief i appreciate it
[Laughter]
well i've already mentioned the
different
factors that come into play
and i would agree with the gentleman
from harvard
and his statements that they're in the
epa that there are differences in
children
i see the differences in my own
grandchildren
and that's you know where i come from
the other thing is
not so much of the
cs as opposed to the methylene chloride
and the agents that were used to inject
it methylene chloride and carbon dioxide
congress mozilla
those are the two agents that i don't
think anyone considered
when they injected the material into the
room and mrs reno was advised
once the fire started then of course you
have
quantities and i think you'll hear this
testimony
later on quantities of hydrogen cyanide
generated
mr
oh shoot
sorry my british cousins
indicated there was a particle size
that prevented the cs from settling out
and if you take a look at that particle
size that's a dust particle
and that could be an accelerant
for a fire
but when the cs does decompose it does
give
hydrogen cyanide carbon carbon monoxide
and carbon dioxide
but i don't think
in the autopsy that you can determine
how much hydrogen cyanide in the lungs
of somebody who's due to cs
and how much of it is due to
fire conditions thank you very much and
dr stone is an indiv independent
reviewer of this tragedy
and someone who worked for the attorney
general in this review
do you feel that she was misinformed on
the information was given to her on cs
gas
i don't think she was
properly informed about the risk of cs
gas to children which concerned her
yes i i would like to have the clerk
pass out copies the whole panel here on
uh the
crisis center log
at ruby ridge
and i'll just read it quickly august 22
1992
the log uh this is entering at 4 50 p.m
the live also stated that weather was a
major factor and the plan was scheduled
to commence late that afternoon but
might be pushed back because of weather
conditions concern was raised about the
deployment of gas into the residence
because of a high degree of risk to
small children a possibility that a
one-year-old baby was inside this was
the uh
these were the marshals and and the
actual marshals official of marshall's
log
and
larry potts was involved in ruby ridge
he was also involved at waco
he was involved with the decision there
and this is involved with the decision
at waco
can
and if i just i'm going to just give you
one
statement here
if you just take this information here
and again i believe it's fairly credible
and it would think i would think
that they would use this after having
gone through ruby ridge why wouldn't
they use the same background
for waco
just one question if if if one child
just one child was known to be under two
years old in the compound since we knew
that there were no gas masks anywhere
i mean
just take a picture of what we did as a
government to to all those children
to what what was hap what happened at
waco
was this a responsible act
was it something that we should do or
was this something that was an
irresponsible act i just like each of
you
just reading this based on what we know
what they knew then also
do you think it was responsible or
irresponsible to move forward let's
start with you dr stone
well i you know i don't want to uh uh
sort of
uh okay let me just say very quickly
that i i in my my view i i don't think
that it was responsible to plan to put
cs gas for 48 hours
into a building containing children i
cannot believe that my colleague who is
a physician from england
would suggest if he was asked that that
was an acceptable plan i cannot believe
it so
so that that's what i like to do is if
each of you are asked based on this
information or whatever else you know
would you move forward do you think
that's a response responsible plan or an
irresponsible i would not say it's
responsible thank you
marcus i just want to make a quick quick
observation the hemsworth report which
is what's relied upon by our british
cousins
is one of what i would consider um
precisely the same type of anecdotal
information uh that they deplore
they went around and talked to people
weeks and weeks after the fact
and i don't think it's
responsible to say we don't know for
sure it's going to hurt kids
well
if you don't know for sure don't take
the chance
that has always been my feeling as
somebody to try to protect children and
the american public if you don't know
don't take the chance
so i don't think it was responsible dr
rice
i think given the circumstances uh
as i said before if it's an operational
decision
uh
that
the actual risk of doing harm is
balanced by the benefit of going in then
i wouldn't have a problem so if if you
were that person that was making that
decision you would go ahead and do it if
that were my if those are my children in
there and they'd gone through all that
we understand that they'd gone through
uh during the siege then
i think if you could maintain the
concentration sufficient to have an
effect then yes i'd go ahead you'd go
ahead with your own children yes that's
amazing
dr upshaw
i i would agree with that furthermore i
would say that the information the hymns
of the report is not anecdotal
the committee investigated all the major
hospitals in in the area at the time and
a massive information was collected on
the consequences of that specific event
drilling
i don't feel it was responsible i
wouldn't be here now if that were the
case and
just to show that there isn't any
bipartisan here i happen to serve on the
democratic committee in probably the
only county in a republican state that
is democratic
so i don't play the party
politics here well i thank you for your
honesty and we would agree on our side
of the aisle as well we're just trying
to get at the truth uh mr parks
congressman i am not qualified to answer
that question and i
can't answer it
okay well i'll tell you what
i'm not a chemist and i don't have a lot
of papers published
but when i go home to my
town meetings up in new hampshire
i sure don't think i could justify our
government
putting in that gas with in those
amounts to women and children
that eventually ended up
in a tragedy of over 80 people i just
think i i it blows my mind and i hope we
get some answers in the next couple days
thank you all very much can i can i just
make a comment there that that surely
assumes that you accept that cs has
killed all these people what is the
evidence for that well i said i look
forward to the evidence
that we'll see in the next couple days
but i i i go according to
order in the house those are obviously
conclusions that different people can
draw mr hyde you're recognized for five
minutes
i thank the chair
i was watching the testimony in my
office
and i got a little concerned about
the
downgrading of those
people who are not published on cs
i understand there have been no tests
made
scientific tests of the effect of cs on
infants
and if that's so then it's pretty hard i
think to draw
scientific conclusions that they were
not harmful
but i did hear
that the use of cs could cause an infant
to vomit
and if you had an infant lying on its
back his or her back
and was in
infused with this gas
causing vomit
if that child couldn't turn over if the
mother wasn't right there
that child could strangle in its own
vomit is that not so
uh dr upshaw what you say is absolutely
correct what i'm questioning is where
the evidence is that the child will
vomit i've seen no evidence no evidence
that the child vomited i have not been
presented with any scientific evidence
that the child well after a fire it
might be awfully hard to find that
evidence that's very true but it doesn't
allow one to presume that the child is
vulnerable no but the likelihood that
this could happen would be a factor in
considering whether to shoot that stuff
in which is going to cause vomiting on
infants who cannot protect themselves
what i'm suggesting sir is that there is
no evidence that they vomit i'm
suggesting that this has been put
forward as a as as one of the signs what
is known in fact in humans and adult
humans is that the incidence of vomiting
is a very low incidence it's about once
we don't know about infants do
absolutely and i concur absolutely we
don't know about the enemy so where do
you give the benefit of the doubt if you
have a lot of infants in a place and you
really don't know you're shooting in the
dark aren't you as i said before in this
situation it's an operational decision
on balance of risk and benefit there is
risk there is undoubtedly risk risk to
the lives of infants
risk to all lives in all these
situations which particularly infants
who cannot protect themselves but what i
have said is there's no evidence to show
that children are any more sensitive
than adults
but when they vomit an adult might know
what to do
but an infant lying on his or her back
is helpless that is absolutely correct i
have children of my own so i know
precisely what you're talking about but
that's a risk then that was obviously
taken by somebody who said let's go
ahead anyway with it right
it's a risk and one has to judge the
risk and benefit in these situations
bearing in mind all the other things
that are happening to the children in
that compound now both of you are dr
rice yourself are scientists and your
experts in this field but experts are
reluctant
in in the pure science of the matter to
draw conclusions without some tests
without some data isn't that a
scientific principle the scientific
principle is that you seek the evidence
and make a judgment based on the
evidence there is no evidence as to the
effect of cs on infants there is no
evidence to show that infants form it
either and i'm suggesting that those
those those two pieces of information
are of equivalent value
in other words you you don't buy the the
the statement that this type of guess
which is supposed to be so irritating as
to drive people out of her out of a
building uh you're not ready to accept
the fact that this poses an extra hazard
on helpless infants who may be lying on
their back what i'm saying is there is a
hazard there is a risk whether you move
is a matter of judgment at the time as
to the relative benefits and the risks
right this is an operational decision
it's nothing to do with the toxic well
it is to do with it because sure it's an
operational decision that was a rather
cold term to describe
the possibility
indeed i would say the probability of
infants who cannot help themselves
coping
with a gas that is designed to irritate
and will result in in vomiting
i'm sorry sir but you keep saying it
will result in vomiting i cannot agree
with that well dr marcus i i see you've
been downgraded but indeed you are a
doctor
um
what what evidence have you got that
this would cause vomiting
i have
i have a paper here by
dr park and
giamano which
my colleagues are very much aware
and it talks about all these problems
that a uh this child doesn't exist
according to these people they this
child does never got hurt
this is the this is one of the objective
pieces of evidence we have
as opposed to nothing and it talks about
what happened to this poor young child
he was observed to have copious nasal
oral secretions sneezed off frequently
and he had upper airway obstruction
precisely what you're talking about
vomit that would be
aspirated giving upper airway
obstruction i think that's that's pretty
clear there better be no asthmatics in
there right
if there's asthmatics in there they're a
big problem they have really big
problems because the secretions they put
out
including the mucous secretions might
plug a lot of things up quickly
all right i thank you this is about a
clarification yes doctor nowhere in that
paper does it say the child vomited
well
uh
an excess of nasal secretions is not
informative
well
dr marcus says it it means vomiting and
and i don't know if any of you are
experts on vomiting um i might be
because i vomited a few times in my life
i am medically qualified sarah
there is no there is no way that you can
say that an excess of nasal secretions
is the same as vomiting and dr really
don't you think that this gas
might well result
in vomiting in an infant
from what we know
vomiting is certainly one of the effects
of cs okay the records that we have it
is not a particularly common one
it is not as common as the other
features that we've already described to
you but you don't know how it affects
infants do you because you've no tests
along those lines isn't that right
but are we suggesting we expose infants
to find out more about about this on
their
systems well i don't know it's probably
better than just saying that it was a
risk benefit and it was worth taking the
risk because obviously it didn't have a
controlled experiment where we
actually exposed children to cs well i
know you wouldn't want your children
exposed to cs not under those
circumstances no yeah i'm sure they
didn't want their children exposed
either i thank you and thank the
chairman mr chairman mrs slaughter has
come in and i will
recognize you mr slaughter for five
minutes thank you mr chairman i i want
to point out that the only infant that
i'm aware of on this list was one that
came out five months old a conversation
later with mrs the real mrs korres the
married mrs corey said that there were
20 children didn't mention infants and i
would like to yield the rest of my time
to mr wise
if you would yield a minute to mr
schumer
thank you
okay thank you i guess mr wise yelled it
to me i'd just like to make one point
and uh chairman hyde is correct henry if
i just might
chairman hyde and i have tremendous
respect for him is correct that if it
was using the gas
versus not using the gas and the
children would come out and be safe
i think everyone would agree
that we would not use the gas
what you had to weigh then
and what we all must still have to weigh
right now is that not using the gas
and letting the children stay in was
also had some risks
we can all debate what the percentage of
those risks were but as i said earlier
today or yesterday
if janet reno had said
don't use the gas let us let the
siege continue
and on day 54
david koresh decided to set fire to the
compound because he believed
armageddon was here or whatever else we
would all be screaming at janet reno for
being too cautious
too careful
that she should have gone in and perhaps
if you would have said what was the plan
of going and they'd say tear gas well
tear gas is a lot better than a
conflagration so the question is not
tear gas versus not tear gas the
question is the risks of tear gas versus
the risks of allowing koresh to remain
alone a very difficult question i yield
the remainder of my time i can't yield
it's mr wise's time
why don't you ask um
we have one request to make one request
yes sir thank you so much i i owe you
one uh dr marcus would you make
available to the committee that
monograph that you were uh
referring to
concerning the stopped up nasal passages
i'll add anything i'm necessary mr weiss
go ahead thank you no i'd rather be in
mr hyde's depth
uh i thank you uh let me get i haven't
agree with what mr schumer said or any
of the panel here experts on the impact
of armored vehicles uh crashing into and
having to tear down a house because you
weren't able to drive the people out is
anyone i'm asking a rhetorical question
anyone here an expert on the impact of
105 millimeter shells reigned into a
compound with women and children and
people inside i don't think so and so
it's a question of in relation to what
what were the options available now dr
upshaw uh since you missed dr mr hyde
was examining you uh is there any
evidence that the any of the children
were killed by c s gas
none that i've seen
and incidentally for the record let me
state that the
i was not referring necessarily to the
pictures that mr barr had i was
referring to the fact that the record
shows that at least one child was
stabbed
so there's no evidence that any child
was killed by cs gas was
going back to your former testimony uh
is it was it not your testimony that the
gas that was injected into that compound
was significantly below any lethal
content very much so and was it not also
your testimony that that would have been
reduced further in terms of lethal
nature uh by the fact that winds were
then blowing through uh that compound
due to the holes that have been knocked
into it any ventilation would reduce the
concentrations
um
we've also spoken a great deal about the
children and that's what is uppermost on
all of our minds particularly those all
of us
because i believe all of us are parents
but at the same time we had a number of
probably 50 at least armed men and women
inside that compound
and that was also part of the objective
was to be able to
get into that compound to get the
children out safely hopefully to get the
parents and adults out safely and not to
have anybody killed and we'd already had
four atf agents uh shot uh in just that
uh just that exercise and so all of that
given
you've talked about risk benefit do you
then think that the given what you know
to be the case both from your research
and what you've heard today did the risk
of injecting that gas
was it commensurate with the benefit
that was hoped to be obtained from what
i understand of the operational
decisions yes i think the risk was
appropriate i just say that to the other
side which is very hot on risk benefit
analysis uh right now in all of our
legislation
um uh
so
what we had then was a situation where
you had david koresh
uh
acknowledged child molester acknowledged
child abuser stockpiled automatic
weapons violation of federal law had
shot
his he and his followers had killed four
atf agents a number of children in in
degrading conditions and the decision
was made to introduce a gas which the
testimony of the only two that have
published and are
acknowledged as experts in the area of
cs gas
was that there was no evidence that any
child was killed by cs gas there was no
the the amount of gas introduced into
that compound was below any kind of
lethal content i think you said about
one tenth of what would be considered
lethal
dr upshaw and that that dosage was also
lessened by not only time but also by
the winds whether it was 25 knots or 35
miles per hour blowing through that
compound
that that was the what the fbi faced
that day
i
would yield back my time to miss
slaughter and thank the panel
well all right thank you very much um i
will uh take five minutes for myself
we'll conclude this panel tonight so we
won't have to come back here i'm sure
they'll be happy about that and so will
everyone else but i want to ask a couple
of quick questions first of all i want
to clarify something dr stone if you
could take the microphone over there
um in any way did your contact with fran
hega have any influence on your
testimony here tonight no i didn't think
it did um i also want to ask dr upshaw
and dr rice
if you had any relationship with the
justice department in giving advice
about the use of this gas before the
assault on the waco compound in april
19th of 93. nonetheless all right uh
also am i correct that the studies
you've done on the delivery method of
the cs gas
in your research was primarily through
the incendiary device
as opposed to the net the type of
delivery method they used in this
particular case the studies reported in
the hemsworth report are largely in
relation to the uh incendiary devices
yes but i should point out that the the
general consensus is that incendiary
devices are actually somewhat more toxic
than the methodology wasn't asking that
question at all i'm just suggesting from
what i've read in the justice
department's own report than the fbi
that the method of delivery was not the
standard one and not the one used
primarily by the british or in your
studies that's correct yes and i like to
make a couple of quick observations of
my own everybody else is making all
these observations tonight i think the
salient points here
is that the question of whether the
attorney general got the full advice
that she should have gotten and
perhaps whether she should have been
questioning it more than she did at the
time she made the judgment call
it seems to me pretty apparent that she
got some their advice we haven't heard
uh except from what dr stone has been
able to tell us because the only one on
the panel here who had any experience
with this and was involved in
overviewing the investigation
of the advice itself we're going to get
that testimony and all about what she
did get both from her and from others
coming up in future panels but based
upon what i've heard tonight
while there is certainly a conflicting
opinion i think that everybody here at
this panel is an expert
not necessarily having done the studies
that dr upshaw and dr rice did and their
peculiar conditions on cs gas but then
nobody else
i guess has really but we have an
imminent toxicologist from the
environmental protection agency who
spent a lot of time studying this and dr
marcus
who gave us what sounded to me a very
very good scientific opinions obviously
someone in conflict with the uh two
british we had dr euleg who is an
excellent uh chemist as far as i know no
one tested his credentials on that he
gave us excellent testimony mr parks
gave us the expert advice from a
military perspective with regard to the
conventions and dr stone who is a
harvard uh psychiatrist and a law
professor seemed a strange combination
and
was
a
person who was designated by the
attorney general to review all of these
matters has given his opinions to us
tonight and i might add that with the
exception of our two british guests who
were brought over here by the justice
department uh and of course not mr parks
who does not have a perspective on the
technical part of this the others
concluded that they would not have used
this gas under this circumstance with
children present for the potential
possibility of vomiting for the
potential possibility of a fixation and
we know that there were younger children
who did die of a fixation whether it was
from the fire or whether it was from the
cs gas i don't think we'll ever know or
whether they ever vomited we won't ever
know the problem is not for us to decide
that the problem is for us to decide
whether or not the judgments that were
being made at the time were being made
with the best evidence available whether
the people giving the advice to the
attorney general
exercised prudent judgment in deciding
what was to be given to her or not
whether she was given enough
and whether or not when she got it she
should have questioned and asked for
more under the circumstances those are
the questions and we don't have all of
those answers tonight but your input has
been very meaningful i want to thank you
in concluding i've got to ask one last
question of you dr stone you left a very
pregnant answer on the table you were
asked and then cut off about a question
related to your opinion as i presume as
a psychiatrist and as a reviewer of the
facts by the attorney general's
designation of the whole question of the
fbi's handling
of david koresh in terms of his
i guess his anti-social behavior would
you at least as we walk out of here
tonight uh clarify that so we don't have
telephone calls ringing off our phones
tomorrow that we didn't give you a
chance to respond to that
yes the question was whether he was an
anti-social personality disorder and
therefore he could be treated like an
ordinary criminal
as i i believe the fbi testified today
and as they said at the briefing
now there isn't any doubt that the i and
the other psychiatrist who reviewed this
information did not think that he was an
anti-social personality disorder he may
have had some other disorder but he
certainly was not that and it was a
mistake to think that he would react
like a common criminal would react to a
show of force
thank you very much i appreciate the
testimony that everybody gave you've
been well to endure us tonight
these uh hearings will then therefore be
recessed
until tomorrow morning you have a point
of order
procedurally i'm about to tell you when
tomorrow but go ahead all right i simply
want to ask in terms of the final focus
of these hearings meaning whether we
will have findings and then maybe
corrective actions i just want to be
assured i'm a new member
that out of the testimony that we've
gotten which has obviously been
conflicting
will we not have findings which may in
fact suggest uh that this cs gas did not
prohibit people from getting out that's
a finding but we also have jackson let
me talk about the procedure if i can cut
you off we've got to go vote and i don't
mean to reroute but the bottom line is
there will be a report issued by the
committee uh you will have an
opportunity you will have an opportunity
you will have an opportunity to uh
correct it or suggest corrections to it
but i think you will also have an
opportunity correct to issue minority
views if you disagree with it so those
opportunities ultimately at the end of
the day will be there for you this uh
joint subcommittee hearing on the waco
will commence tomorrow morning at 9 00
a.m not in this room but in 2141 next
door until then to 9 a.m tomorrow
morning these subcommittees are in
recess
tomorrow
this concludes day six of the waco
hearings tomorrow see the seventh day of
the hearings witnesses are former fbi
assistant director larry potts and fbi
gas experts
each weekday we'll re-air the house waco
hearings at 10 a.m eastern time here on
c-span
kid